Hello, welcome to my lecture.
Welcome to my lecture.
Today I am going to teach you how
to be a Muslim.
Allahumma alayhi wa sallam wa rahmati wa rahmati
wa rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati
wa rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati wa
rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati wa
rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati wa
rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati
wa rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati
wa rahmati wa rahmati wa rahmati and
then he said and
know that love of it that's blameworthy is
that which is solely for the benefit of
the nafs not in order that you're safe
or that others are safe from you In
other words, that it does not include love
of dunya, it does not include desiring it
so that others are not bothered by your
needs and you are safe from dependence upon
a servant and you are safe from depending
on Allah's servant or dependence on
Allah's
servant.
To the next world, this is why the
Islamic tradition said, the dunya is a bridge,
so pass over it to the next world
and don't try to build on it, don't
think you're going to be here forever.
And then he says, realize too that blameworthy
love of this world, indeed, love of this
world falls under the five categories of legal
rules.
Thus, its ruling is based on what it
helps one to achieve.
In other words, it goes under the five
categories, wajib, right?
So we should love those things in the
world that help us achieve akhara, like we
should love the Kaaba, it's in the world.
And we should love the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi
Wasallam, who's in the world, partly.
And we should love the people of Allah,
we should love the books of knowledge, we
should love things that are means, and we
should love our brothers and sisters who are
Muslim that help us in our deen, things
like that.
So all of that is wajib, mandu, there's
love that's mandu, and then love that's mobah,
like love of your children, love of your
wife, your husband, things like that.
And then love that's makru, and love that's
haram.
So he says, fahugo mamin ha'i'anatun
arashayin minin maharamat yahodilah.
So to love anything that helps you to
do something haram is prohibited.
And then he says, wahakada wadam muhamukayyadu, bi
'hayrimah aran najyati yorfidu.
So censoring the world is really only for
those things in it that do not help
towards salvation.
Waqaidu hukaidu nidam mehugbihah lidan aha khairul warah,
and sabihah.
Thus its reproach is restricted only to its
love for those reasons.
Indeed, the best of creation, SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam,
prohibited cursing the world.
There's a hadith in which the Prophet said,
lata subh ad dunya.
Don't curse the world, because Allah created the
world, and the world is a means to
achieving Allah.
Subh'ana wa ta'ala, knowledge of Allah.
And really dunya comes from a word, some
say it comes from dana'a, and some
say it comes from danu.
There's a difference of opinion.
But it's different from anam, which is, anam
is the world, anam.
This is the world, anam, like nature, all
these things.
Dunya is the hayat ad dunya.
It's the ephemeral aspect of the world.
It's all the hustle and bustle that people
get caught up in.
That is dunya, and that's what Allah warns
us about, hayat ad dunya, being deluded by
this ephemeral thing.
Whereas the anam that Allah has created, anam
comes from the root meaning is alama, which
is a sign.
So the anam is the greatest sign of
Allah.
So the cosmos in and of itself is
the greatest sign of Allah.
And that's why it's not something that we
despise or look down on.
We're not like traditional Christian doctrine, even though
they've been trying to get rid of it
for the last hundred years.
Their traditional doctrine is to condemn the world.
The world is evil, and the evilest thing
in the world is a woman.
I mean, that's traditional Christian doctrine.
And we don't say that.
We say, like Allah says, he created everything
in the world for you.
Some of them say to reflect on it,
to take you to Allah.
Some of them say to benefit from it
other way, to be the Khalifa, to guard
it, things like that.
So all those things are there.
Since things are only praised or blamed.
So things are praised or blamed on what
they result in, like either a cure or
a harm.
If something leads to a disease, it's blameworthy.
If it leads to a cure, it's praiseworthy.
And that's the way you should look at
things.
Anything that is obtained of the corporeal necessities
of being in the earth, in other words,
food, housing, shelter, all those things, those are
not considered dunya.
And in fact, even by sharia, the first
wife of a man is not considered dunya.
And if he marries for things like orphan
or to take care of a poor thing,
that is also not considered dunya.
If he marries a second wife or a
third or a fourth wife, simply for dunya
reasons, then it goes under that category, which
in that case it's still mobah.
It's permissible, but it doesn't have the same
category like this.
He's saying this is a good thing, hasan.
Things that get you wealth or get you
a good jaa.
Jaa has a name or a position.
And they say that having a good name
is good to help other people.
Not for its own sake, but actually to
help other people.
The ulama have disliked getting too much wealth
because of the danger of doing haram things.
In other words, the more wealth you acquire,
the higher the probability that you're doing things
that are displeasing to Allah.
And so most of the ulama consider it
makru, ik thought, arhaka mutta kathru.
You become entertained or engrossed in
amassing and vying for wealth.
So it's a dangerous thing.
And people get addicted to stock market.
They get addicted to these type of things.
It becomes an addiction.
Also, somebody who earns wealth, to say, look
at me, look how clever I am, look
how much money I have, look at all
this, man says, oh, look at all the
wealth I've consumed.
If you do it for those reasons, the
ulama reckoned it from the people who have
acquired enormities.
Muktasib al-qaba'iri means you've done a
kabirah, that that's a kabirah.
It's haram to do that.
And then he says, wahub bohul midhabim ala
mi'afali sabah bohut tama alfirayd al-ali.
Love of praise is another disease.
Love of being praised for what one has
not done, not accomplished is caused by desire
for other than the exalted.
So people who love to be praised for
other than what Allah subhana wa ta'ala
has praised them for.
And that's considered to be haram, to do
that.
It's a disease of the heart.
So you should only want to be praised
for what you've done, although some of them
say that you shouldn't really desire praise except
from Allah subhana wa ta'ala, although they
don't prohibit it.
In other words, it's not necessarily a bad
thing to like that people say, ah sinta,
and the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam did say
that to people.
And there's a difference between midah, you know,
midah, that's haram and midah that's permitted.
The midah that's haram is flattery.
And that's what the Prophet said, you know,
armulfi, would you have midah, armut torafi, would
you have midah and throw dirt in the
faces of flatterers.
It's people that are telling you how wonderful
you are.
And they don't, it's not true, or they
don't mean it.
And like the poets used to go to
the Khalifas and write these amazing poems, you
know.
Mutanabi has all these poems he wrote to
Sefid Dola and it's all just midah, you
know, it's telling him how wonderful he was.
So that's a bad type.
Whereas telling somebody genuinely, ah sinta, you did
a good job or something like that, that's
not prohibited.
And particularly in people that, you know, you're
not really worried about them becoming deluded about
themselves.
So, it's an encouragement, you know, because it's
part of thanking somebody, things like that.
And then he says, warasim b'chub b
'kazu'a'an'na'ama'an'ra'idika
rahasatah sin rasma.
And he says, sabahu wa tama'afi ra
'id al-ali.
Tama' is the reason people praise others and
also love to be praised, is they want
something from them, right?
So that's a disease.
If you want to be praised for what
you didn't do, it's really a tama.
Because, I mean, it's a pretty despicable thing
to, like, enjoy somebody telling you, you know,
you did a great job and you didn't
do anything.
And you know you didn't do anything.
That's a despicable thing.
You're saying, oh, thank you very much.
I'm really glad you appreciate the work.
And you didn't do any of it.
Which happens in universities, professors that have graduate
students do all their work and then they
get credit for it.
It also happens in many corporations where you
have a team and it's really, you know,
the manager didn't do anything.
He just assigned things and they did all
the work and then he takes all the
credit.
It's a very common thing in human, it's
obviously part of human nature because it was
recognized centuries ago by our scholars and also
by the Quran.
Allah says that they love to be praised
by what they didn't do.
So it's actually, you know, in the Quran.
And then he says envy.
I'm going to stop with envy because that's
a really long one because it's like a
major illness.
So we'll do envy and riya inshallah next
week.
We're inshallah going to continue on with matara.
This is the third meeting.
So we should get to fear and desire
of other than Allah.
I don't know if I'll be able to
do that because we still haven't finished the
others.
But you should have the latest version or
update of this.
And we ended on Hasad, right?
So Hasad is, yeah, this updated version here.
So the Arabic is not on that first
part because you already have it on the
other part.
But you can just make the changes as
necessary.
Hasad is probably one of the most serious
diseases.
Again, because you have a difference of opinion
about the diseases and the root disease, some
say Hasad is the root disease.
But again, I think it will always go
back to humah because desire, in Hasad there's
always desire.
So really it's going to go back to
humah.
Or habriyasa, like Ibn Ashraf says, but then
even Ibn Ashraf admits that the source of
all wrong is hubal ajila, which again, love
of the world is related to desire.
Hasad, according to the ulama, is the first
disease, it is the first manifestation of wrong
in the heavens.
So the first thing that Allah was disobeyed
within the heaven was Hasad.
Because Iblis, nothing prevented him from bowing down
except for Hasad.
And it's a Hasad that's called tazuz, which
he'll go into.
He couldn't stand that Adam and As-Sinnam
would have a higher position than him.
He couldn't stand that.
Or Hasad at-Takab-Buhr, it's related to
his own pride.
It's takbarah, he was arrogant and full of
pride.
Now there's a hadith in which the Prophet
SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said that Hasad will eat
good deeds like the fire eats wood.
Which is really important because if you've ever
seen fire eat dry wood, it should let
you know what happens to the Hasanat.
And so they say the Hasid, who is
the person who actually has envy, and his
object of envy is called masud, right?
And we should know this, the Hasid in
the verse of Quran that people should memorize,
wa hasidin idah hasad, right?
Wa hasidin idah hasad.
Hasid is shaytan, is al-hasid.
And so to have envy is to manifest
one of the attributes of shaytan.
And there's a hadith in which the Prophet
SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, kulu
vi nyamatin masud, every possessor
of a blessing, any blessing, is envy.
So there's always going to be somebody that
envies you if you have a blessing.
Two people, street sweepers, one of them has
a cart that he has to pull and
he's got all his brooms and everything on
it.
The other street sweeper has a donkey that
pulls his cart.
For you, totally insignificant.
For the one without the donkey, he looks
at the one with the donkey and he
envies him.
So it doesn't matter what level it's happening,
envy is a very strange thing and it
permeates human culture and society.
And it's also believed that envy has a
harm.
There's a madara related to envy, but it's
said that the one envying, his envy harms
him before it harms the object of his
envy.
So he's harmed by it faster than he
can harm the object of his envy.
Although the evil eye is generally related to
envy, it doesn't have to be.
Some people just have the eye.
It's some type of psychic power that some
people have.
So it doesn't have to be that they
envy, although it's dangerous.
Traditionally in a lot of Muslim cultures, a
first born male, they used to pierce their
ears and dress them as little girls for
the first five years.
And really, they did that.
It was very common.
I knew somebody's older man who had holes
in his ears and I asked him about
it and that's what happened.
So people were very fearful of these things.
Now, obviously in Western culture, most of this
stuff is seen now as kind of superstitious.
It's interesting that every culture has a concept
of the evil eye.
Every culture.
European cultures, I mean, invidious, which means to
envy, means to look with evil.
The evil eye is an evil glance.
The Chinese have an evil and they do
a lot of ritual to prevent the evil
eye from afflicting their houses.
You'll see mirrors on Chinese houses often and
it's to deflect the evil eye.
So it's a universal belief.
It's not limited to Islam.
And generally, when you have universal beliefs, there's
a foundation for it.
It's not an imaginary type thing.
Although, the anthropologist would say, you know, things
happen to people, right?
And they don't know why it happens so
the way that they explain it is things
like he got afflicted with the eye.
In other words, it becomes a kind of
easy way of explaining the inexplicable, right?
So you do get situations where people will
attribute something to the eye simply because they
can't, like somebody gets sick.
And you don't know why they, you know,
they're just sick and you look and all
these different, nobody can understand why.
They'll say, oh, it might be the eye.
So, there's a hadid al-Ainuhaq, the evil
eye is true.
And the Prophet, if you look at him,
he was somebody that was very much engaged
in getting rid of superstition, right?
I mean, when the moon eclipsed, the Arabs
believed that if a moon eclipsed, it meant
a great person died.
And it eclipsed the day that his son
died, Ibrahim, the moon eclipsed.
It was a perfect opportunity for somebody who
was a charlatan to get a lot of,
and people actually became Muslim that day because
they said, you know, the moon eclipsed for
his son.
He went out and announced to the people,
the moon is a sign of Allah, the
sun is a sign of Allah, and they
don't eclipse for anyone.
So, he dispelled that superstition.
So, part of his teaching was really to
dispel superstition.
So, when he said al-Ainuhaq and it's
a sahih hadid, he's telling us that there's
something real in the world called the evil
eye, and people should take it seriously.
It's not a joke.
And in English, you say, if looks could
kill, right?
People have a sense of when somebody's looking
at them, and there's psychic power with looks,
you know?
So, anyway, the hadith says that, that hasad
will eat yaqurul hasanat, kamma takurannar al-happab,
just like fire eats dry wood.
And the reason for that is, is because
when you have hasad, and he explains it
here, right?
He said, warsim bihub bikaz zawad en-nyama
an-gaidi kar hasad atah sin rasma.
Describe your desire for someone's loss of their
blessing as envy, and you'll have correctly described
it.
So, if you desire somebody to lose a
blessing that they have, that means that you're
envious.
It could be anything.
It could be a house, a car, a
job.
Somebody got a promotion over you, and you
wish they lose their job.
They do a bad job, so they get
fired, and you get the position, or just
so they get fired.
Somebody gets, you know, has a husband that
you envy, and you wish, you don't think
she deserves him, and you wish she got
lost her husband, or a wife, something like
that.
These type of things.
Envy is many, many variations of it, but
ultimately, it's the idea of loss of nirma.
And a nirma, which comes from an Arabic
word, nirima, which has to do with softness,
is the opposite of difficulty, softness.
So, nirma are things that make life easier,
is a nirma.
Now, obviously, there could be a nirma hidden
in a nirma, and a nirma hidden in
a nirma, and they say it's a blessing
in disguise.
In this culture, in English, we say, it's
a blessing in disguise.
In other words, you don't see the blessing,
but it's there.
Every cloud has a silver lining, these type
of things, indicate you have to be careful
with what's a blessing and what's not a
blessing.
So, a nirma is something that Allah gives,
and Allah's name is a munin.
He's the giver of nirma.
If Allah gives a person a blessing, and
you wish they lose that blessing, what you're
basically saying is, Allah was wrong to give
that blessing to that person.
In other words, you are judging Allah's wisdom
in placing a blessing with somebody else.
And one of my favorite stories is, and
some people have heard this, but Al-Asma
'i, he used to travel all these desert
camps to collect words and things.
And he was at one Bedouin's tent, and
the Bedouin, the women come in, serve, and
sit.
It's part of Bedouin culture then and now.
And this man had a very beautiful wife,
and he was incredibly ugly.
And when the man went out to sacrifice
the sheep for Al-Asma'i, he couldn't
resist saying to this woman, How did you
end up with this?
How did such a beautiful woman like you
end up with such an ugly man like
that?
And the woman said to Al-Asma'i,
and Al-Asma'i, he's relating the story,
so he's that type of person.
The woman said to him, tsukillah, have takwa
of Allah, fear of Allah.
She said, la'allahu ahsane idar abhi wana
jaza'uhu.
Maybe he did good things with his Lord,
and I am his reward.
Or maybe I did some bad things, and
he's my punishment.
So the point being, Al-Asma'i was
saying, Allah has a hikma, and you don't
know what the hikma is.
So you have to be very careful when
you are looking, what's that doing there, why
is that person with that person?
So Allah is Al-Munun, he's the giver
of blessing, and if you question the ni'ma,
then you're questioning the giver of the ni'ma.
And that's why Allah hates it, and that's
why Shaitan was disobedient to Allah.
And the difference between Shaitan and Adam, Alayhi
Salaam, is Adam, when he made his mistake,
he made toba, and the hasud doesn't make
toba.
The hasud is unable, because part of his
problem is qibr.
He doesn't feel somebody's worthy, and he's worthy,
that's takabur, I'm better than him, he doesn't
deserve what he has.
And that type of person, they can't make
toba, it's hard for them to admit they're
wrong, so they don't turn away from their
hasud.
They don't actually turn away from it.
So then he says, he
means by hasud that really, in other words,
if you were able, through some ruse, to
eliminate it yourself, you would do so.
You'd utilize that thing to eliminate the hasud.
What that means is, is that the shari
'a definition of hasud is, because there's a
hadith, la islam al mu'min min tara'a.
The mu'min will never be safe from three
things, and hasud is one of them.
One and piyyara are the other two, which
he'll get to.
Hasud is one of the things that no
mu'min will ever be safe from.
So the cure for it is la tabri.
The hadith says, if you have envy, don't
harm, don't oppress the person.
And this is why, as long as you
won't do something that causes that person to
lose the blessing, then it doesn't go under
the category of hasud that is harmful, in
other words, that eats your hasunat up.
The hasud that eats your hasunat up is
the hasud that you would actually do something,
if you were able to, to cause them
to lose that blessing, wa ra'ayal alibilah.
And then he says, amma'i dakyaanat makhavatu
samat, anha tasudu ka farasta dah hasud.
If your fear of Allah causes you not
to want to do that thing, in other
words, to harm the person, then that's not
hasud that's going to harm you.
But if you could, you would, that is
dangerous.
And then he said, fi'ma tara jafu jitat
islami min fadri lil jadadi wa rikrami, in
other words, that's what the imam al-hazadi
ar-bilma'anu said about hasud.
So that's his judgment, how he distinguished it.
That's where that's coming from.
And then he says, kala imam al-hazadi,
wa mankari hu hadta ka an, yam kotanaf
suhu lahubari amin, ada imalazimuhu ammadawah, fa amarum
bibilim mukfad al-hawah.
He says, imam al-hazadi said, if you
hate it so that you despise that part
of yourself that's causing you to envy, then
that means that you're not an envious person.
So hating the experience in yourself of envy
is a sign that you're not an envious
person.
And this again is recognizing that you have
a nafs and you have a ruah, which
are really the same thing.
But the nafs is the ruah that still
has the tarnish of this world.
It's not pure.
And so recognizing that in yourself, that things
like these things that occur to the heart,
those are parts of the taint or the
pollution as a result.
It's the rahm that has acquired or accumulated
over the heart as a result of wrong
actions and these things being in the world.
So if you detest it, then it's a
sign, in fact, that the ruah is a
higher force in you, this pure aspect of
yourself.
And then he said, as for the dawah,
he said, the dawah is amaron bibidi.
He always gives us two treatments.
One of them is the knowledge, because the
rahm, the rectification of the heart has to
come by two things.
So now he just told you what the
knowledge is.
You have to know that the way to
get rid of the hasad is not to
want to harm the person and to have
taqaw of Allah and to recognize what a
bad thing it is.
That's your knowledge base.
But now he's going to give you the
amad, right?
This is really important.
The first is not to follow what your
hawah desires.
And hawah is caprice, right?
Al hawah is caprice.
Hawah comes from a root word, which means
to fall, and it's also related to the
word wind, hawahun.
Because the nature of hawah, of passion, is
another translation.
The nature of passion is that it's like
a wind.
It calms, stirs things up, and then it
dies down.
When the wind comes, shakes the tree, does
all of its damage, and then it dies
down and goes away.
And the hawah is like that.
Sometimes it comes to the self, and sometimes
it leaves.
And if you follow the hawah, then you're
following whims, caprice.
You're not following the akhal, which is something
that's fabbits.
It's fixed.
It's not like the wind.
Haq is fabbit.
Ba'at is always something yazul, is something
that goes away.
If you look in the history of man,
you can see very clearly these false things
come, and then they go.
They come, and they go.
They come, and they go, right?
Whereas haq is something, it's fixed in that
everybody recognizes that it's true.
It doesn't matter where.
I mean, haq, in terms of its manifestation,
will manifest and remove.
But it's always recognized for what it is,
as haq, by the people of haq.
Whereas Ba'at is something, in one people,
it's one thing, and in another people, it's
another thing.
It just has no foundations.
So he's saying, don't follow your hawah.
And Ha'uya is the name of Jahannam.
Because Ha'uya takes you down into the
fire.
Ha'uya.
And your hawah is what takes you down
there.
Ummuhu Ha'uya.
The Ha'uya is the fire.
Jahannam.
So, when he says to do the opposite
of what your hawah says, now he's going
to give you an example.
Kannathirihi in Zana Durran.
Like benefiting him when it would seem to
be a good thing to harm him.
In other words, your hawah wants to cause
harm to him.
At that point, you do Mujahada.
And you actually benefit the person that you
have envy towards.
It's a really important thing here.
So if you have feeling envy towards a
person and you really want to harm them,
you do the opposite.
You give them a gift.
Right?
And that's going against the nafs, getting a
reward with Allah, but doing something else.
Or another thing he says, and I'll get
to what the other thing is doing.
Alayhi haythulaka damman zayyana.
Praise him when it would appear good to
you to say something bad about him.
So somebody who you have hazard for, somebody
mentions them in a gathering, and you feel
like saying, oh, you know what he did?
Right?
You want to say something that you actually
say something good about him.
And there's always something you can say about
somebody.
You know, I mean, Hitler, you could say,
you know, the guy really did what he
set out to do.
Whatever.
You can always find something good to say
about somebody.
Right?
You can.
And that's the thing.
So you choose, you know.
You choose.
And the thing to do is, you know,
if you want to say something bad about
him, say something good about him.
Or her.
Now, what that will do, one of the
things it will do, is if you do
that to the person who you have hazard
for, it will make cause their heart to
incline towards you.
As their heart inclines towards you.
Now, obviously, this isn't always true.
In other words, if they have hazard for
you, which is very possible, and they're not
working on themselves, and they haven't studied Mahatat
al-Quru, then you can get in trouble.
Right?
Because there are some people out of that.
But generally good people, which those are the
people that we want to not envy and
beyond, because he'll get to that it's permissible
to envy bad people.
Generally, good people are inclined to love those
who show good to them.
So, if you do good for those, to
that person, they will tend to want to
do good to you.
And if they do, it changes your heart.
So, what Sidi Ahmadzaroq says is, if you
actually apply this, you will see a transformation
in their heart and in your heart.
And then he says, and then another theoretically
is to know, not only you should know,
this harms the hazard, the one envying is
harmed by this.
In this world, he's always anxious and upset,
the fact that, why did he get that
promotion?
He shouldn't have got that promotion.
He goes home and complains to his wife
for two hours about so-and-so, got
the job that he should, the promotion he
should have got.
In other words, he becomes obsessed with the
object of his envy.
And it's a disease in the heart that
causes him to have rum.
He actually has this, this feeling of sadness.
And it's a result, it's meaningless.
It has absolutely no meaning whatsoever.
It's a completely insane act to envy another
person.
It's a completely insane act.
And the Arabs have a really powerful problem,
which al-Hasud, la-Yasud, the one who
envies can't get into a position of leadership.
In other words, the fact that you have
this resentment is actually prevents you from ever
accomplishing anything in the world.
People that, you know, the end here, see
a person who doesn't have envy, if he
sees somebody doing something, he'll set out, it
might motivate him to go out and do
it himself.
But he's not going to sit there, he's
not going to sit there and, and why
is, why is that happening here?
Why isn't this happening?
He just goes out and does it for
himself.
So the one, you know, the one who
envies will, will never have siyada.
And one of the interesting things about the
Muslim world now is that we're filled with
envy.
You know, the Muslim, when they look at
the Europeans and the Americans, even though a
lot of them use all this Islamic rhetoric
to talk about how horrible all these Europeans
and kuffar and this and that, the real
bottom line is they have dunya and we
don't.
Seriously, for a lot of these Muslims, they
have dunya and we don't.
And so there's Hasud.
Or, for instance, like the Arabians who got
all the oil, you have all these people
in other Arab countries or some other countries
always talking about these terrible Gulf Arabs.
How, you know, they just waste all the
Muslim money.
It belongs to us.
Well, what the question to ask is, if
oil was discovered in Jordan, would all the
Jordanians be oleah, giving out, fisibililah, all over
the, no, it's a question for them to
ask.
In other words, you can look and say
how terrible the Gulf Arabs are because they're
wasting all the money of the Muslim.
That's easy when you don't have any money.
But what do you do when suddenly you've
got all the dunya?
Right?
Well, I mean, that's the question.
So, and there's a strong case that they're
probably giving a lot more money than most
of the other people would be doing because
they're extremely generous by their nature.
I mean, it's part of the traditional desert
Arab culture.
And there are a lot of really generous
people there.
So the point is, you can look at
them, but really, is your anger, is it
from resentment and hassad, or is it really
being stimulated by an altruistic desire for wealth
to be used properly?
That's a question.
Now, you can look also at the communist
revolution.
Communism is pure hassad.
Marx is filled with resentment.
If you read his book, you know, it's
filled with resentment.
It's all about getting what really belongs to
us from the rich people.
It's all turning, you know, and it's all
based on this resentment.
Now, obviously, rich people like to hear that
because they can say, yeah, exactly.
You know, it's the, you know, it's just,
they're just envious of us.
They just want our money.
But from the Sharia point of view, both
have an obligation.
The obligation of the poor people is not
to envy the rich people.
And the obligation of the rich people is
not to belittle the poor people.
So it goes both ways.
But because one of them's not fulfilling their
obligation, doesn't mean that you become a communist
to overthrow the status quo.
I mean, that's the point.
And nowhere in Islam does it say that
you have to remain impoverished.
You can go out and earn money.
But it's difficult, you know, to have accumulations
of wealth tend to be traditionally in families.
And it's still true to this day, you
know, that even though America, quote unquote, land
of opportunity, you can come here, work 80
hour weeks, and start your grocery store, your
this or that, and you work hard enough
and you'll get the dunya.
We already covered that in that section on
not wanting to do that.
Because right when you get it all, you
drop dead.
But the point being is that still most
money, right, in fact, is really interesting in
this country, you know, over 90% of
the wealth is in the hands of like
less than 3% of the population.
So people that you think are rich, like
a millionaire, if he's got two, three, four
million dollars, that's not real wealth.
I mean, for us, obviously it is.
But in terms of who's got money in
this country, that's not real wealth.
That's peanuts.
And even Bill Gates, they did a thing
on Bill Gates.
Bill Gates is still only worth about 30
% of what Rockefeller is worth, for instance,
right?
So he's an upstart, you know, even though...
So the point is that money is a
doula, bain al-arniya, which one of the
reasons why Allah did something in the Quran,
which in terms of human history is extremely
radical.
The inheritance laws in Islam are designed to
break monopolies.
You see, if you look at the Sharia,
it's designed to spread the wealth out.
In traditional cultures, the progenitor, the firstborn, all
the money would go to the firstborn.
And in English culture, people were out of
their houses, right?
I mean, if women didn't...
If they didn't have a male protector, they
lost their houses, which is one of Jane
Austen's themes, right, in her stories of women
just literally losing everything because there wasn't a
husband.
I mean, she saw it as an injustice.
Even though she's a comic writer, she saw
it as a type of injustice to women.
In fact, there's no male, and they lose
everything the moment the father drops dead because
some uncle or distant cousin who's a male
gets to inherit all the money because the
women don't inherit it.
In Islam, Allah broke that.
So a woman would actually suddenly get money.
Now, what did that do?
If a woman marries outside of the family,
it takes money outside of the family, which
was one of the reasons why oftentimes wealthy
families like to marry within the family to
try to maintain it somewhat.
But you can see that in Islam.
There really is an attempt to break down
that type of monopoly in wealth, which once
it occurs, you have a doula, what the
Quran calls a doula, wealth only revolves around
the rich people and that will cause a
type of resentment, right?
So in Islam, traditionally, there was always a
very strong middle class.
And where you have a strong middle class,
you're going to have a lot less social
pressure than where you have an extremely wealthy
class of say, you know, maybe 10%
with all the wealth and then 90%
impoverished.
That creates a massive tension.
Whereas if you have, you know, 40 to
60% in the middle somewhere, right, it
enables one, the people down here, to be
able to, you know, move into that middle
class because it's not so far off.
Whereas in this type situation, the gap is
so great, it creates resentment and hassle.
And so poor people begin to envy the
rich people.
And then you're ripe for, you know, the
communist manifesto and this type of thing.
And look how many people died.
I mean, all those people that died, you
know, millions of people because of communist revolution
and it's all about resentment.
And the other interesting thing about communism, nowhere
is Marx critical of industrialization and massification.
He never questions, you know, the whole technological
society and where it was headed.
And Baldrallard wrote a really interesting book criticizing
that aspect of communist critique that they never
deal with, you know, factories.
And, you know, he's all just saying, well,
let's make the factories, the people working in
them own the factories.
But is factory life, do we really want
people to be working like that and those,
you know, that type thing?
That's never questioned.
So that's a really important thing to reflect
on, people, about this idea of resentment and
a lot of what people actually think is
righteous indignation is nothing other than Hasid, envy
and resentment, really.
Seen it a lot.
And one of the things that you saw
happen in the Muslim world is a lot
of the communists, interestingly enough, in the 70s,
in the 80s became Islamists, right?
And changed all the vocabulary, right?
And suddenly started talking about the social justice
of Islam as opposed to the social justice
of communism.
And so you just, Islam becomes a vehicle,
again, to realize your own petty dunya aspirations,
right?
People have to be really wary of that
type of Islam being used as a vehicle
for anger that is not rooted in anger
for the sake of Allah.
It's rooted in anger simply because one is
dissatisfied with one's worldly position, right?
And that's a really tricky one to tell
you.
And then he says also, He says, also
think about this.
It doesn't benefit your one iota to have
envy, nor does it cause the one you're
envying.
He's not going to lose that niqmah because
you're envious of it.
Allah gave it to him, Allah will take
it away.
It's not you that's going to do anything.
So it's really a waste of time.
Now he goes into the asbab, which is
really important here because the asbab, if you
understand the causes, you can understand, you know,
one, whether you've got it and two, how
to get rid of it.
The first thing he mentions is adawa.
Somebody doesn't, it's your enemy.
And so like America, there's a lot of
places that America is the enemy, so hassad,
right?
It becomes hassad.
And the really interesting thing about all these,
a lot of these anti-American people, they're
obsessed with American culture, right?
So the guy hijacking the plane has Nike
tennis shoes and he's got his t-shirt
with Mickey Mouse on it and, you know,
orders hamburgers and milkshakes.
I don't know, but I mean, you see
it.
American culture is just everywhere.
It's just rapidly globalizing, right?
Now, why is it that people in Beijing
go to a McDonald's?
Why?
I don't understand, but they do.
And so, you know, the fact that a
lot of people are anti-American, again, one
has to question, what are they anti-American
about?
Is it because they're just envious of the
fact that America happens to be the dunyui
most powerful country on the earth?
Americans have the dunyui highest standard of living,
blah, blah, blah, whatever it is.
Is that the reason?
Or is it genuinely do they see that
this is unfair?
You know, this is an oppressive society that's
doing harm.
So, again, people have to be really careful
about what their intentions are and where they
are.
So, Adawa is a cause of hassad.
You might not like somebody that you're working
with in the office, so when good things
happen to him, you get angry.
You get, there's hassad.
You can just cause Adawa.
Very common.
Another one, tahubub.
Tahubub is a type of hassad.
There's almost an element of humor in it,
but it can get quite vicious.
And tahubub relates to the object.
You have two people or more, and they
all have the same object of desire, like
parents, children, siblings, are fighting for parental love.
Mother only has a limited amount of time
in the day.
She's got five children.
So, those children are vying for her attention.
And there's a book, although it's written by,
I think, Solomon called Born to Rebel, which
is all about birth orders.
He did this massive statistical study about birth
order, and he's convinced that people's personalities are
a direct result of all this envy they
had in trying to get their parents.
And with massive sweeping theories, you always have
to be careful, but obviously there's an element
of truth in that.
So, birth order is very interesting, because first
-borns tend to be much less rebellious, according
to his research, than later-borns.
In fact, most of the real rebellious type
people in the history, in social history, have
been later-borns, not first-borns.
And he said it has to do with
the fact that they see the first-born,
he's got all the perks, and so they
want to rebel against that kind of status
quo.
And first-borns historically tend to be the
ones that are always supporting the status quo
and don't want.
It's an interesting study.
So, that's the hubbub.
Another one is a teacher.
People, students that vie for the teachers, like
teacher's pets type people, that want, and they
have this envy.
Another one is, it's called the da'udarayr,
the disease of second wives, right?
Hasr.
Because, you know, if there's more than one
wife in the situation, obviously there's one husband.
Husbands' times tend to be limited, and so
they're vying.
And that's why sharia is so adamant about
being fair to the wife.
If you give one to one, you have
to give one to the other.
Have to.
That is a given.
And the knights are the same, I think,
for that reason.
Now, obviously, the word in Arabic for second
wife is dara, sometimes mispronounced dura, but it's
actually a dara.
Dara means harm, right?
That's what it means.
It means harm.
So, obviously, I don't know if the first
wife named the second wife dara or not,
but it indicates that the Arabs understood something
about the psychology of multiple marriages and that
the second wife will bring in a type
of dara to the first wife.
So, that does happen.
And you can get that vying for things.
So, that's tahabur.
And then takabur is arrogance.
That causes envy.
If you see somebody getting ahead of you
and you're arrogant, you see, he doesn't deserve
that.
I'm better than him.
That's takabur.
He should have got that promotion.
And this is something that some of the
Arabs had in, like al-Waleed ibn al
-Mukhayrah, Abu Jahal, you know.
They had that against the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi
Wasallam.
They thought themselves, he's Yateem al-Bani Hashem.
He's the orphan of Bani Hashem.
He's Ibn al-Abi Qabshah.
That's what they called him.
Abi Qabshah is his father by wet nursing.
So, they just saw, he doesn't deserve this
ni'ana of being spoken to from the
heavens.
We deserve it more than he does.
So, that's takabur, which is, I think, pretty
obvious.
Ta'azuz is less so than takabur.
Ta'azuz has to do with a person
wanting the status quo.
In other words, he doesn't mind feeling the
same as the other person.
As long as we have the same things,
it's okay.
But suddenly, you get the job promotion, and
I didn't.
And then, my question is, I start saying,
he's going to start looking down on me.
Right?
So, the dynamic changes.
So, Ta'azuz is, I'm trying to maintain
my izah.
So, really, it's related to a poor self
-esteem, and I think that's how I translate
it.
Poor self-worth.
Ta'azuz is an attempt to re-establish
an equilibrium, because you're feeling that your self
-worth is compromised by the fact that another
person has more than you do.
And so, that's also a cause of hasad.
And you can see that also in the
first Muslims who, when they, for instance, they
said, lola nuzirahad al quran al-rajirim.
Right?
Minar qariyatani al-im.
Had this quran only been revealed to a
man from one of the two big cities
who was great, a great man.
In other words, if it would have been
revealed to Walid ibn Mureyra, we wouldn't mind
bowing our heads to him and admitting that,
you know, you're the prophet.
But this is Yateen Beni Hashem.
How can he be over us?
In other words, we want him to stay
the same as us.
So, this is something that happened, afflicted those
first Arabs.
And also those who said, this is just
hada basharu, mithilana.
Right?
This is just a man like us.
How can he be a prophet and we're
not prophets?
In other words, we don't like this idea
of somebody who's a common man.
If it's a king, that's all right.
We can deal with that because the king's
better than us.
We know that.
But he's my next door neighbor.
Right?
He shouldn't have anything better than me.
So, it's that idea there.
And also, you find that Faraon says, actually
that's more takabur.
But he says about Musa, you know, that
how can a prophet come and his people
are our slaves, you know, looking down on
them.
So, these are all reasons why people reject
the truth.
And Ta'ajob has to do with, you
just can't believe it.
It's more, you know, I can't believe.
It's not takabur.
It's not ta'azos.
It's just type of, you know, this can't
be happening.
Right?
This person couldn't have won the jackpot.
I've known him all my life.
This can't be happening.
So, it's a hasa that's really related to
a type of disbelief, you know, in somebody
getting a blessing that you just can't believe
that he has that blessing.
It doesn't make any sense.
And then also, hubrriyasa, love of leadership, always
wanting to maintain one's position of authority.
Sometimes hubrriyasa will lead a person to not
want somebody to get a blessing just so
they can maintain the position over them of
authority, which is similar to takabur, but different
in a sense because he does have a
position of leadership or he desires to have
it over that person and by them getting
some type of blessing, it's going to lead
to changing that equilibrium or creating a disequilibrium
there.
So, and then shuhunhati, shuh is covetousness.
So, that's also a cause of envy, just
pure shuh.
Like you see somebody has something, you just
have a shahiya, you're covetous of it, you
want it.
And that's a big disease.
Which Allah says, waminyukashuhanapsifa wurekumunu fahbihun, those who
are saved from their shuh.
Now, another thing, one of the concepts that
Imam al-Ghazadi mentions often is because these
diseases, in fact, are part of our nature,
the process is to transform them and make
them something beneficial to you.
For instance, Native Americans, some of the Native
American tribes in this country used to name
their children names that had disabilities, right?
Like lame deer.
They would give it a name that had
a disability.
And the reason for that was that they
noticed that animals that had disabilities tended to
overcompensate.
And it would make them more clever than
the other.
They'd have to be more aware.
And so there's an idea of getting your
disability to become an advantage.
And this is what really successful people in
dunyawy terms tend to do.
And what Imam al-Ghazadi is saying is,
this is what the ukhrawi people need to
do with these disadvantages aspects of their selves,
to turn them into advantages.
So, for instance, the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
said, la hasada il lafiyat an attain.
There's no envy except in two people, Rajulin,
Utsiya, Malin.
He was given wealth for sallbatahu alal khayri.
He used his wealth for good.
Right?
And in the rihwah, it says that, hiyun
fiqhul an alayluat raffan nahar.
You know, he's giving it out by night
and by day.
So that's a good reason to envy that
person.
Not that you want him to lose the
envy, to lose the nama, but that you
actually want to be like him to have
wealth so that you can also give out.
And that is called in Arabic, rhipa, which
is different from hasad.
Rhipa is good envy.
It's a positive envy.
You're envying the person.
You don't want them to lose their nama.
You want them to keep their nama.
But you wish that you had what they
had.
And the other person is, Rajulin, Utsiya, hikma.
He was given hikma, wisdom, fayu alimu hanaas.
So he teaches that wisdom to people.
And so those two people, in other words,
what we're being told is, don't envy people
over petty, trivial things like dunya.
It's not worth it.
Envy people for things that are high things,
like akhira.
And then what that will do is it
will make you set out to achieve what
they've achieved.
All right?
So...
And then he says about...
Those are the causes.
And then he says...
As for a blessing that a kafir has,
a non-Muslim or a bad Muslim, fajr.
Somebody who's fajr.
They have fujoor.
A profligate.
Somebody who does kabaya.
A fajr or somebody who does kabaya openly.
As for a fajr, he says...
The disease of second wives is permissible in
this case.
I'm going to use the second wife because
it works with the rhyme.
And also I think it indicates that that's,
you know, it's a natural type of hassad.
You know, it's a good thing to have
hassad towards non-Muslims and...
But obviously that has to be because they're
using it for bad things.
Do you see the difference?
In other words, what I was saying earlier
about having envy towards non-Muslims just because
they have dunya and you don't.
That's not a good reason.
The reason that he's saying it's a good
thing to do is because they have dunya
that they're using for harm.
They're harming people with it and they're using
it to oppress.
And in that case it's justifiable.
It's permissible.
And he says...
And then he says...
Blameworthy modesty.
Modesty is a good thing.
It's virtuous.
Al-hayyāʿu min an-īmān.
The hadī says al-hayyāʿu min an-īmān.
And hayā is from imān.
So this hayā, which is called al-hayyāʿu,
the mean, blameworthy.
This is...
The blameworthy modesty is a modesty that prevents
you from making inkār of mūnkār when you
see it.
So you see somebody doing something wrong and
you really should say something, but you're too
shy.
You're too shy.
Like a child...
An adult child with the parents.
There's a type of modesty because they're my
parents.
I can't say anything to them.
A mūnkār is a mūnkār, whether it's the
parents or anybody else, if it genuinely is
a mūnkār.
Now, just to say a few things about
mūnkār.
There's a condition about mūnkār.
One, a mūnkār has to be mūjmaʿalei, in
order to make inkār of it.
It has to be agreed upon.
You can't make mūnkār of something that's called
mukterefihi, which means there's difference of opinion about
it.
So whenever there's difference of opinion, you have
to be very careful about mūnkār, because technically
the mūnkār of one scholar might not be
the mūnkār of another scholar.
And unless it's absolutely agreed upon that it's
a mūnkār, then you can't make inkār of
it.
And they said about Imam al-Maziri, he
was so knowledgeable that he rarely made inkār
of anybody, because he could always find a
dealil for, a proof for their action somewhere.
And that's a really important thing to know
now, just because there's so much, Muslims make
so much inkār of each other.
There's this impulse now, just everybody attacks everybody
else.
So, blameworthy modesty is something where you don't
make inkār where you should, or to ask
a question about the deen.
That's blameworthy modesty, and that's why I say
that to Aisha al-Dilam has said that
the best women were the women of the
almsar, because modesty did not prevent them from
learning the deen.
So she was praising them, saying that even
though there's things that people would be modest
about, it didn't stop them.
Like the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam, who somebody
came to him, a woman asking about the
period, and he was explaining to her, and
she kept asking, and finally he just asked
Aisha to show her what to do, because
it was embarrassing for him.
And Aisha could answer the question, because she
was pakīhā.
But the point is that that woman wanted
to know, and even some of the women,
they used to send in a little box
the cloth from their period to ask the
hukam from Aisha about the color.
That was like asking to make sure they
understood when the hayith ended and when it
started.
So that's obviously most women, they would not
feel comfortable with that at all, because they're
modest about it.
But the point is that those women were
so bent on doing what Allah or so
straight about doing what Allah told them to
do that their modesty didn't prevent them from
doing those things.
And that would tend to be more with
women than with men, but it applies to
both, because there are some men that are
extremely modest, so they don't ask questions.
And then he said, Amma hayah ukharimin kamājara,
lirmus pafa is zaynaban takam mara.
As for the hayah of generosity, just as
it occurred with muspafas allāh islam when he
married zaynab, takam mara means, you know, to
spend the night zaynab, the first night of
their marriage.
What happened was the Prophet said, He said,
Marry zaynab rādīla anha.
And he invited people over for a walima,
a wedding ceremony, and they came, and then
they didn't leave.
Three of them stayed behind, and the Prophet,
being his generous he was, he sat with
them, but he just got married, and it's
his wedding night, right?
And so he's waiting for them to leave,
and they want to be with the Prophet
SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam.
They're enjoying the company, and so they didn't
leave.
And so he got up, left the room
to kind of give them the idea, and
then he came back, and they were still
there, so he sat down, and then he
finally left again.
And then the ayah revealed, you know, to
leave the Prophet when you finished your business,
to leave, you know, to go, and they
thought, I'm such a good old, when you
finish eating, go, move along.
And so that type of modesty is not
blameworthy, because there's no haukam sharai, and it's
out of his karam that he didn't say,
you know, it's my wedding night, can you
please go now?
It was out of his karam, SallAllahu Alaihi
Wasallam, that he didn't say that.
I mean, there would be some people that
would, you know, they wouldn't have any problem
with that at all.
But he was so generous that it wasn't
in his nature to do that, and so
he's saying that is not a, that's not
a blameworthy.
Wa ashwah ar-qallamun al-waleemati, he fed
them, wa kharaju an-hussi wa tharathati, and
they left except for three.
Labu wala mi'atmor bi'il pe'lakhi,
fa'u wamun mahasun al-akhlaki.
So they stayed, and he didn't tell them
to leave, and so that's from good character.
That's not blameworthy.
And then he said, lokana rajlan, that's for
the line of poetry, kana rajlan swariha, and
it's a way of saying rajul.
Had, and it comes from a hadith, lokana
rahaya o rajulan, lakana rajulan swarihan.
If, if modesty had been a man, he
would have been a righteous man.
So it's, it's a hadith of the Prophet
explaining that modesty is, is a very, very
high thing.
Now he's talking about the heart's engagement in
matters that do not concern it.
So he's talking about ar-khold.
Khold al-khald is the movement of the
heart, and basically the heart, he'll, he'll go
into it later about, I think it's, I
hope we get to that.
I think we'll get to it.
But he goes into great detail about the,
the types of thoughts and things like that.
And so what he's saying here is that,
Khold, if you have the heart moving or
reflecting in things that are prohibited, then it's
prohibited.
But that is also, it's what, it's what
they call tafakkur, or takhaion, not tafakkur, takhaion.
Tafakkur is when you think about maqulat and
takhaol is when you think about mahsuzat, sensory
things.
So he says there that, al-kholdu hima
raisa yaaniinama yahram wahaythukana fima harama, if you're
thinking about something that is haram, then it's
haram to think about that thing.
And then he gives you an example, kebfikri
hima hasan al-ajanavi, like reflecting on the
beauty, fantasizing about the beautiful qualities of those
unrelated to one by marriage, from male or
female.
So thinking about things that one shouldn't be
thinking about is considered prohibited.
And also, including that would be weaknesses or
faults of Muslims, whether they are absent or
present.
So actually reflecting on the faults of Muslims.
Right?
And you shouldn't even be doing that.
And that's why there's a hadiqubalim inshagarahu agua
an'ayyubiraylihi.
There's a tree in paradise for the one
who's preoccupied with his own faults over the
faults of others.
His own preoccupation causes him to forget the
And the older you get, the more serious
you should take that.
You know, really.
And it's just life's too short to be.
Everybody's got faults.
And if you start thinking about other people's
faults, you're just a fool.
The point is, is to get rid of
your own.
And also, I put in there, because it's
important, but it's in the commentary, also reflecting
on the nature of Allah's essence.
The that of Allah is haram.
You can't think about the that of Allah,
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
I'm going to inshallah go till 2.30
and then we can pray.
The next one, wa asuru khafir fakari su
avanni bihi ta'ala wa dawafir husni wa
anmi annamara dehila yapel wa annamara tursakahulaka yasool.
Alsuru khafir fakari is, what he's saying is,
the origin of fear of poverty is a
bad opinion of Allah.
So, fear of poverty is one of the
diseases of the heart and Shaitan in the
Quran, Allah tells us that he promises you,
ya idukum al-fakari, he promises you that
you're going to lose your money.
That's something that Shaitan does.
He promises you that you're going to lose
your wealth.
And so, fear, and this is going on
right now, this is a time of real
khof al-fakar, because there's all this uncertainty
in the dunya right now.
You're having collapses all over the world and
the Americans are obviously getting very concerned and
stock market and people's portfolios are getting thinner
and all the same.
And the thing about it is, fakar, real
fakar, these people don't know, they don't have
a clue what fakar is.
I mean, really, people don't have a clue
what fakar is.
I mean, you want to see poverty, you
have to, you know, you go to somewhere
like India, you know, go somewhere like West
Africa, go somewhere like, you know, now, Kosovo
and places like that, and there you'll see
real poverty.
People don't know what poverty is.
So, fear of poverty is a bad opinion
of Allah, because Allah promised to provide for
you.
Whoever has taqwa of Allah, Allah promised, that's
a Jumla shartiya.
In Arabic language, that's called a conditional sentence.
If you do this, I'll do this.
And the condition is, if you have taqwa,
I'll provide for you.
That's a promise from Allah, Subh'anaHu Wa
Ta-A'la.
If you have taqwa, I'll provide for you,
and I'll do it from even where you
wouldn't think it was coming.
In other words, it won't be from the
things that you wear, you expect it, your
job, your monthly salary, whatever.
Allah can provide you from places that you
would never expect, but it's on the condition
of taqwa.
If you don't have taqwa, then Allah is
not obligated to take care of you.
If you're not doing what He asked of
you as a condition for walking on the
earth with dignity, because if you don't do
what He said, you're going to walk on
the earth in humiliation.
Especially the Muslims, because we should always remember
that the dunya is the paradise of the
non-Muslims.
So if they have their good now, you
should be, you know, this is all they're
getting.
You know, this is all they're getting.
Let them enjoy it.
Seriously, think about that.
This is all they're getting.
And this is what, there are different people
it's related to.
I've seen it related to two different people.
But the meaning of the story is sound
anyway.
There was a Jewish man who was an
oil, he used to sell oil.
And he would heat up oil as well
and sell hot oil.
And he was covered in the oil and
his clothes were dirty.
And he was a poor man in Cairo.
And one day this item, very famous, wealthy
item came out.
He had a white horse came out.
And this Jewish man came out to the
horse and said to him, do you relate
a hadith that says that this world is
the paradise of the disbeliever and the prison
of the believer?
And he said yes.
And he said, then I have a question
for you.
What kind of paradise am I in?
And what kind of prison are you in?
And so they say he looked up and
then he looked down.
And then he said to him, when I
contemplate what is waiting for you because of
your disbelief in the next world, I can
only assume that you're in paradise now.
And when I contemplate on what Allah has
prepared for me, for my belief in the
next world, I can only see this as
a prison.
And as the story goes, he said, a
shadow in Allah.
But the point is, this is all relative.
Poverty is a relative state.
And your fear of poverty, it's also a
foolish thing because what benefit is it?
American humorist Mark Twain said, most of my
problems I never actually saw them.
Right?
In other words, you've got all these concerns
that you think about and you never actually
see them.
They're just in your head.
And so that's part of the thing about
having fear of poverty.
It just ends up in your head.
And if you're impoverished, you don't have any
fear of it.
Right?
What are you afraid of?
That's your state.
But if you have money and you're always
afraid of poverty, what's the point of having
money?
If it's going to create all this anxiety
for you and all this problem and all
this trouble, you're better off without it.
And Al-Harmun, Al-Harmun, anxiety is half
of growing old.
It's a hadith.
Anxiety is half of aging.
And there's a hadith, Al-Biru, Yezidu, Al
-Ammar.
Righteousness will increase your age.
It'll lengthen your life.
It's a hadith.
And one of the interpretations of that that
I think is really interesting is people who
are righteous don't have anxiety.
And people who are irreligious, they're in this
constant state of turmoil within themselves.
And so their hearts are never at ease
and they have all this anxiety, so they
age faster than other people.
So their life gets worn out.
They dissipate quicker than other people.
So fear of poverty is a waste of
time.
And now he says the cure for it
is to have a good opinion of Allah.
An-An-An-An-An-An-An-An
-An-An.
Right?
Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la says,
I don't want them to feed me and
I don't want them to provide for me.
Right?
Allah says that.
I don't expect that from you.
And then he says that he is the
razaq, Dhul-Qulit al-Mateen.
Right?
Allah is the razaq.
I'm the one who razaq is a mubarakah.
It's an exaggerated form, always providing, continuously providing.
So Allah is the provider, have a good
opinion of him.
And then he says to know also, and
know that Allah is not diminished.
His mulk, his dominion is not diminished by
him giving out.
If he's giving somebody all this wealth over
here, it doesn't diminish his mulk.
And that's why you shouldn't have hassads for
him.
Because just like he made him wealthy, he
can make you wealthy.
But again, you should be content.
That's why the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said,
Al-Qana'atuh, Kansun La'atna.
Contentment is a treasure that's never exhausted.
So know that what he said.
And then also know, The thing that's been
allotted for you, it will reach you.
And there's a difference of opinion amongst the
ulema about risk.
Some of the ulema say that risk, right,
Allah is razaq.
He's also a razaq.
Some of the ulema say that your risk,
which was makzum, it was allotted to you
in the womb of your mother, that it
is only what you'll actually use in the
world.
And others say it's everything that you have.
But the dominant opinion is, it's only what
you use.
In other words, if you have, if you
die with a million dollars, and you never
used it, it wasn't risk for you.
It was actually risk for the people that
inherited it.
Right?
If you had a house in some place
that you never went to, it wasn't risk
for you.
Even though you owned it, you could have
gone, you never did.
No, it wasn't makzum, because you never got
any benefit out of it.
In fact, I saw a book the other
day called, How to Live Well.
No.
You have to, you have to live wealthy
and die broke.
Right?
And that's that idea, right?
Don't let anybody get it after you.
Just use it all up, which is a
horrible thing, because in Islam, you're supposed to
think about your children and think about, it's
good to leave something behind for your children.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam didn't, because
prophets aren't allowed to leave behind dunya.
There's not.
Now, the next one is called Mudahana.
Right?
This is a really important one here.
One who uses his religion as a means
of benefiting his worldly condition is known as
a psychophantic hypocrite, Mudahana.
In his transaction, and he has been cheated
in the end.
Mudahana is a really important concept.
Right?
They would love if you would make Mudahana,
so they could make Mudahana.
Mudahana is where you use your deen to
rectify your dunya.
Even Khadun mentioned, he said, We try to
sew our dunya up by ripping our deen
apart.
People in this world, he said, So our
deen doesn't remain, nor do we ever rectify
our dunya.
In other words, it's a stupid thing to
do, because you lose your deen and you
lose your dunya, because Allah won't rectify your
dunya by destroying your deen.
He won't let it happen.
He won't give you tawfiq in that thing.
Right?
You'll lose both.
So, the point of Mudahana is, Mudahana is
when you, like for instance, you don't make
inkar because it's your business, it's your boss,
and you don't want to lose your job.
It's a dunya.
So, you do, this hypocritical yudahinuhu is a
hypocritical behavior because you're afraid of losing some
worldly benefit.
Like that.
So, it's where you actually lose your deen.
It's not that, for instance, if it's none
of your business, you stay out of it,
or if it's not wajib on you to
do it, which in many instances it's not,
then you have a choice of doing it
or not.
But this is actually where you lose your
deen because of some love of dunya.
And I put a reasonably long note there,
just about, because this is really an important
one.
And there's another concept which is important, which
is mudarat.
And also, I just mentioned that mudahana, the
root word is duhun, which is like covering
up, you know, cosmetics, oil, that's used in
cosmetics.
It's covering up as a type of kufr.
Shekhali adari says in Al-Khatima, mudahana is
when a man gives his religion up in
order to secure his wealth or his blood.
And sitting with the people of disobedience and
keeping their company, and praising their actions and
displaying pleasure at their condition without condemnation just
for some worldly benefit.
So that's haram.
And keeping their company, right?
The difference between this and mudarat is mudarat
is expending one's present life, the dunya, for
the sake of one's afterlife or for the
sake of some worldly benefit or both.
In other words, udari, the Arizona power of
darihim, madumtafi darihim.
You know, mudarat is where you're nice to
somebody and there's a reason for it, but
it's not at the cost of your deen.
If it's the cost of your deen, it's
called mudahana.
If it doesn't harm your deen, it's mudarah
and it's permissible.
You don't have to do it, but it's
permissible.
They say darihim, madumtafi darihim, wahiyim madumtafi haiyim,
wariyim madumtafi arbihim.
You know, like greet them as long as
you're in their height, don't make enemies.
And, you know, you don't like, my brother
-in-law was, you know, he just got
here from Morocco and he was in this
office and he drove all his way to
get this, to see somebody and they said,
oh, sorry, you have to have an appointment.
And he's like, isn't there something you can
do?
I just drove like 45 minutes and she
said, no, there's nothing I can do.
There's nothing he can do.
He said, no, because in Morocco obviously, you
know, it's not, and he said, that's America,
you know, and I said, don't say that.
It's the wrong thing to say.
You can't make, well, go back where you
came from.
That's the way they'll take that.
Right?
Most Americans, they'll take that.
Go back where you came from.
So, mudarat would, in that case, because you
might want to make an appointment.
Now she remembers you said that, so she
doesn't write it down in the book.
And then when you show up, now you
don't have an appointment here.
So, mudarat would be a situation like that,
where it's permissible, even though you'd want to
say something else, to say something nice, as
a way of ensuring a worldly benefit, or
another worldly benefit, or both.
It can also be used for somebody who
wants to, and it's not considered nifaq.
This is not hypocrisy.
It's a recognition of Islam, that there's things
in the world that you have to do,
and this is a ruhsa for people.
And another one also, is helping other people.
So using your position, if you have a
position, like somebody who's close to the minister,
and somebody who's been oppressed, and that person
has an ability to get in, and help
this person out, that's a mudara.
Right?
Because you're friends with the minister, you can
get them help like that.
And those are all praiseworthy things in Islam.
And just in this culture, there's a type
of, you know, I'm okay, you're okay culture,
which is, that is the mudahana.
So people do wrongs, and everybody says it's
alright, there's nothing wrong.
So there's a type of conspiracy of silence
that takes place.
Whereas in Islam, a mutman is the mirror
of his brother or sister.
They want to see them improving, getting better,
and so they do things.
And then the next one is, he says
the origin of it.
So now he says it's root causes desire.
Pama.
So we get back to pama, and doing
works of worship to obtain a place in
the hearts of others.
That's called ria.
Ria is when you do an action that's
a qurba.
It's with the condition that it's a qurba.
In other words, something that draws you near
to Allah.
If you do an action, that's the definition
of ria.
If you do a ria, a qurba for
other than Allah, you're mora'i.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam called it
a shirk, a shirk in As-sahr.
It's the lesser polytheism.
And in a hadith, and even imagine the
Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, I don't fear
for you worshiping the sun, the stars, and
the moon, right?
But I fear for you the worship of
other than Allah through ria.
Ria.
And there's another hadith, akhwa, fumma, akhwa, adaumati,
ria.
The thing I fear for my ummah most
is doing things for other than the sake
of Allah.
So, it's ilhar.
Now, obviously, somebody who, like if you're a
really good shot, or an archer, or something
like that, and you want it, people are
there, and you're doing it, and somebody shows
up, and now you're really going to show
them that you can do it.
That's, it's madmum muru'atan, not sharan.
In other words, we have to differentiate between
shari'ah and muru'ah.
In Islam, muru'ah is something that you
should preserve, your human dignity.
That's something that's blameworthy to do that, because
it is showing off.
But it's not showing off in something that
relates to a religious matter.
So, it's not a shirk with Allah like
the other one is.
So, he says, the source is desire, and
also ria, right?
You want people to think better of you,
to gain a place in the hearts of
others.
And he says, its cure is also my
cure for the latter disease.
In other words, I have a cure for
both of these.
And he says, my cure for tama is
my cure for ria also.
So, he says, wa shammer.
So, roll up your sleeves, get to work
and set out for this cure of the
root of all these diseases.
Tama.
Right?
And ria.
Get to work, because ria is really a
tama, you're desiring something from other people, not
from Allah.
And he says, get to work, because I've
got this cure.
And aqidi al-wiyati vil adwai is, aqidi
al-wiyati is the root.
Aqidi al-wiyati, the one who's carrying the
banner, you know, it's like the one who
began the thing.
The Arabs say, aqidi al-wiyati is the
one who begins something, so it's where it
began.
And so he says, I mean by that
showing off in good works, ria.
And now, this is really important here.
Look at this.
The signs of ria are three, laziness and
a lack of actions for Allah's sake when
one is alone.
So you don't have energy to do things
when Allah's alone.
Like you don't have energy to read the
Quran.
But when you're in the masjid and there's
other people around, you have all this energy
to do it.
That's a sign of ria.
Enthusiastic energy and much action for the sake
of Allah, when people are present, so the
opposite.
When they're not there, you don't have any
energy.
When you're there, you've got energy.
Now, there's something that I think also to
be careful about, even though it is a
sign of ria.
There's definitely something to be said for company.
And that when you see somebody who's worshipping,
it can sometimes stimulate you to worship, which
might not be from ria, but it's just
as the result of like a spree decor,
a type of, you know, because other people
are doing it, it gives you an energy
to do it.
So that's not necessarily a negative thing, but
the danger is that you're doing it, not
for Allah.
And then he says, increasing one's actions when
one is praised and decreasing them when one
is not praised.
So you want to hear people tell you
how wonderful you are and how much like
the man praying and people say, SubhanAllah, we
always see him pray and it's incredible.
He just prays all the time.
And then in his prayer, he says, what
about my fasting too, right?
The people that love to hear other people
saying those type things.
Right?
Yeah.
Well, that's behavioral psychology is all based on
that.
Rewards and stick and carrot to get motivate
people.
In sharia, it's not necessarily, I mean, there's
definitely something to be said for encouragement.
In other words, the Prophet's allies, and when
he saw people do things good, he used
to say, you did well, things like that.
It's not wrong.
And there is a hadith that says, if
the moment hears somebody praising him, it increases
him in Iman.
In other words, it makes him want to
do more with Allah, you see.
So it has the opposite effect.
And this is why this idea of here
is that you're doing it solely for the
praise.
That's what he's saying is the dangerous thing.
In terms of telling people, and also there's
a difference in sharia between medha, right?
Flattery and between thana, right?
Medha is when you're flattering somebody where it's
not true, right?
Whereas what's permissible is to tell somebody that
they did a good job or something like
that.
You should acknowledge people.
Not prohibited.
In fact, it's encouraged to acknowledge people, to
acknowledge what they do, things like that.
The danger for people is to desire the
praise, and that's what the people have to
work on in their own hearts.
And there is a cure for it.
He's going to give it in a second.
We're almost there, people, because I'd really like
to get through this.
You know, we should pray.
Do you want to come back, or do
you want to come back for about a
half hour after the whole?
So we'll pray the whole and then come
back.
InshaAllah, there's not much more through here than
we'll be caught up to, so we're on,
because I've arranged it so we can get
through this during these twelve classes.
InshaAllah, so I'd like to try to keep
up with the, so he's dealing now with
Rian.
We were looking at the signs of it,
and then, so he says, As for its
treatment and purification of the heart concerning it,
it is to remove from the heart four
things.
Love of praise, fear of blame, desire for
worldly benefit from people, fear of harm from
people.
Now, the way that's accomplished is, one, having
Yaqeen certainty that only Allah can benefit or
harm you.
And that has to be done first at
the level of Aqida, because that is a
premise in our Aqida.
In other words, in the belief system that
we're commanded by Allah to believe in, there's
no harm and there's no benefit except from
Allah.
Those are two names of Allah.
And if you really believe that, then you
recognize nobody else can benefit you or harm
you.
It's an illusion, right?
It's just an illusion.
And so that will free you from this
desire for praise and blame or for something
other people have.
Because in the end, what you really want
is Allah to be pleased with you, not
other people, because it's a waste of time.
So if all these other people are praising
you, telling you how wonderful you are, and
Allah is not pleased with you, it's a
disaster.
And the disaster manifests itself when you die,
which is when you wake up.
So the point being, don't be deluded by
praise and blame.
And then another thing to remember is, people
all over the world, like Muhammad Ali, there
was a time when Muhammad Ali was, you
know, he was the big man on the
scene.
Everybody was praising him, telling him how wonderful
he is, right?
And then he's no longer the guy that
can beat people up.
So Larry King's not calling him, he's calling
somebody else.
And it's the nature of dunya.
Praise and blame is all related to your
worldly position, your ability in the world.
When you lose it, people stop praising you.
And in fact, some of the Unama, they
said that one of the best signs of
the truth of this is when you have
nothing, it's very difficult to have friends.
And the minute you start getting things, suddenly
you have a lot of friends.
And that partly is the natural inclination of
the world, and that's the way people are,
right?
And so if you're not deluded by that
and recognize that, then you find it.
And that's why in fact, the Unama have
always said that knowledge, traditionally in the Muslim
world, knowledge was something that people sought after.
Because in fact, in the traditional Muslim world,
unlike today, which is wealth oriented, it used
to be it was knowledge that people wanted
to be associated with, not with wealth.
I mean, this really is true.
In the Muslim world, there were scholars that
achieved incredible status in the world simply because
of their knowledge.
And it's no longer the case now.
It's interesting.
I was reading Helen Keller's autobiography yesterday.
It's very short.
It's an amazing, very powerful work.
I really recommend reading it.
It's one of the most powerful things I've
ever read.
Because she was deaf, dumb, and blind.
And it's just her experience of her awakening,
the awakening of her consciousness.
One thing she said in that I thought
was very beautiful.
She said that she became deaf, dumb, and
blind from a scarlet feeling that she got
in childhood because she wasn't born that way.
And it's interesting because she said that even
though she was 19 months old when it
happened, she said the fact that she could
still remember what a tree looked like was
enough for her when she felt a tree,
just that she'd seen it one time in
her life.
She said, even though she was only less
than two years old, and she could still
remember that blessing of just having seen a
tree, that that was enough for her, that
she'd seen it.
That's an amazing thing.
The name of the eye, the human eye,
is just so awesome.
Anyway, she mentioned in there that she said,
there's no slave in this world that didn't
have a king somewhere in his ancestry, and
there's no king that didn't have a slave
somewhere in his ancestry.
So I mean, it's interesting.
People, the ups and downs of the world.
So everybody probably somewhere along the line has
their great-great-great-great-great-great-great
-grandfather, something, was the king of the roost.
And now they're nothing.
Or somebody who's now the king of the
roost, at one time down the line, one
of their ancestors was a servant in somebody's
house.
Get this and get that.
And this is Dunya.
So when you see the nature of Dunya,
is that nothing is permanent.
And I'll tell you, when you read the
history of the Arabs, the sissitudes of Arab
rulers is just amazing.
And if you read like Al Mansour, the
history of Al Mansour was a Khalifa.
He wasn't a Khalifa, actually.
He was a minister in Andalusia.
And he was a mediocre student in the
Madrasa, but he was very ambitious.
And he ingratiated himself, got into the palace,
got one of the really strong women in
the palace to one of the mothers of
the Khalifa to be.
He enamored himself of her, and she put
him in these positions.
And there was one minister who was the
most powerful minister in there that everybody feared.
And Al Mansour succeeded in having him in
the end in prison.
And he was one of the wealthiest people
in Qopaba, and he ended up a pauper,
dying in rags in the prison there.
You can imagine the life, that man's life,
right?
And so this is the nature of the
Dunya, it's like that.
So recognizing no harm and no benefit except
from Allah, and then also that likewise, if
the whole creation wanted to harm you, they
couldn't, unless Allah willed it.
And then if someone believes that with certainty,
riya doesn't occur to them.
Because you always, the reason people do riya
is to get some worldly benefit.
You want a worldly benefit.
So in the traditional Muslim world, because religious
people were so honored, there was a type
of showing off in order for them to
get a position amongst people, right?
And still, I mean, that's still a danger,
because the Muslims still do respect religious behavior.
So people will do those things.
Now, he says, I mean by that showing
off in good words, one of the calamities
of the heart, his definition is to do
an action of devotion for other than the
creator's sake.
Indeed, it was really done seeking some worldly
benefit or praise from the creation, or to
protect oneself from the opposite, meaning harm.
In other words, some people will do it
simply to get praise, because they enjoy hearing
how wonderful they are, and these type of
things.
So that's why they do it.
Then he goes on to give its various
types.
Allah muhumma kyana wusratan ira zem bin kamuv
diwara anliu jana diyad dihimadu yateemun tum mama
di dumni awi yin antapahu sunnana So he
says, the worst is that which is done
as a way of displaying virtue in order
to be entrusted with the wealth of an
orphan.
That's really bad.
In other words, you use the deen for
some to be put into an entrustment in
which out of that like an orphan's wealth,
well, you'll misuse it.
And this is religious hypocrisy done to actually
cheat in the religion itself.
And it was amazing, I met this Moroccan
man who was talking about people that did
vicar for money in Morocco, which there's actually
a lot of people that do that.
Because in Morocco, they have singers that sing
praises of the public to like them, and
they pay them to come to weddings and
things like that.
And he told me, because he does that,
he's a beautiful singer, but he won't do
it for money.
And he told me, he said, Allah has
made myriad ways to get your provision in
this dunya.
And he said, so don't do it in
a way that is designed to draw near
to Allah.
In other words, Allah gave you all these
different ways to make your money.
My father told me in the early 60s,
he realized that you can make money anyway
because he once sent in a dollar for
this barbecue starter kit.
And he got back a match and a
small piece of flint.
So people, you can make money a lot
away, especially in America.
In all these 1-900 numbers and things
like that.
Psychic, you know, those psychic things.
And all they do, they call them up.
I've never done this, thank God.
But people call them up and they say,
you're looking for a better job.
Everybody's looking for a better job.
Wow, yeah, I am.
You're looking for a better relationship.
And it's all just these things that poor
American people are all obsessed with.
And then also they know that he wouldn't
be calling them if his life was working
out.
So they know they can play on that.
I mean, there's all these things that they
know to do.
So the next thing he says is the
next thing is a worldly thing.
So the worst thing is a other worldly
thing.
An entrustment, like an endowment that was done
for religious endowment and then you use it
for dunya, like a luck, right, or money
that was collected for the sake of Allah.
And then the people use it for a
dunya we think.
That's the worst type of riya.
The worst type of riya, to display religiosity
and make people think that you're trustworthy so
that they put you in, like, on the
masjid board.
And then make you the treasurer, and then
dazzle the firm.
I mean, go out and rock, don't rock.
You know, it's horrible.
You read about, like, people that trick, you
know, old people like they go, these people
that go, and it's unbelievable what human beings
will do.
You know, because there's even degrees of despicable
behavior.
You know, not all behavior has the same
level of despicable, right, or despicableness or whatever
the word is.
And then he says, and finally, the least
of it is what is done out of
fear of other scornful days, right?
In other words, you do it, that's the
least of the riya.
You do it just because you don't want
people to say, you know, he's a bad
person or something.
So he says, it is cured by knowing
that had all creation joined forces to oppose
you or support you, they would not be
able to without his permission, Allah.
Indeed, he alone possesses rewards for your actions
in your two abodes.
In other words, in dunya and akhara, it's
Allah alone.
It's also cured by maintaining awareness of its
harm, which results in detesting it and thus
causes it to pass.
That is its intellectual treatment.
Its practical treatment is accomplished through veiling one's
actions from the eyes of others and by
reciting surat al-Ikhraas often and say that
it's tikhara.
So this is a really important treatment here
for everybody because this disease is a serious
disease and we all want to be free
of it.
And so the first one is doing things,
veiling your actions.
This does not mean that you should not
do actions in front of people, but it
means that you should also, out of fear
of riya, if you're able to do it
when people aren't there, it's better to do
it that way.
So if you're going to donate money, it's
better not to do it in front of
people.
Although, the udama say, if your intention is
to encourage other people, it's a good thing.
So it has to be waiting.
You have to look into your heart, what
you want.
If you want to show off that you're
the one giving the $10,000 donation or
$5,000 donation, then you have to do
it secretly.
But if you really don't feel that, you
know, you want to encourage others, something like
that, then it's permissible.
So you have to watch your own heart
and guard it.
And this is a very subtle matter.
So avoiding doing things, night prayers, right?
Doing night prayers where people aren't going to
see you, where people aren't going to reciting
the quran, doing the qur, things like that.
And even though the udama do say that
for scholars it's better to do these things,
also where people see them to encourage them
and to give them that.
It's also a danger for people of knowledge
because they're as susceptible or often more susceptible
to this disease than other people, right?
Because of the nature of their position and
things like that.
Now the other thing is Surat al-Ikhlas.
Ikhlas, if you look at the actual meaning
of the word, Ikhlas comes from a word
khalousah, which means to be pure.
And it relates to honey.
Pure honey, leaven, khalis, pure milk.
Leaven, khalis is leaven that has no, nothing's
come into it.
It's pure, right out of the udder.
So it hasn't been contaminated by anything.
And that's what the deen al-khalis to
Allah is that which is not contaminated with
riyyah.
That you worship Allah and there's no contamination
of riyyah, of hidden shirk, of doing it
for other than Allah's sake.
And the mukhli seen are the people that
do that.
Now if you look in the Qur'an,
there's two words that are used.
Mukhlas and mukhlis.
You can find them both in the Qur
'an.
The mukhlis is the active participle and the
mukhlas is the passive, which indicate there has
to be a tawfiq from Allah.
It's not enough for you to be sincere
from yourself.
There has to be a tawfiq from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala as well.
And that's the secret of success, is that
Allah gives this tawfiq.
And that's why Abrahassan al-Shadri said, Allahumma
ijaaal saiyati saiyat al-mahbul ladeik.
Walat ijaaal hasanati hasanat al-mabrodi ladeik.
Make my bad actions the bad actions of
those you love and don't make my good
actions the good actions of those you hate.
In other words, you have to have tawfiq
from Allah.
And Allah promises tawfiq if you do certain
things.
So it goes together.
And this is why if you're a mukhlas,
but you're a muftedek, you're not mukhlas.
If you're sincere in your actions, like a
Christian can be absolutely sincere, they can.
They can have yikhlas.
Don't think they can't.
You can have a sincere Christian, really.
You can have a sincere Buddhist.
You can have a sincere Jew.
You can have a sincere person in any
tradition.
But he's not mukhlas.
Why?
Because his action is not in accordance with
what Allah wants.
Do you understand the difference?
So the mukhlas, who's also mukhlas, is when
his action is sincere for solely for the
sake of Allah.
And with that, he's doing what Allah loves
him to be doing, not what Allah hates
him to be doing.
So that's really important to recognize that difference.
So Allah has commanded us to do things
and given us a sharia.
We have to follow and be in accordance
with the sharia.
If we're not, we don't get tawfiq.
There's no tawfiq.
It doesn't matter how sincere you are.
And I know Christians have a hard time
with this.
Because the Christian focus is to say, the
law is not really important.
The important thing is the spirit of the
law.
No, we say both are important.
And that's where you get the tawfiq.
The tawfiq is following the law and the
spirit of the law.
Because you can be following the law.
You're doing exactly what Allah tells you to
do, but it's not for the sake of
Allah.
So there's riya, rirmothak.
So you're not sincere.
You're not mukhlas, even though the action is
in accordance with what Allah has commanded you
to do.
So outwardly, you're praying like Allah told you
five times a day.
You're praying your zakat like Allah told you.
You go on your hajj.
You do all those things outwardly.
Everything looks good.
But you're doing it for other than Allah.
No tawfiq.
And on the other hand, you can have
inside, you're doing it sincerely and for God,
right?
I'm doing it for God.
Charity.
You do it hidden.
A Christian knows about it.
They have these things too.
They know about this, not being sincere and
things like that.
It's in their tradition.
So there's a Christian.
He's doing it, but he's not doing it
in accordance with what Allah said.
So you have to be with the spirit
of the law, but also the letter of
the law.
So our dean is the middle way.
The Jewish way is to focus on the
law, forget the spirit of the law.
The Christian way is focused on spirit of
the law, forget the law.
So they're both wrong.
One's mukhlaas is a passive.
And mukhlaas is an active.
In other words, in the mukhlaas, it's Allah
who's making you that way.
And the mukhlaas, it's coming from you.
So doing Surah Al-Ikhlaas, the word ikhlaas
comes from akhlaas too, or akhlaasa, which means
literally to make pure.
So the Surah is the Surah that makes
you pure.
The Surah literally is the Surah that makes
Ikhlaas will purify you, the Surah itself.
And that's why, and I put in the
note there, that Murat al-Haj, havida Allah,
most people that come to him with diseases
of the heart, he tells him Ikhlaas, to
do a lot of Ikhlaas.
Surah Al-Ikhlaas, including waswasa, like obsessive compulsive
thought.
So don't underestimate.
He's giving you a real cure here.
Ikhlaas is an important Surah.
You should say it minimum three times in
the morning, three times in the evening.
That's the least amount that you should say
every day.
Morning three times, evening three times.
It equals one-third of the Qur'an.
So it's a great Surah.
I mean, they're all great, but it has
a special mukham.
Mm-hmm.
What's that?
Yeah.
He says...
So that's the second practice to get rid
of this, is to do Saeed al-Ikhlaas.
Saeed al-Ikhlaas is there at the bottom.
It comes from a hadith that's related on
the authority of Boreda, of the Allah Anu.
It's in Imam Ahmad, Abu Dawood, Ibn Mahdi,
Ibn Khadban, and Al-Hakim.
So obviously, it's an important hadith that's mentioned
in a lot of them.
And if you do this a lot, it
will also purify you from riyyah.
And the hadith, the Prophet said, whoever, if
he rises, if he says this and in
the evening, then if he dies in that
day or in that evening, he'll enter Jannah.
So that's a big...
You should do it every day, three times
a day in the morning, three times a
day in the evening.
But preferably, I would do it also after
the prayers.
When you finish your prayers, it's a good
du'a to do, you know, any of
these times, even in sajdah.
And it goes, Allahumma antarabi, Allahumma antarabi.
Oh Allah, you are my Lord.
If you want me to write the phonetic,
do some people want the phonetics?
All right.
Allahumma antarabi da'a ila ila anta kharaktani.
wa'ana abdukha, wa'ana ara ahadika, wa
'ana ara ahadika, wa'ana abdukha mista'aalimaa
a This is really a cure.
I guarantee you, try it on yourself.
He is not making this stuff up.
This is a science.
Do what he's telling you to do and
you'll get it.
Say in every day...
Say that du'a Every evening say that
du'a.
Do Surat al-Ikhlas.
Really do it.
With the intention of Ikhlas, Ya Allah, akhlas
need.
Do what you could care for.
Do it.
Say it to Allah alone in the night.
Get up.
Ya Allah can do that.
And if you do it with sincerity, he'll
do it.
But, you know, if it's all just like,
okay, you know, and what's next?
What's the next disease?
You know.
I mean, this is serious stuff.
This is our lives, you know.
This is serious stuff.
This is not, I mean, this is our
life.
I take this stuff really seriously because it
scares me.
I read this stuff.
I mean, I read Imam al-Ghazali's signs
of insincere preachers and sincere preachers.
And I'll tell you, I saw more stuff
on the insincere side.
And it really frightened me.
You know, you read this stuff.
This is the danger of this science.
You start reading it and you start seeing
yourself in it.
And it's unnerving because we're going to be
taking into account for all this.
And this is what life is about.
And either we get the point or we
don't.
But the point is, we've been given a
hudah.
This is guidance.
And we're being told.
Now, another thing, which is a really important
du'a to do.
Right.
And he doesn't mention it in here.
But the city mentions it in the nasiha.
And this is a, it's a really, it's
a great du'a.
It's from our Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam.
So it has to be great.
But to do
this three times in the morning and three
times in the evening.
This is prescription drugs.
Right.
No side effect.
No, it has primary effects.
I seek revision you that I should associate
with you.
And I know it.
In other words, shirk riya.
This is a du'a for Isti'adah
min'ar riya.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam did it.
So Allahumma, Inni,
Bar'udu, Bika, and
Usharika, Usharika Bika,
Usharika Bika, Usharika Bika, Usharika Bika, Usharika Bika,
Usharika Bika, Usharika Bika, Usharika Bika, Usharika The
Koran is a tension- It's a shifaah
for what's in the hearts.
The Koran is a shifaah.
For what it says is shifaah, And
the Qur'an cures the hearts of believing
people, right?
So the heart can be cured, and this
is one of the duas, because the Qur
'an tells us to, what the Prophet gave
you, take it.
So he gave us this, so it's a
really good du'a to do every day,
at least three times a day.
And then he says, and this is really,
look at this, he says, as for the
chronically diseased heart that results from constantly showing
off by doing good works, even it will
find a cure in this, and what a
cure.
So he's letting you know this is a
serious treatment for this disease.
All right, so people believe it and practice
it, and inshallah you'll see the results of
it.
And then he says, He's saying, as for
hypocrisy, and here, riya is closer to a
type of hypocrisy that relates to veiling your
wrong actions, hiding your faults.
This type of riya is a riya that
is wajib, according to Ibn Zukri.
In other words, if somebody says to you,
did you ever drink alcohol?
You say, I never drank alcohol.
If somebody asks you, did you ever steal,
and you made telba from that, then you
say, no, I never did that.
He's saying that that's something that's not riya,
that's actually really important, it's wajib.
It's not considered a lie by sharia, and
I'll tell you why.
My note there is that this is in
fact a type of riya if the person
desires others to consider him better than he
is by concealing his misdeed from them.
In other words, it becomes riya when you're
doing it because you want people to think
you're better than you really are.
But it is an obligation to conceal one's
wrongdoing, not for this reason, but so that
misdeeds are not taken lightly by the community.
Because you see, if I don't know that
you've drank an alcohol, and I say, have
you ever had alcohol?
And you say, yes.
I say, oh, then I'm not that bad.
You see, it kind of, it lessens the
whole enormity.
Because kabirah means enormity.
The word in English language, enormity, means a
great evil.
It's very similar to kabirah.
Kabirah is an enormity.
You don't want to make little of enormities.
You want the society to actually respect.
And I just added in there that although,
because if people freely admit their transgressions, this
leads to complacency and lack of shame.
And although there's an obvious hypocrisy inherent in
this, it is really a type of homage
that vice pays to virtue in order that
virtue can act as a deterrent to the
inurement of deviation in the social arena.
In other words, you know, vice, in a
healthy society, virtue is the norm, is the
marov, and vice is the munkar.
In an unhealthy society, the opposite occurs.
So when you have a healthy society, vice
has to pay homage to virtue by hiding
itself.
Do you see?
So it's really, it's not a hypocrisy.
It's a respect for virtue.
And that's why the sharia is honoring it.
And the danger, see, this is what, like
Freud said, no, this is all hypocrisy.
And really, you're all seething with sexual lusts
and with desire and all these things.
So just let it all come out and
you'll be healthy.
And now, you know, welcome to 1998, right?
Seriously.
Where it's all, I mean, unbelievable.
Newsweek, you can't really even read it now.
It's the last few issues.
It's unbelievable.
There's no shame.
None.
I mean, this guy will.
Writing, it's pornographic.
And he's like a conservative commentator for time
or music or something.
And this is, there's no shame because they're
no longer paying homage to virtue.
They don't even have the shame to hide
it all.
It's all like, the problem here is not
what he was doing in the room.
That's all fine.
There's no, we all, there's no big deal.
The problem is he lied about it.
I mean, this is really the whole, you
know, so it's become all sick and perverse.
And even some people are saying, well, big
deal.
Everybody lies about that.
You know, it's not like lying about something
really big.
But it is big.
It's an enormity.
How did it become such an insignificant thing?
Because in this culture, in the 1960s, in
most cities in the United States, if an
unmarried, 1960s people, if an unmarried girl got
pregnant, she disappeared.
She disappeared from the community.
And about seven or eight months later, she
showed up again.
And they say, oh, well, she went off,
you know, to stay with her grandparents.
What she did was they sent her to
a place to have her baby.
And then they put the baby up for
adoption.
She came back into the community and nobody
knew about it because there was shame.
That's 1960s.
You know, seriously, that's not that long ago.
In 1968, a woman was kicked out of
Radcliffe for living with a man in the
same apartment.
1968, Radcliffe was at that time still considered
a reasonably radical place.
And they kicked a girl out for living.
Now there's coed dorms.
I mean, it's no who cares.
So how did it get from it got
from that by having a big deal?
Who cares?
Belittling it.
So Islam says, no, it's better to have
that hypocrisy because what it is is really
it's honoring virtue.
And that's the important thing.
It's not that there's that hypocrisy.
That's seen as less harmful than what happens
when it's all let it all hang out
type attitude.
You know, big deal.
That is what's dangerous, not the hypocrisy.
And this, again, is the idea in Sharia
of lesser of the two evils.
They're both evil.
You can see that.
Obviously, nobody wants to be hypocrite or tell
lies or say, no, I never did something
and you did it.
But the point is the Sharia saying there's
a greater evil in saying that you did
it.
Because it's going to lessen the impact of
the action when other people start saying, oh,
he's doing that, too.
Or, oh, he did it.
Well, maybe it's not that bad.
So instead of having that attitude, no, of
course not.
I would never do that because there's a
shock.
Seriously, it's not.
This is really serious stuff.
And this is how the Muslims viewed the
world.
There was shame.
You're not lying to show yourself as a
bad person.
Right.
What you're doing is you're recognizing you don't
want this other person to lessen their fear
and their disgust in the wrong action.
That's the important thing.
Well, see, even now, Imam Junaid, and I
really think this is a healthy opinion.
Imam Junaid said, if you do a wrong
action and you make talba, forget it.
Don't dwell on it.
I mean, have a fear of returning to
it, but don't dwell on it.
Because what that does, it results in guilt.
It results also in a type of despair,
and it results in a feeling of self
-loathing.
And you really shouldn't.
Those aren't healthy feelings.
They're not.
If you make talba as takfirullah, and make
a sincere talba, don't return to it, and
then just forget about it, like it never
happened.
And that is a...
When is this one, the big one, is
like a river or something like that?
And if you're in a place with...
Well, I mean, you're not...
I mean, if somebody's in an enormity, like
a riba, that's not kofar.
It is an enormity, and it's a bad
one.
And it shouldn't be taken lightly at all.
But it doesn't take you out of the
pail of Islam.
You're still within the fold of Islam.
It's an enormity.
If you've gotten yourself into that situation, and
it's not easy to get out of it,
right?
Then you have to make talba, and do
whatever you have to do to get out
of it.
In other words, begin that process, and make
the talba, get out of it.
Once you're out of it, you make, you
know, khalaf.
And talba has to be sincere.
And the signs of sincerity is real remorse.
You have nadama, that you leave it immediately,
and you make the intention never to return
to it.
If you do that, khalaf.
That's a talba, and you should have a
good opinion of Allah when you make talba.
Like, I'm so horrible, I'm miserable, Allah will
never forgive me.
No, Allah tells us not to think like
that.
And that's like a Christian disease.
You know, a lot of Christians fall into
that despair.
It's interesting, there's a lot of complexity in
Christianity.
Because they do have that tendency, and then
the other tendency, like the Baptist.
The Baptist, I mean, in Baptist Christianity, you
can be the most outrageous person, and really
completely be convinced you're safe.
And there's a Baptist that are like that.
That's why Baptist ministers, you know, it's kind
of just a notorious thing, the Jimmy Swaggart
syndrome.
Is that they really can do these horrible
things, and then get back up on the
pulpit, and it's not a shock to Baptist.
It's because, like, you know, yeah, the devil
got you that time, you'll get him the
next time, you know.
No, an islam is talba.
Islam is the talba of a non-Muslim
from his kufa.
And that, by consensus, is accepted.
When you make talba as a non-Muslim
by entering Islam by the ijma of the
ummah, all of your wrong reactions are forgiven.
Nothing remits, like the day you were born,
by consensus.
Whereas the talba of a Muslim, khilaf.
In other words, if Allah wants, he can
accept it.
If he doesn't, he can reject it.
But you should have a hope that he
does, because we have rajat.
But don't be absolutely certain.
In other words, that'll put your fear in
you from not returning to it another time.
All right?
Yeah, I think we can stop there.
I heard people say that when you take
shahadah, that all your bad deeds become good
deeds.
Is that correct?
No, but all your good deeds come with
you into Islam.
Your bad deeds are wiped out.
Yeah, but the good deeds come with you.
So anything you did good before Islam, it
comes with you into Islam.
That's why you don't lose anything, you just
gain.
Uh-huh.
That's a really good point.
We don't say that Allah brings evil.
But we say that Allah, within the decree
of Allah, is good and evil.
In other words, Allah has measured out good
and evil.
It's going to exist.
But the hadith, the Prophet, Dua of the
Prophet, he said, All of good comes from
you, and evil does not return to you.
So while Allah has created a world in
which he has allowed evil to exist, we
don't attribute evil to Allah, even though we
believe that it is Allah who measured it
out.
In other words, Allah has given...
See, evil can only exist, interestingly enough, with
human beings.
It can't exist in the animal kingdom.
It can't exist...
If a lion eats a baby, it's not
an evil act.
There's no moral compunction, therefore, the lion not
to eat the baby, right?
You cannot say the lion is an evil
lion.
You can't say the cobra is an evil
cobra if it bit...
Because it's just a snake, it's just doing
what it's created to do, right?
But if a human being takes a gun
and goes out and robs somebody of his
hard earned money and then shoots them, robbing
is an evil and then shooting them on
top of that for no reason is another
heinous evil.
Now, what we say is that Allah created
the human being and gave him the ability
to choose and then measured out for him
what he was going to choose.
In other words, he, Allah Subh'anaHu Wa
Ta-A'la, has measured out that that
person would, at that point, choose to do
that act.
And he's fully responsible for it and Allah
allowed him to do that.
In other words, empowered him to do it
because it was Allah's Qudra that enabled him
to carry out the act.
And it was Allah's Mashi'ah, right?
His providence and his will that allowed that
person to will what he want.
Wamaat al-Sha'oona illa'an yasha'Allah.
You don't will anything except Allah wills it
at the same time.
I don't want it to be like I
want it to go and do something harmful
to somebody over here.
And I start walking.
Now, my Mashi'ah has started.
But if Allah doesn't want harm to come
to that person, right?
And the person gets a heart attack, drops
dead on the way.
He willed something, but Allah didn't will it.
So anything that you actually do can only
be done if Allah wills it as well.
And that is when, now, when it's called,
it's tawfiq, when what you will is what
Allah loves.
And it's qudlan when what you will is
what Allah hates.
You understand?
So Allah is the Muwafriq and is the
Khadir.
But you're ultimately the one who is doing
the evil.
We don't attribute the evil to Allah, but
we admit that Allah has measured it out
in the world.
It's part of the qadir of Allah.
Allah has allowed evil to exist in the
world.
So it is part of his creation?
It's part of his creation, exactly.
And we're not overlooking evil, but the
consequences of our actions.
We're responsible for, absolutely.
Whether it's evil or good.
But it's Allah's qadir, he measured it out.
In other words, without him creating a world
in which human beings could choose good or
evil, no evil could exist.
So ultimately you say, had Allah not willed
it, there would be no evil.
But it doesn't return to him.
We don't attribute it to him.
You see what I mean?
How do you know that there is Allah,
like God will and Allah will, at that
point in the moment before I know an
action is there?
If it's in sharia.
If it's not in corresponds with sharia, then
there's no tawfiq.
But if what you're doing is done with
ikhlas, sincerity, and it's in accordance with Allah's
laws, then there's tawfiq.
That is tawfiq.
That's what mu'afak means.
Somebody who, their actions, what they will is
what Allah loves them to do.
You should.
He stops everything until he knows what the
hukam of Allah is.
You should never engage in anything that you
don't know what Allah has willed in it,
has decreed.
It's haram, to do anything that you don't
know the hukam of Allah.
And thank goodness, the vast majority of things
are permissible.
And there's only a small group of things
that are haram and you have to learn
them.
It's pretty simple.
Well, Allah didn't make the deen hard.
I'm serious.
The deen is not difficult.
The problem is, human beings just, they don't
want to do these things.
Taqwa is very simple.
Taqwa is four things.
Taqwa is doing what Allah commanded you, inwardly
and outwardly.
Inwardly with ikhlas, outwardly in accordance with his
laws.
Right?
That's the first two parts.
The second two parts is not doing what
he told you not to do, inwardly and
outwardly.
Leaving it not out of fear that somebody
is going to see you going into the
bar.
Right?
Out of fear of Allah.
That's inwardly with ikhlas.
And outwardly, not doing it, whether you're alone
or whatever.
And that's all Taqwa is.
And if you have Taqwa, Allah promises you
every good in this world.
He promises you makhraj.
He promises that he'll rectify your children.
He promises that he'll forgive your wrong actions.
He promises that he'll open up the gates
of the heavens and reign and give you
good agriculture.
He promises you that you'll have a good
life, hayah pa'yiva.
He promises you all these dunya things.
And then he promises you otherworldly things.
He promises that he'll forgive you.
That he'll enter you into paradise.
That he'll put you in the company of
the neviyin, the prophets.
The siddiqin, the righteous people.
The shuhada, the martyrs, and the sadihin.
I mean, what a deal.
What a bargain.
Yeah, it's not a good thing to do.
It's called ikhraj.
Ikhraj, you know, the Arabs.
Ikhraj is when you...
Yeah, it's like putting somebody in an embarrassing
type.
And particularly about wrong actions.
Not a good thing.
Again, that's muru'ah.
And it's also, the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
said, From the good Islam, the beautiful Islam
of a person, is to leave what doesn't
concern him.
It's no concern of yours what he does
between him and Allah.
And it's better not to know, because one,
you'll think badly.
They asked him how old you were.
He said, yeah, Anik, is it any concern
of yours?
And he was asked about that.
And he said, look, if you tell them
your age, either they'll say, oh, I thought
you were older.
And so they belittle you.
Or they say, oh, I thought you were
younger.
Right?
So you can't win.
No, that's different, because there's a concern.
Right?
I mean, if you're getting married, there is
a concern.
And age is one of the concerns of
marriage.
It's a perfectly valid reason for a man
to be concerned about the age of a
woman.
Because there's things that relate to marriage and
that.
And also the woman with the man.
That's why it's not permissible, for instance, to
dye your hair.
If you have gray hairs, you know, and
go and dye your hair.
And then go to the woman and present
yourself as a shab, you know.
And then she marries you.
And suddenly, you know, she starts seeing the
roots.
Right?
Oh, well, yeah.
That's a big problem.
And vice.
That is a really major problem.
Because, obviously, in traditional cultures, you know, people
knew good people, good families from bad families.
I mean, it was just unknown.
You know, in most Muslim cultures, a good
family, you know, that they weren't doing bad
stuff.
Unfortunately, now, that is no longer true.
Good families, bad families, it doesn't matter.
There's a lot of people that have fornicated.
There's a lot of people that have taken
alcohol, taken drugs, taken things.
And especially nowadays, you know, it's very serious.
Because there's diseases that relate to this.
There's a lot of repercussions in that.
And so, I think that, you know, there's
a valid concern there.
Well, it depends on, you know, what it
relates to.
I mean, I think in terms of zina,
you know, people have a right to know
if they're getting into a marriage.
Now, in sharia, the verse, you know, that
a fornicator can only marry a fornicator, right?
Or the polytheist.
That has to do with before toba.
In other words, the bariya was a woman
who would just sell herself in the marketplace.
And she, it was prohibited to marry somebody
like that if that was their condition.
If they made toba, then there's no prohibition
against it.
But, you know, that's something that people have
the right, I think, in relation to the
situation that we're in now.
Does that make sense?
InshaAllah, we'll return to the maphara.
Where did we get to last week?
What's that?
The middle of riya, what a terrible place
to be.
InshaAllah, Allah, give us all a cure.
Yeah, so, did we get to the, about
imamare karodilanu?
When nejmu lem yarabi himin basi?
Yeah, all right.
So, what he was saying here, that he
mentioned about the scholars have two opinions about
those seeking some worldly benefit through worship as
opposed to the next world.
In other words, for instance, if you recite
surat al-waka in order, for the sole
reason of not being impoverished in this world.
Because there's a hadith in which the Prophet
SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam was reported to have said
that whoever recites surat al-waka every day,
let us see the hufaka.
He won't be afflicted with, you know, any
financial calamity or great difficulty, hardship in the
dunya.
And this is well known, even Masayyid al
-Radimah Anu said, when they asked him what
did he leave his daughters as inheritance.
He said, taraktulahumna surat al-waka, I left
for them surat al-waka.
So, surat al-waka is known if you
recite it every day, that it protects you
from poverty.
So, what he's saying is, you know, the
scholars have different opinion if that's why you
do it.
In other words, the hadith indicates that whoever
does it every day, that that's the benefit.
But if that's the only reason that they're
doing it.
In other words, it's encouraged by the Messenger
of Allah to do it every day, but
what is the intention behind it?
Obviously, you know, there's always a degree of
iman if you do anything that's from the
Messenger of Allah.
In other words, reading surat al-waka every
day is not like, for instance, investing in
the stock market, something like that, where there's
a tangible, maybe not so.
But some people think there's a tangible benefit
in doing something like that, whereas this here,
it's from the unseen world, right?
There's something, a benefit coming from the unseen
world, so it's related to iman.
And then he said, or even seeking the
next world, or worship, seeking its pleasure.
Now, Imam al-Ubi al-Matici radiAllahu Anhu
said that to seek the next, as that's
the reason why you're worshipping, he said it's
jaiza.
In other words, it's permissible, but that's not
the reason why people should be seeking the
next world, or seeking, that's not why they
should be worshipping, simply to seek the next
world.
So the idea is that it's jaiza.
In other words, permissible, that's where it would
go under the categories.
It's mobah, right?
That's one opinion.
The people of tasawwul tend to be extremely
down on doing ibada for worldly or otherworldly
benefit.
They say you should only do ibada because
Allah SWT says, Allah
is worthy of takwa and is worthy of
magfirah.
Simple as that.
That's the reason.
We don't want to reward, thanks, nothing.
We're doing this, it doesn't say we're doing
this for akhirah, we're doing this for akhirah.
So that's the position of Akhtar al Sufi,
Qadi Abu Bakr bin al-Arabi, Radilah Anu,
who was both a Sufi and afaki.
He says that you shouldn't say that because
if you look at the Qur'an and
read it, using your intellect, you will see
that Allah is encouraging you to strive after
his jannah and to have fear of his
fire.
And there's a famous quote from Rabbi al
-Adawiya, Go after the gardener, don't go after
the garden.
And she also said, oh Allah, if I
worship you for the garden, then put me
in the fire.
That's a pretty strong thing to say, I
wouldn't say that.
But that was her state, that was her
maqam, that was her had, her state.
But Qadi Abu Bakr bin al-Anu says,
and Sidi Ahmed Zarrukh says, in no way
should the worship of Allah for his garden
be belittled because it's not belittled in the
Qur'an.
Now Imam al-Ghazadi says there's three types
of people.
There's people who worship Allah as akhirah, they're
free people.
They do it for the sake of Allah,
they're not interested in anything other than just
worshiping Allah for the sake of Allah.
And there's a hadith even though I think
it's either weak or some takallam fihita maman.
But there's a meaning in it which is,
Even had it not been for the fire,
he wouldn't have disobeyed Allah.
In other words, there's some people that they
don't disobey Allah, not out of fear of
the fire, but simply because Allah should not
be disobeyed.
He's akhirah takwa, he's worthy of takwa.
Now what Qadi Abu Bakr says is, Imam
al-Ghazadi ar-Anu is the first one
is worshiping Allah like a hoor, free man.
The second is the worship of Allah which
is like the tujar, what's in it for
me.
And he said that's like thinking if I
do so many rakats, I get such and
such a reward.
If I read so much Qur'an, I
get such, and it's like a merchant, it's
buying and selling.
Or he wants the garden, that's why he's
doing it.
And then the last one he said is,
it's the worship of the slaves who do
it out of fear of the whip.
So they're afraid of the fire.
So you have ones who are doing it
solely for the sake of Allah, others doing
it desiring the garden and others doing it
out of fear of the fire.
Now if you look at the Qur'an,
there's definitely tari'b and tari'b.
They're both.
Allah is encouraging us to do things and
says, sabiqul iram al-firatan, you know.
Allah says, go for magfirah, wajannatin, right?
And go after the jannah, fafidarika, wafidarika fari
'atanafisun and mutanafisun.
Let them buy one another for the jannah.
If you're going to do munafisah, do it
for jannah.
So in the Qur'an, there are many,
many verses that deal with tahweef, frightening us
about the fire, and also tari'b, encouraging
us to do good because Allah rewards it
with things.
And so I think what Adil Vakr, Radilah
Anu says is that, you know, that you
should, that you should not belittle that and
that not only that, but worshipping that having
tama' for Allah's jannah or desire for Allah
jannah and this fire is ikhlas with Allah.
In other words, if you do that, you're
mukhles and there's no sha'iba.
So this is what he's, all he's telling
us in this line is that you have
difference of opinion, all right?
You have difference of opinion.
If you're doing your worship for the next
world and that's why you're doing it, he's
saying some people are going to disagree with
that and those people tend to be the
Sufiyyah.
It's considered an extreme position by the fukaha
because the fukaha like Adil Vakr and Imam
Rubi and Adir, they say, you know, that
this is, it's ikhlas because Allah says that
in the Qur'an and that's inshallah, the
strongest opinion.
Now, the next thing that he says, which
is really important is, some also consider seeking
the pleasure.
Now, what this means is, and people who
do ibada seriously, do it over time, what
they will often discover is that there's actually
a pleasure in ibada that becomes more pleasurable
than other pleasures that other people are preoccupied
with.
In fact, one of the Hanafi, great Hanafi
scholars said, he said, if the kings knew
that the pleasure that we're in, if they
knew what we have, they'd send their armies
with swords to try to take it from
us.
In other words, he was saying that this
pleasure of ibada and of ilm and worshipping
Allah is so great that the kings, with
all their palaces and all their dunya, if
they knew what we had, they would fight
us for it.
So, what he's saying is, is that some
of the people, especially again, the Aarifin and
the people of Tassou, tend to say that
this pleasure can be so strong that people
do the ibada to obtain that pleasure.
So, they begin to actually pray in the
night because of that type of pleasure.
And so, some of them warn against it.
But again, Ahmad Ibn al-Hawari, no, one
of the greats, Olaman, I'm trying to...
said that had it not been for these
things, then most people would have a difficult
time doing these things consistently.
In other words, that Allah has given those
things as a reward for the mu'tabara, for
the constant practice, for the ibada, and there's
a blessing in it.
And it shouldn't, again, be belittled.
So, he's just giving you some differences of
opinion about that.
And then he says, The one who likes
people to see him doing these things.
In other words, he's doing it for Allah,
but he likes that other people happen to
find out about it.
Right?
That is considered riya according to some of
the ulama.
According to other ulama, it's not.
And the reason for that is the Quran
mentions that there are people that they love
to be praised for what they don't do.
They love to be praised for what they
don't do.
And some of the ulama took from that
ayah the indication that it is a natural,
it's part of the human nature, The human
being is actually presupposed to enjoying the fact
that he does good things and that people
give him recognition for that.
But if that's the reason why he's doing
them, that's the problem, and that's what he's
saying.
There's a difference of opinion.
So some of the ulama say the fact
that you like that other people know that
you're doing good things and they say good
things about you, some say that is a
riya.
Others say it's not riya if that's not
why you did it.
You see the difference?
So some say if you did it for
that reason, that's definitely a riya.
But if you didn't do it for that
reason, but you like the fact that people
do recognize that, then that is not riya.
He said...
One of the ulama he said, whoever loves
to do something and get known by it
and remembered by it, he's made shirk with
Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la.
Imam al-Jazuli, a great faqih from Maghrib
said also, he's the teacher of Siri Ahmed
Zarrukh, he said, even if it's a riya,
you can have riya when nobody's there.
And the riya is, for instance, you're reading
something and then there's a masala hariba, like
a strange thing in the book that you
know not very many people know and you
think, oh this would be a good thing
to mention in the gathering and so you
write it down and you memorize it or
something so that you can make mention of
it later.
He says that's riya.
Khalas.
So, it's a big problem.
Exactly.
If your intention was to benefit people, that's
not riya.
But what Imam al-Jazuli was saying is,
if the person was thinking, oh, this all
get them with this one, or they'll be
really impressed with this one, that type thing,
which is obviously a danger of people of
scholarship and other things, but particularly people of
scholarship have that problem.
Because when ulema get together, there's kind of
an expectation that there's Muvakara and Musharaka and
it can turn into a type of riya.
And Sahar ibn Abdila, great, great early scholar,
Muhadith, amongst other things, said, manahab banyakari anas,
adamaa bainahu wa bainarabihi, fa hua ghati loon.
Whoever desires people to know what's between him
and his Lord, he's in ghafla.
In other words, it's nobody's business, but you
and your Lord.
You shouldn't desire for other people to know.
Unless he sees that people have left good
actions and he does it as a way
of nasi'a.
So, for instance, ibn ulema radilano and ibn
misa'ud were known to go into the
masjid before fajr and do to hajjud.
So they did that.
They could have done it in their houses,
but they did it there as a tariqib
for other people from the tabu'in to
see them doing that so that they could
do that and that wasn't their intention other
than as a nasi'a to the Muslims.
Now, he says, when nizhmu lem yara bihi
min baasi in bhuni asa'i wa ala
asasi, ima madik radilano who's called a nizhim.
And the reason he's called a nizhim is
because his student and later to become mushtahid
muktak, ima mushtahri radilano said, ida adukir al
-urama fa madikun a nizhim.
If we talk about that, ule madik is
the star.
And that was something that his student said
about him.
And so he became known as a nizhim.
It's one of the names of ima madik.
He has alqab, alimul madina, like Imam Shafir,
he's called the Alimo Quraish.
He's called the Alimo Madina.
Abu Hanifa radilano is called often Al Imam
al-Ahram, the greatest ima.
So those are alqab that are given to
them.
So he did not consider that harmful as
long as the original intention was based on
the foundation of sincerity.
And this comes because Imam Madik radilano was
once asked about a man, he said, what
do you say about a man who's walking
to the masjid for the sake of Allah?
He went out with the sake of Allah.
I want to pray in the masjid, jama
'ah.
But on the way he says, he starts
thinking, I hope somebody sees me going to
the masjid.
And he said, la'arra, la'arra, ba
'asan, right?
Iva kana alsarawil ikhlas.
He doesn't see that as harmful if he
started out with ikhlas and fights it.
In other words, he doesn't, you know, he
doesn't follow through with that inner type, waswasa.
But rather he actually says, awudu billa or
something like that.
So that's important to know.
And then he says, wa'amirun ala'riya
an'afballu min tarkihi lekhawihi wa'fatballu dikar
al-lisani farrag al-janani aragufur al-qalbi
wa lisani.
This is really important here.
What he's saying is, is that it's actually,
to not do something out of fear of
riya is worse than doing it with riya.
So to leave an action, say you're coming
into the masjid and you want to do
some rakats and then you think, those people
might think I'm doing it, or you're worried
like, oh, you know, I'm probably just doing
this because I want them to think that
I'm a good Muslim.
If that type of fear of riya, that's
called khawfar riya.
If that occurs to the heart and you
leave the action because of it, it's riya.
Because the problem is, is the reason you
left the action was the people.
So the whole point is, you're concerned about
the people.
So leaving it out of fear is the
same as doing it for the people.
You're concerned as the people, not Allah.
And that's why they say it's better to
do the action even if you feel there's
a riya in it.
Now this does not mean if you have
a possibility to do it on your own.
In other words, if it's an ibada or
a worship that's related to something you can
hide from the people, then it's better to
hide it.
It's always better to do something secretly as
opposed to publicly.
Why?
Because of the danger of riya.
But if you leave it out of fear
of riya, it's worse than actually doing it
with the riya.
And this is also the same with dhikr.
That if it, according to the unama, it's
better to do dhikr, heedless, than it is
to not do dhikr at all.
The unama say, it's better that your tongue
is doing dhikr and your heart's rafid than
that both your tongue and your heart are
rafid.
Because what they say is, if you do
it on your tongue, it might reach the
heart.
Because a man's heart, the heart of a
man lies under his tongue.
And it's interesting, in Chinese medicine, just in
their physiology, there's a direct connection from the
tongue to the heart.
And they say that what the tongue does
affects the heart, that it's actually even the
movement of the tongue affects the heart.
And that's in their physiology.
Now another thing is important also to know
that riya, the derivation of riya actually comes
from seeing a man, seeing the creation, not
the opposite.
In other words, you would think that riya
is them seeing you.
But it's actually you seeing them.
That's where the riya is.
It's your seeing them as opposed to seeing
Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la.
And one of the things about the Yoma
Qiyama that's fascinating, one of the many things,
is that Aisha Radhila, I know when she
was told by the Prophet that everybody was
naked, and she asked the Prophet, won't they
be looking at each other?
He said, it's going to be much greater
than that, Aisha.
In other words, people will be in such
a state of awe, they won't even be
aware of other people.
And this is the point of ibada for
the sake of Allah.
If it's really for the sake of Allah,
then you have a knowledge of Allah that
completely makes everybody else seem insignificant.
How can you give, I mean when you
think of Allah, what you're worshiping, I mean
just imagine that the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
once saw Jibriel in his true form.
He filled the entire horizon.
One angel.
The whole horizon, that whole plane, you look
out there and imagine seeing a being filling
that whole horizon.
It's unbelievable.
And that's Jibriel.
So the point being is when you realize
what you're worshiping is infinite, and then you
start thinking about the pathetic, other pathetic human
beings, not just yourself, but all these other
pathetic creatures who are in the same mess
that you're in.
In other words, they need Allah as bad
as you do.
There's nothing they can do for you.
There's no benefit, no harm, nothing.
And that's the bottom line.
And that's why he says, So
now he's telling you why.
Fear of other than Allah and desiring them,
it obviates, it's against tawakkul.
In other words, if you have true tawakkul,
Allah, Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la
says, well, we need tawakkul, Allah.
He's going to have tawakkul, Allah.
What he's saying is, if you're worrying about
other people, you don't have tawakkul, Allah.
There's no tiklan.
And if you don't have tawakkul, Allah, the
reason that you don't have it is because
there's no Yaqeen.
And what you don't have Yaqeen, the Yaqeen
that you don't have is that everything good
comes from Allah and everything harmful can only
happen by the will of Allah.
That's the Yaqeen that Tawheed is teaching us.
He's telling us to be absolutely certain that
only Allah can harm you or benefit you
and for that reason, you lose your fear
of human beings.
Which does not mean that you become like
a fool and go start doing impetuous things
without thinking, like driving like a madman or,
well, it's all written by Allah.
That is not tawakkul.
The Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said to the
Bedouin about the camel, tie it and then
have tawakkul, Allah.
So then he says that he seeks refuge
in Allah but the reason for this, every
disease is lack of certainty.
What is prohibited from the two is that
which prevents an obligation from being fulfilled.
If on the other hand, it leads to
neglecting that which is recommended, then it is
considered reprehensible.
In any case, flee in fear to your
Lord from both of them.
So don't desire creation and don't fear creation.
But what he's saying is, what is haram
are those things that are going to prevent
you from doing an obligation or it's maqrou
that prevents you from doing something that's mustahab.
So fear and desire from other than Allah
Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la.
Now then he says, keep in mind that
the cure for both is to know that
there's no harm that benefits or harms other
than him from Allah.
And then he goes
now to the next which is called displeasure
with the divine decree.
And this is going to sound very familiar
for a lot of people.
This pleasure with the divine decree occurs when
one resists Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A
'la, the majestic exalted in what he has
decreed.
For instance saying, I didn't warrant this happening
to me.
In other words, I don't deserve this.
And that's really interesting because you hear that
from a lot of people.
I don't deserve this.
Why is this happening to me?
Or the next one he gives you, what
did I do to deserve this suffering?
What wrong did I do to deserve this?
So the point here is everything comes from
Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la.
And this is why Imam Abrahassan, said that
there's a quality that people have that they're
completely unaware of and it destroys all of
their actions.
And he said very few people actually recognize
this and it is being displeased with the
divine decree.
Very few people actually recognize that they're showing
displeasure to the divine decree.
And this is because Allah Subh'anaHu Wa
Ta-A'la says they were displeased with
what Allah has given to them.
And so Allah removed all of their good
actions.
Because the people of Taqwa, if they're asked
what did your Lord bring down?
They say good, it's all good.
That's what they say, it's all good.
The moment everything is good, nothing is evil,
it's all good.
There's a reason, there's a lesson to be
learned, a lot, there's a wisdom.
And this is the difference between the people
of Allah and the people other than Allah.
The people of Allah recognize that the world
is a place of purification.
It is a mapara itself.
That we were sent here to purify ourselves.
The reason that we exist is to purify
ourselves to draw near to Allah and worship
Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la.
That's it.
Once you recognize that, then everything becomes an
opportunity to learn and to increase and to
draw near to Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta
-A'la.
Everything.
Because there's only four possible states of the
human being.
There's only four, that's it.
There's no fifth, guaranteed.
And if you can come up with a
fifth one, I'll be amazed.
According to Abbas and Mursi, he said you're
either going to be in Nirmah or you're
going to be in Baliyah or you're going
to be in Fara or you're going to
be in Maasihah.
That's it.
You're either in a blessing from Allah or
a tribulation from Allah, obedience to Allah or
disobedience.
That's it.
Now, each one of these necessitates a response
from Allah.
Allah wants a response from you in each
one of these.
If Allah gives you a Nirmah, what's his
response that he desires from us?
Shukar.
He wants shukar.
That is the response, gratitude.
Now, what is gratitude according to Sharia?
It is to use the Nirmah in what
is acceptable to Allah.
Either mobah, permissible, mandu or wajib.
To use it in something that is makru,
there's not really gratitude there, but it's not
ingratitude because it's not in the haram.
That's what Allah is proving to you.
You look at those five things, there's only
one that you're punishable by.
The other four, you either get a reward
or nothing.
So shukar.
He says later on in the matara, that
shukar is to utilize what Allah has given
you in what is pleasing to Allah.
That's shukar.
So you have shukar al-lisan, you have
shukar al-janan, al-lisan, al-banan.
You have shukar on the tongue and part
of it is to thank the people.
That's part of shukar.
To tell other people what they did for
you is part of shukar.
That's actually considered part of shukar.
To remind other people, oh, so-and-so,
he benefited me in this or that.
Ihara ni'ma is part of shukar, to actually
show the blessing.
Allah loves that.
To feel the blessing in your heart and
to act in something that's pleasing to Allah
with the blessings.
The next one is a tribulation, baliya.
And what does Allah expect from us?
Sabar.
Allah expects, if he gives you a tribulation,
he expects Sabarun Jamil.
I mean, actually, you don't even have to
have Sabarun Jamil.
Sabarun Jamil is when you don't complain to
anybody.
You can actually complain, and we'll get into
it in a second, but that's not a
good thing to tell people.
It just makes you feel a little bit
better.
And then the next, fa'a, obedience, what
is the response?
Shuhud al-Minna.
The response is not to become arrogant.
If you're in obedience, to recognize that it's
from the tawfiq of Allah that you're in
obedience.
So you don't start thinking you're better than
other people because you're in fa'a and
they're in masiya.
That's the danger of obedience.
And this is the danger of religion.
The inherent danger of religion is self-righteousness.
And this is really the disease of the
religious man.
He begins to see himself as better than
the irreligious man.
And that's Shaitan's inroad.
Once he's got you in that corner, it's
rope-a-dope, like Muhammad Ali did.
It's rope-a-dope.
He's got you till the end of the
fight.
Because kibir is his game.
That's Shaitan.
Once he's got you in mutakabir, to takabir
al-Anas, he's got you.
So that's the danger of obedience.
What Allah expects you when you're obedient is
to recognize it's a gift from Allah.
And so you recognize that just as he's
made you obedient, he could have made that
person over there who's disobeying him, he could
have given you the nama.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, don't
find faults in others.
Because if you find faults in them, Allah
will take their faults away from them and
give them to you.
So there should be a fear.
There should be a fear in recognizing that
that person is in baliya.
He's in baliya.
And he has to change.
If he's in mausiya, it's a baliya as
well.
Because pa'a is a nama.
So they go together.
But he's in a baliya.
And this is why Imam Matic relates in
the Mu'ata that Isa Alayhi Sallam said,
according to Imam Matic, balarani an-na Isa
bin imariam qal, which means I just heard.
So it's a story.
But he obviously thought it was good enough
to report it in his Mu'ata.
He said that Isa Alayhi Sallam was reported
to have said that there's only two types
of people.
There's people who are in tribulation and people
who are in nama.
And he said, so don't look at the
people of tribulation as if you're lords.
But rather, look at them with compassion like
servants would look at them.
So that is the point.
When you see people who are in tribulation,
don't look at them like I'm better than
these people.
Look at them like SubhanAllah, they're in tribulation
and alhamdulillah al-diyafani.
That's the du'a of the Prophet.
When he saw people in tribulation, he said
alhamdulillah al-diyafani.
Praise be to the one who made me
healthy in a way that I wasn't given
the tribulation of these people.
Alhamdulillah alhamdulillah alhamdulillah alhamdulillah alhamdulillah.
He over so much of his creation.
So that is where you should be with
obedience.
Now in Maasiyyah, obviously, what is expected of
you?
Tobah.
You have to make Tobah.
Now, if you look at this situation and
realize SubhanAllah, every single thing that happens to
me is going to be one of these
four things.
And there's a response that I can do
that will please Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta
-A'la.
And if I please Allah, it means that
that thing in fact was an amma.
Because it took me closer to Allah and
that's the point.
Maybe you hate a thing and in it
is much good for you.
And maybe you love a thing and in
it is much harm for you.
And Allah knows and you don't know.
So just admit you don't know.
And then when it comes to Alhamdulillah, alhamdulillah,
alhamdulillah, right?
He ni'am.
And even Abbas said if you get a
tribulation, it's a ni'amma that's not worse
than it could be.
So you have to thank Allah.
Alhamdulillah, it's not that bad, right?
And the best thing is to look at
the Seerah of the Messenger of Allah, SallAllahu
Alaihi Wasallam and see how he lived his
life and how nobody had greater tribulation.
He buried all of his children except for
Fatima.
How many people will do that in their
life?
How many people will bury all of their
children except one?
Out of six children, you bury five of
them?
He lost the closest people to him.
His most beloved uncle slaughtered on the battlefield.
The beloved wife of several years of blissful
marriage dies in his most difficult year.
Abu Talib, his uncle, he was raised an
orphan.
He had no supporters at one time.
People who honored him were calling him a
madman saying he was Majnun.
I mean, how many people have that?
Where suddenly all of your friends and coworkers
and everything start calling you a Majnun, spitting
on you.
Seriously, so you look, he had sanctions against
him that most people couldn't bear, you know,
anything near just that one period of his
life.
So all of those tribulations, and then you
realize, never once, we have no...
No complaint, no complaint.
Never once.
Twenty-three years, no complaints.
Alhamdulillah.
That's all I knew, Alhamdulillah.
So this is the situation.
So to be angry at the Qadr is
to be in a state of ghafla, in
a state of heedlessness, right?
It's a state of heedlessness.
Now, another really important thing here is Imam
al-Qarafi, Radilah Anu said, gave us, he
wrote a book called, all it is is
differences in the Sharia.
It tells you the differences between all these
different things that appear to be similar.
And one of them is the difference between
arriba, bilqaba, walmakbibi.
So when you're looking at the qaba, you
have two things.
You have the qaba itself.
You have the qaba itself, and the qaba,
and you're gonna get into some difference of
opinion about qaba and qada.
And you know, there is a difference, but
it's very subtle, right?
The qaba is that Allah, some say it's
one or the other.
The maturidi and the sha'ara differ.
They have absolute opposite interpretations.
But the point is it's one or the
other.
It's not really important which one it is.
One of them, the qaba, in this case,
is that Allah has decided to make something.
And the qada is that he enabled it
to happen.
In other words, gave the means, measured out
the means in which it could happen.
But the qaba is that he qaba'u,
qaba'r abukha.
He decided to do something.
And the qada is enabling that thing that
Allah decided to happen.
Now, the makbibi is the thing that happens
itself.
Now, should we be happy with the makbibi?
Should we be happy?
Everything that happens?
Okay, who said no?
Why not?
Why shouldn't we be happy with everything that
happens?
Because bad things happen, right?
I mean, don't forget that Allah has, in
his qada, is khair and shar.
So you should not be pleased with shar.
Because Allah is not pleased with it, right?
So Allah has qaba'u, he's decided that
there's going to be evil in the world
that he created, but he is not pleased
with it.
In other words, he doesn't reward it.
That's what his rihabah is, his reward.
He doesn't reward it.
And so when you see malsiya, it's not
something that you should like or be pleased
with.
Allah doesn't want you to be pleased with
it.
But you should not be displeased but that
Allah has created a world in which that
exists.
In other words, so you see the difference?
One is recognizing that we should not be
displeased with Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A
'la and the world that he created.
Because it's Allah's world, he created it.
But two, there's things in the world that
Allah has placed in there as a challenge
to the believers.
And that is what you should not be
pleased with, those things.
Because he doesn't want you to be pleased
with them.
Because if you were pleased with them, you
wouldn't do anything about changing them.
And if you're displeased with them, that becomes
the impetus, the compelling reason for you to
get out and actually transform what's wrong in
the society.
All right?
And so that is the difference.
Now, an example that what little Khadim gives,
actually Imam al-Qarafi gives it, is he
says, here's the difference.
I think there's a really good analogy.
Just for takribah and ma'ani, that's all.
He says, you have a doctor.
And you go to the doctor, and the
doctor says, you've got gangrene, I have to
cut your arm off.
So he cuts your arm off.
Now, one day the doctor's out walking by
and hears you talking to a friend.
And now you've got your arm there, and
you're saying, I went to this stupid doctor,
I didn't get a second opinion, I know
this guy shouldn't have done this.
Now, the doctor hears that, he's going to
get upset, right?
Because he obviously doesn't want to hurt you.
He wants to help you.
But in helping you, you had to cut
off your arm.
Now, what he's using that analogy for somebody
that goes out and says, I don't deserve
this.
Like, why did I lose all my money?
I didn't do anything to deserve this.
Why did Allah take away all my money?
Now, he said, if, on the other hand,
the doctor's walking down and he hears you
saying to somebody else, I went to this
incredible doctor, and he cut off my arm,
and it's causing me so much pain, I
can't believe it.
And it was the most severe treatment that
I've ever had, and I can't sleep at
night.
When the doctor hears that, he's going to
feel compassion for you.
Because you haven't said anything against him.
All you said is this treatment was really
intense.
And so what he's saying is, if you
say about things that Allah does to you
in the world, Allah's really doing it to
me this time.
It's hard, but, Mashallah, there's a wisdom in
here.
In other words, that is not going to
make Allah angry.
It's better not to tell people.
If you go and tell other people, it's
not, but it doesn't mean that you're not.
You become, you're no longer patient when you
start telling people, I don't deserve this.
Why is this happening to me?
You see, there's a big difference there in
the two reactions.
One of them is, you are complaining, but
you're complaining in a sense you're getting released
something, you're releasing something, not complaining about what
Allah has done to you, complaining about the
difficulty you're having in dealing with it.
That's all.
And there's a big difference.
So that is an important thing to note.
And he said another thing is that we
were not commanded by Allah that we should
enjoy difficulties and tribulations.
There's nothing in Allah, nowhere in the Quran
tells you, enjoy horrible things that happen to
you.
That's not the way he made us, right?
And so you don't have takleef there.
But what Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A
'la says is, and in fact, he actually
censures the people in the Quran when he
says, We gave them a punishment and it
didn't humble them and it didn't make them
call on Allah.
Please take away this punishment from us.
In other words, like now, you see, you
look at people now, it just gets worse
every year, and people, they just throw up
their arms, right?
Muslim countries, Kuwait, you look what happened to
Kuwait, you would think that they'd all be
aliyah now.
They'd all be up every night doing tahajjud,
begging Allah, please don't ever let this happen
to us again.
Things go back.
There's no Istikana.
There's no sense of Al-Buddiya to Allah.
So tribulations happen, and if they don't change
people, then Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A
'la, you know, it's just, it's a bad
state to be in.
Then he says, the next thing that he
says is, Suma'ah.
Suma'ah is one of the diseases of
the heart, and suma'ah, the best way
to understand suma'ah, is suma'ah is
identical to riya, except riya relates to the
ni'ma of the ayin, an ayin, and suma
'ah to the udon.
In other words, suma'ah is that you
want other people to hear about you, or
you have to tell them about the thing.
I did the, oh, you won't believe.
I did the most amazing thing.
I gave $10,000 to this and that,
you know, charity, or whatever.
What you're doing is you want to tell
people about good actions that you did, and
that's called suma'ah.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, man
samma'ah, samma'Allahu alahi wa yamaqiyana.
Whoever does this suma'ah tells people all
the things they did.
Allah is going to tell people what they
really did on the yomuqiyama.
You see?
Because everybody has the skeletons, right?
Everybody has those skeletons.
Kulu kum kappa'on.
All of you do wrong.
Ukhirul kappa'ina tawaboon.
So everybody has akhpa.
And so if you're going around telling people
what good you're doing, Allah says he's going
to tell them what bad you were doing
as well on yomuqiyama, and you don't want
that, so don't say anything.
So he says, was suma'atul ikbar of
the pa'ati, ba'ad al-ghulusihah min
al-athati.
So you did the action for Allah, but
then you went and told people about it.
And so, akhbat al-amad, you ruin it.
Libad al-aradi ar-riya i-wal-amad
tufsidhu, what I can intubtam damad.
So what he's saying is, you know, that
there was riya related to it, and it
ruins action.
Suma'at ruins your action.
But if you make toba, then it rectifies
it.
All right?
So you can make toba from that.
And he said also the one who does
it in order to tell other people about
it.
So he didn't do it with yikhlas.
He actually did it in the first place
in order to tell other people, and that's
also suma'at.
That's also.
And in the note there, the difference between
seeking reputation by telling others of one's deeds
and showing off is that the former involves
a sense of hearing and the latter of
seeing.
In other words, they are one but use
different routes to affect the hearts of others.
Ibn Abd al-Saram says that should the
reason be a desire to encourage others or
to relate Allah's blessings upon you, then I
mean it.
The hadith says whoever informs others of his
good deeds out of desire for their benefit.
That's not in the hadith, but that's the
explanation.
Allah will inform them of his foul deeds
on the day of judgment.
And whoever dislikes his good deeds, displays his
good deeds to others.
Allah will display his bad deeds to them
on the yomukhayam.
It's related by Ahmad and Imam Muslim.
They always put one of the sunnah of
the muhadithin is to put Imam Ahmad first
because of his...
Even though Sahih Muslim is more sound than
the Muslim of Imam Ahmad, the Jalala of
Imam Ahmad's maqam in the ummah, his exalted
place, puts him first before there.
So you'll see that very often in books
that he's mentioned before Imam Muslim.
And now he says he's going to tell
us what's going on.
This is very interesting here.
He was a brigand from Beni Ababa.
And so the Arabs, they use him as
aqtam min shilab.
He's like a proverb.
If you want to say somebody's a really
bad robber, then they say aqtam min shilab.
You know, he's more of a brigand than
even shilab.
So he's saying, this brigand that that means
like a highway robber, severs the road.
On all those people trying to get to
their Lord, this brigand that's going to stop
you on the road and try to rob
you of your rewards with Allah is tama,
covetousness.
So we go back to this source disease
of desire, right?
The Arab, Abra Abbas al-Mursi said one
day, He
said, Abra Abbas al-Mursi was once in
the marketplace and he was going to buy
something and he saw somebody he knew.
And he was a very righteous man.
He was known for scholarship and his spirituality.
And so he thought, if I go to
that person, he'll say, oh, I'll give you
a deal because he's a religious person.
And he said, he heard a call, nuditu.
He got a call like a hadtif.
And the hadtif told him that a salam
al-fideen, to be sound in your deen,
is not to have desire for created things.
So that is how you have a sound
deen, is to lose that tama in other
people no matter what.
And that's what he's warning us against because,
again, if you look at these previous diseases,
all these things, you think you're going to
get something from them.
Right?
You think that you're going to get something
from them.
And the pama, the reason for pama, according
to Sidi Ahmad Zaroq, radiAllahu alayhi wa sallam,
is a ghafla.
You forget that you've become heedless that Allah
is nazi and dar.
Human beings don't have anything to benefit you.
So there's a ghafla that comes on the
heart and Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A
'la warns us about that very often in
the Qur'an.
And one of the verses is a reminder
in Allahu wa razaq.
Allah He is the razaq.
He's the one that provides for you.
Another one, Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A
'la says, that Inyam siska, Inyam siska Allahu
bi adurren, fadaa kashiva lahu.
Lahu wa Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la.
If Allah gives you a harm, there's nobody
that can remove that harm except Allah Subh
'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la.
In the famous hadith when the Prophet SallAllahu
Alaihi Wasallam saw Ibn Abbas, he said, yeah,
hudam.
He called Ibn Abbas, he said, I'm going
to teach you some words.
Amongst what he taught him was that if
all of the creation got together to harm
you and Allah didn't decree it for you,
they couldn't do it.
And if all of creation got together to
prevent some harm getting to you, they couldn't
prevent it.
It's over.
The ink has been lifted, the pens are
dry.
The pens have been lifted, the ink is
It's over.
So everything that's going to happen to you,
you have to recognize, is in the hands
of Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la.
And then you should desire Allah Subh'anaHu
Wa Ta-A'la, not what people have.
And then, like in
an example, people wish you ill how though?
When they say bad things against you?
Well, if you're straight with Allah, then their
prayer is going to be of no benefit.
If you're oppressing them, then you should have
fear, because the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said,
fear the prayer of the oppressor.
If you're not an oppressor, you don't have
any fear of their prayer.
If you're not oppressing them or anybody else,
then you shouldn't have any fear, because somebody
who's making a prayer against you, that's voting
against you.
And it'll just go back to them.
It doesn't go back to you, it'll go
back to them.
And that's their business.
Somebody making a prayer against you, you know.
That's their business.
You know, Allah didn't tell us to make
prayers against people, unless they're oppressors.
Al-Adwani, Al-Alawani mean, there's no aggression
except against oppressors.
And he said, ad-Duaas, Al-Ahul-Mukhman,
the prayer is the weapon of the mukhman.
That's the only weapon that a lot of
mukhmanin have.
There's a lot of places where the mukhmanin
are completely bereft of any ability to defend
themselves.
All they have is dua, and dua is
not to say that all they have, because
it's a lot, dua is very powerful.
And Allah answers the prayers of those who
call on Him sincerely.
So, I mean, I wouldn't worry about people
doing that, unless they have justifiable reason, and
then you should ask them to forgive you
if something was done that warrants what's that.
Mm-hmm.
The rafla is heedlessness.
And what Sid Ahmad Zaroq said is, the
reason for pama'a is rafla, that you're
heedless of the way creation really works.
I mean, if you think somebody can benefit
you, it's a rafla.
You know, you're forgetting.
It's just like somebody, you say, you know,
somebody was sick, and you say, how are
you?
And they say, I'm doing great.
I took this incredible medicine.
It was really beneficial, and I feel great.
And they forget.
It's a rafla.
They're a movement, but they're attributing something that
shouldn't be attributed to the medicine.
They say, Alhamdulillah, Shafani Allah, Allah cured me.
You know, I took some medicine, and sha
Allah Allah put a cure in it for
me.
He cured me through it.
But to think that the medicine, and people
do that.
It's a rafla.
And if you remind them and say, no,
Allah cured you.
Oh, Safar Allah.
Fakhir, you know, of course.
Right?
I mean, that's what people say.
So human beings go into rafla.
They go into this forgetfulness that they don't
remember how things really work.
And one of their raflas is that people
can harm and benefit you.
That's a rafla.
Because they can't.
There's no way they can harm or benefit
you unless Allah wants it.
And especially, I mean, obviously, when you're dealing
with armies and military formations, you have to
be very realistic.
Because you're in the realm of asbab.
But when you're dealing with risk and ibada
and riya and pama and suma and these
diseases, you know, it's all just wahm.
There's no foundation for it.
Rafla is a bad, I mean, it's a
disease.
Rafla is a disease of the heart.
It's a bad one.
I mean, some will say, actually, Imam al
-Juna'id said the only disease is rafla.
He actually said that is the disease.
He said that he never saw any wrong
action, except it was a result of rafla.
Any wrong action.
In other words, if you're really in a
state of awareness of Allah, there's no way
you can do wrong.
So he actually felt that it was the
source disease.
You know?
Rafla, rafala, mohafal means a simpleton.
Mohafal, somebody who's easy to fool.
So rafla is a state where you're being
fooled.
But rafel is fooling himself by not remembering
how things really are.
So it's a careless heedlessness, stupidity.
It's a type of stupidity.
Only it can be temporary.
It's not permanent.
And then he says, He says, He says,
I mean, why are you talking bad about
somebody?
What's the benefit?
There's some thama there.
There's something.
Why do you want to speak bad about
somebody or somebody else?
What is it that you want?
You want that other person to have a
bad opinion of that person that you're speaking
bad about?
That's thama.
You're desiring something.
So there's some desire, because there's no reason
to do it unless you think you're deriving
something out of it.
And banati ariiri is a word for the
lying.
So people who lie also.
You lie because people want benefit.
It will also preoccupy your prayer, preoccupy your
heart during the prayer.
Preoccupation of the heart during one's prayer, and
insincere praise of others.
Thama will cause you to say things about
people you don't believe, like the salesman.
You look great in that.
And he just wants to sell it.
He could care less.
But he's not going to tell you, he's
not going to tell you, it's horrible, you
look terrible.
He's going to say, you look really good
in that.
I bought a cheap pair of glasses once
that they were ugly, but they were inexpensive.
And I got them, and the person said
to me, oh, this is really nice.
I said, I think they're really terrible, but
it's a good price.
And they said to me, yeah, you're right.
It's just fine.
Why are they saying that?
Because they want me to buy the glasses,
come back another time, whatever, have a nice
day, you know.
Ching, ching.
And you can see in sales, you learn
that, right?
People that are salespeople, they know this better
than anybody else.
It's all about thama.
When the guy walks through the door, there's
thama.
You want to sell something, you have thama.
And that thama makes you do certain things,
that you wouldn't normally do.
Like there's people you'll talk to and be
nice to, that you wouldn't give the time
of day, if you saw them in normal
circumstances, right?
Because there's thama there.
And that's why, atayjiro sada, kmashu hada.
The truthful merchant is with the martyrs on
the yomukhayama, the hadith.
The truthful merchant is with the martyrs, which
means he doesn't have thama in his heart.
Now, how do you say, how can you
be a merchant and not have thama?
Because he sees everything coming from Allah.
If Allah brings him a customer, it's Allah
bringing his provision to him.
If he doesn't buy anything, Allah didn't decree
it.
And he can just be a human being.
He doesn't have to lie.
He doesn't have to tell him how wonderful
everything is.
He can just be a human being.
One of the things, in traditional cultures, and
in some places, like some people infest will
still do this.
In traditional cultures, when you went into the
marketplace, they had aswah, right?
These were like rows of hanout, stores.
Now, in America, the dumbest thing that you
can do in marketing is what?
Build a place next to a place where
they're selling the same thing.
I mean, anybody, right?
Anybody who's been to business school, you always
do your marketing analysis, right?
And you find out, is there a need
for this thing?
Well, why would, in traditional societies, why would
they put them all in the same place?
And so they call it sukkad-aparin, right?
They'll call it sukkada, you know, whatever they're
selling.
And this, you go to Damascus, right?
Everybody knows where the sukk of the clothes,
where they all are, the sukkah of the
iskafiyin, where they sell the shoes.
Right?
Everybody knows where to go.
They're all sitting there.
Not only do they all sit there together,
but traditionally, they usually pray together.
They were friends.
They often were in guilds together, and actually,
apprentice people, and they were often attended the
same circles, had the same sheikhs.
They were best friends.
Seriously.
What would happen is, if this guy who
had the first store, he sold enough for
the day.
He would shut down and go back to
the home or go to the messian, and
let his other brothers get what they needed.
I'm not making this up.
It's hard to believe that there were actually
people like this on the planet.
But it's really true.
And there's still a few left.
I mean, they're really old usually, and their
sons think they're idiots.
Right?
Because they've been to business school and have
their MBAs known.
Right?
No, seriously.
There's all these books, How to Swim Amongst
the Sharks.
No, there's business books in this culture teaching
you how.
They have an ad in, I think it
was Time or U.S. News and World
Report.
It shows this guy looking in the mirror,
this young guy looking in the mirror.
He's in like a hotel, and it says
he's going to eat the competition for breakfast.
And then down below, written on the window,
and then down below it says, and then
he's going to take his kids to Marine
World.
And it's like an ad for a hotel.
But the point is, that is American culture.
And that's something, yeah, we really did it
to them, didn't we?
We wiped out the competition.
That is exactly how, and that is what
this country's all about, competitive capitalism.
Wipe out the competition.
Whoever's in your way, eat them for breakfast.
Native Americans, no problem.
Send them blankets with smallpox or wipe them
all out.
Right?
Oh, the Iraqis, you know, they're causing problems
with the oil?
No, we want to keep the oil down.
Right?
Just bomb them, blow them out.
We'll eat them for breakfast.
Right?
That's what we'll do.
We'll send them back into the stone ages.
We'll bomb them so badly, they won't recover
for decades.
And it's the same mentality.
Walahi, it's the same mentality.
And this is why these big events that
occur, like the bombing of Iraq, are nothing
other than these small, petty little events blown
up to big proportions.
Because it's the same mentality that creates it.
The exact same mentality.
So this is, you know, this is the
world that, and this is, what he's saying
is, we're supposed to, we want to purify
ourselves from all this stuff.
We don't want to be like that.
We want to actually coexist with other people.
Right?
The Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said that the
Dzizi, that Ummahum is tenefus, competition over dunya.
That is the disease of civilization.
And he said, that is what will destroy
them in the end.
Because in the end, if here's your philosophy,
us against them, the problem is, their philosophy
is us against them.
So everybody's philosophy is us against them.
And unfortunately for other people, you're their them,
just like they're your us.
Right?
So you wipe them all out.
In the end, everybody gets wiped out.
Right?
Because they're out to wipe you out.
You're out to wipe them out.
So that's, it's a deep disease.
Some of them said that that the harul
of tama'a are all mujawafa.
It's just, these are like sucking.
You know, they just, there's no way to
fill them up.
That you always desire more.
You'll never get what you want.
In fact, the Greeks had a concept for
it called Eros.
Right?
They differentiate between different types of desire.
Agape and Eros and Eros is like a
longing.
It's a desire that's never fulfilled.
It's never fulfilled.
And that's, it's like just always wanting more
and more and more.
And that's why the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
said that the son of Adam, that nothing
will fill his mouth.
Jove.
Nothing except the dirt in his own grave.
If he had one mountain of gold, he'd
just desire a second one.
Nothing's going to fill you.
And then he said, Two people will never
be quenched.
Seekers of knowledge and seekers of dunya.
So you choose.
You choose.
Right?
Those are the two people that are going
to be insatiated in the world.
And you're either one or the other.
You're either seeking knowledge or you're seeking dunya.
That's it.
No other choices in this world.
Right.
I mean, in other words, pamaa, if it's
for Allah, that's a good pamaa.
You see what I mean?
In other words, if you desire Allah, pamaa
is a human urge.
It's in it.
It's there.
I mean, all of us have desire.
What he's saying is, the disease is when
you desire other than Allah.
You think some benefit is in other than
Allah?
The same with hasad.
If you're envying people in order because you
don't think they deserve what they have?
No.
But if you see somebody who's outstripping you,
you should want to be like them.
In fact, that impetus might make you start
doing things that they're doing in order to
become a better person.
So those are utilizing these things to your
advantage.
Now, listen to this.
This is so brilliant, I thought.
He says, If you ask desire, what's your
trade?
It'll answer earning humiliation.
That's the herfa.
Or if you ask about his father, he
would say, Doubt concerning the divine measuring out.
There's not coming to me.
Or if you ask him about his goal,
he would say, It's the deprivation of the
very thing that he desires.
Now, another thing.
In the khatiman, this is really important.
So I want everybody to really listen closely
here.
What he's saying here is that is your
desiring something.
And what's been allotted to us in this
life is called a risk.
And there's some really important concepts here.
One of them is, rarely does he use
two names with the same attribute.
You'll find it, like rafir al-foor, things
like that.
He's a razaq and he's a razaq.
And we're called marzuk.
We are marzuk.
We're the ones, the passive form.
And what we're getting is called risk.
And I mentioned last week, there's a difference
of opinion about risk.
Some say it's what you actually benefit from
and others say it's whatever you have.
Dominant opinion is what you benefit.
There's nothing on the earth except its risk
is from Allah.
Allah has given it its risk.
because the nature of the world is that
Allah has divided the provision of people, the
arzaq of people.
And there's two types of arzaq.
There's risk which is bopani and there's risk
which is lahiri.
Those are the two types.
The rizq that is outward is your food,
your health, those type of things that we
can see.
The bopani rizq is things like your company,
your knowledge, the things that you actually learn,
the character that you have, all of these
type things.
Now, if you look, one of the interesting
things about life is the fact that the
same people keep showing up in your life.
This is a very strange phenomenon about life.
When you realize that there's only there's five
billion people on the planet and yet if
you actually think of the main people that
are important in your life, they're actually a
very small number and they keep coming back
again and again and again because they're actually
part of your rizq.
They're in your rizq.
So your company is going to be, you'll
keep seeing the same people again and again.
Now, and there's tribulation and benefit.
Some of it's good, some of it's bad.
Some people have very pessimistic view, other people
optimistic, especially if you realize it's all from
Allah.
Allah is the one doing it.
Now, here's what's really important to remember.
Because Allah has given the human being wealth
and his wealth is a nirmah and he
placed it in you and then in his
divine decree he has distributed the arzah, these
provisions amongst people.
But some of the risk of one person,
he put with another person and there's a
sabab that means you have to go and
get that.
Do you see?
So there's this thing, here's the person over
there, he's got your rizq.
It's not his rizq, it's your rizq.
But Allah put it in his possession.
Now, however you get it, it depends.
If it's food that he has that was
written for you, he'll invite you over for
dinner.
He might not even like you, but if
it was written for you, you have to
come to dinner.
Maybe you weren't invited, you show up with
so-and-so.
Right?
And that's rizq, it's there and it's makson
and he can't eat it because it's not
for him, it's for you.
And that's why the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
said he loved the guests more than anything.
He came with his own provision.
You're not losing anything by feeding the guests.
It's his provision, it wasn't written for you,
it's for him.
And he leaves with the wrong actions of
the house.
In other words, it's a kafara when you're
kind to a guest and courteous, Allah will
remove wrong action.
So the guest is a great blessing from
Allah.
Now, because the asbab, you have these asbab
and they're very mysterious, people start thinking, my
rizq is from him.
That's the kafla.
Because Allah has made the sunnah where he's
put your rizq with somebody else.
And so people start seeing, he benefits those
guys.
Maybe I can get something from him too.
And so that's where the famah comes in,
where you start seeing the sabab and lose
sight of the musabdib.
You see the means, but you lose sight
of the true means, the true musabdib, the
cause of those means.
And this is what happens, and this is
where the famah comes in and this is
what's so dangerous.
And the biggest sign of this is when
you get angry when you don't get what
you want.
That's the biggest sign.
When there's an expectation, it's not fulfilled, you
become angry.
Now, this is obviously not about hukuk.
In other words, if somebody owes you something
and he's not giving you it and he
has it, that's a vulnerable.
And you get angry because it's vulnerable.
This is talking about arzaq and what's coming
to you and what's yours.
And this is why the Prophet SAW said
in the hadith, he said that the rizq
is coming to you.
He said, Allahumma siri Anasina Muhammad, that Jibril
said to him, no soul will die until
it completes the rizq that was allotted to
it.
It has to complete it.
It's amazing.
You know, I was on an airplane in
Mauritania.
We flew from Nirma to Noakshap.
And there was a man on the plane
up front.
We saw him get on in a wheelchair
and everything.
Right when we landed, we were just landing
in Noakshap.
And they started doing, they put the seats
down and started doing CPR.
He died.
And then even more extraordinary, it's not that
extraordinary in Mauritania.
The man who was meeting us at the
plane was good friends with him.
So we learned his whole story.
He was like a minister and very well
respected person.
And he'd become ill.
He was only about 44.
And he was in Nirma.
And he was out in the desert recuperating.
And he took a shot.
Somebody gave him a shot of something.
He went into a coma.
They took him anyway.
They were bringing him to Noakshap.
The point is he had an appointment with
the Angel of Death at that place.
There he was out in the middle of
the desert in Mauritania in a tent.
But he was meant to die in Noakshap.
So all the as-bab were made so
that he could die where he was decreed
to die.
Because there was no other place he could
die.
It was his, it was Maksun for him
to be in that place at that time
and to die there.
And so, you know, if Allah, you know,
If Allah wants to destroy somebody in a
certain place, He'll give him reasons to go
to that place.
And it's an amazing thing.
So the same is true about risk.
And this is why the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi
Wasallam said that, Jibril is telling us all
your risk is written for you.
And then he said, So have takwa of
Allah.
Don't do anything haram to get your risk
because it's coming to you.
And don't be somebody who's going and begging
or asking people.
And that was one of the things that
the Sahaba took bayah with the messenger of
Allah.
One of the things of bayah was that
they didn't ask people for money.
That was actually in the bayah that you
did not ask people for money.
So, you know, the iman should free you
from all those concerns.
And then he said something, He
said, don't let the delay of your risk
cause you to be disobedient to Allah.
In other words, if it's not coming as
soon as you want it to come, don't
let that be a cause for you becoming
disobedient with Allah.
So that's really important.
Everybody in Salah.
The next disease is extended hope.
Salah will cover that next week.
We last
week we covered which was covetous desire.
And then what he says in there, what
he says is He says that
the Arabs have a, they call it sumu
sa'a, which is a poison that acts
immediately.
Quick acting, immediate acting poison.
The immediate acting poison of this love of
dunya and pama and all the diseases of
the heart is tatwil al amal.
And then he gives us a definition of
it, which is accustoming or assuring yourself that
death is a long way off.
And this is something obviously, on the one
hand, it's a necessary human condition.
And there's an amazing wisdom in tatwil al
amal.
And one of the wisdoms that the ulama
have mentioned about tatwil al amal is that
if people did not have extended hope, they
wouldn't bother planting trees.
And if you thought you were going to
die any minute, you're not really going to
be worrying about farming or having children.
And so what would happen is there'd be
no infrastructure for the next generation.
Every generation would have to come and deal
with the immediate circumstances.
But instead, because human beings do have hopes
that they're going to live, they build things,
they farm, they create infrastructure, and that infrastructure
is inherited by the next generation.
And the famous story in one of the
Persian stories is about the Persian shah who
passed by an old man planting an olive
tree.
And the king said, You know, is this
tree going to be of any benefit for
you?
Because you'll die surely before it comes to
fruition, because a good olive tree takes several
decades before it really is producing good olives.
And so the sheikh said, and it became
a proverb amongst the Arabs, They
planted before us, and we ate from what
they planted.
And so we plant so that those coming
after us will eat.
So the king gave him a reward.
And then he said, already the tree benefited
me.
And so he gave him more.
So the idea of this tatwil al amal
is that it's a necessary, it's a rahma
from Allah, that Allah has put this in,
because people wouldn't go to school, people wouldn't
do anything.
Now, one of the things about modern society
is because of the apocalyptic nature of the
age we're living in, people are beginning to
lose hope about the future.
A lot of young people are becoming very
nihilistic, dressing in black, right, at these schools
and things like this.
There's a morbid perspective on the world.
And the fast food culture, which is the
idea of, you know, get it now, don't
wait.
And the credit culture is a culture that
really is causing people to lose this sense
that there is a future.
And in fact, it's only recently, this is
the first generation of Americans that actually see
that their future will be worse than their
parents.
Prior to that, I mean, Americans were noted
for their cheery optimism about the future.
And they're losing that, right?
And so it's actually a bad sign when
people do lose hope.
On the other hand, what he's saying is
that it's also a deadly poison if you
have too much hope.
It becomes a false hope, an aman, ul
al aman.
And the result of it is that it
generates hard-heartedness and indolence.
So he says, yul hitu kaswatir kurubi wal
kasal.
What that means is by ul al aman,
the heart becomes hard because it doesn't reflect
on akhirah.
It doesn't reflect on its own mortality, on
its own dependence.
And so it gets a hard heart.
Now, Al-Fubayl ibn Ayyad, radiAllahu Anhu said,
and he's one of the great early scholars
and zuhad, the people of asceticism or of
doing without.
He said, chamsul min alamt al-shakha.
There's five things that are signs of shakha,
which is wretchedness.
The world is divided into two types of
people, saeed and shakhi.
There's only two types.
That's it.
No third.
Saeed and shakhi.
Saeed is felicitous, and shakhi is wretched.
And the idea is obviously...
Now, if you look at Aristotle, who's kind
of foundational to Western civilization, Aristotle wrote a
book called The Ethics.
And in this book, he basically says the
goal in life is leisure and happiness.
And this is reflected in the Declaration of
Independence, because the Declaration of Independence, written by
Thomas Jefferson, he says in there that people
have these inalienable rights from God given to
them.
And he says, among which are life, haiya,
hakul haiya, liberty, hariya.
These are sharia rights as well.
But then he says, and the pursuit of
happiness.
And his original wording, he actually said, the
right to be free of debt when you
come into the world.
Because what happens now is that because of
national debt, children are born in debt.
I think it's about $50,000 in debt.
Every child that's born is automatically in debt
based on their previous generations overspending.
So that was the original phrase.
But then he changed it to the pursuit
of happiness.
Now, what is happiness to a middle-aged
white landowner in 1776 having more land?
So their idea of happiness really was the
pursuit of stuff, of goods.
And this is part and parcel of the
modern American dream.
Happiness is seen as pursuing stuff.
What Islam did is it radically altered human
beings' understanding of what happiness is.
Happiness is not necessarily a quote-unquote good
life.
According to the Muslims, happiness is sa'ada
in the next world.
If you're sa'id in the next world,
it doesn't matter how you lived your life
in this world.
And the previous class, when we were looking
at the sira, the du'a of the
Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam, when he said, if
you're not angry with me, then I don't
care what you do with me.
In other words, if my life is miserable
in this world, but I haven't incurred your
wrath, I'm happy with that.
Because he knows that the akhirah, chayru lakamine
l'ulah, the end world, the afterlife, is
better than the first life.
So anyway, the opposite concept of shakawah is
sa'ada, felicitousness, is shakawah.
Shakawah is the idea of, in the next
world, the person doesn't have akhirah.
They're shakhi.
That's what it means.
So Fubayr ibn Ayyab said that there were
five signs of shakawah.
The first one was kaswat al-khali, a
hard heart.
That's a sign of a person's shakhi.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said to
a man who saw him kiss a baby,
he said, I kissed my children.
I have ten children, I never kissed one
from them.
And that's the hilva, you know, it's a
pride in being a tough Arab.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, I
don't have anything in my deen for a
man who Allah has removed rahma from his
heart.
So hard heart, it means that you don't
have a portion of the deen, right?
Have mercy on those in the earth and
he in the heavens will have mercy on
you.
So kaswat al-khali, the eye that doesn't
weep.
And the ulama say, if you want to
know whether your heart is hard, then look
at your eye.
Because if the eye is dry, it's an
indication of a hard heart, right?
So the person who has riqah in the
heart has a wet eye and the person
who doesn't has a hard heart.
And the next is qillatul hayah, lacking modesty.
People that don't have shame.
If you have no shame, do whatever you
want.
If you don't have shame, do what you
So qillatul hayah is a sign of shakkawah.
Ar-rahvatuf id dunya, desiring dunya, is a
sign of shakkawah.
Because they say that no one increases in
his akhirah except that it harms his dunya.
And no one increases in his dunya except
that it harms his akhirah.
By the nature, because they're two opposites.
So increase in one is decrease in the
other.
Now this does not mean wealthy people automatically
you assume that, oh.
There's a famous story.
It's a story.
It's like a teaching story.
There's a famous story, some Moroccan story, right?
About, there was a zahid who heard about
this sheikh who had, that he was a
big wali of Allah.
And so he wanted to go see him.
And he came down from the mountain.
He was riding his lion.
And he gets there and the sheikh lives
in a big palace.
And he said, this is so-and-so's
house.
And he's shocked because he lives up in
a cave.
And then the sheikh comes out and he
says, where can I put my lion?
He said, put him in my barn with
my cow.
He didn't know he'll eat the cow.
He said, no, no, no.
Just put him in the barn with the
cow.
So he puts him in the barn with
the cow.
Then they had this big dinner.
And the sheikh eats a few bites.
And he says, astaffil Allah.
This is so luxurious.
He said, I live on water and dates.
And then that night the sheikh goes to
sleep.
The zahid stays up all night praying.
And he hears the sheikh snoring next door.
He's completely shocked about it.
He decides the next morning after Fudger, he's
just leaving.
So he goes to get his lion.
He goes in and the cow ate the
lion.
So he says to the man, where's my
lion?
He said, your lion is just like you.
It's all outward.
And he said, and you thought my cow
was a harmless cow.
But he was a lion inside.
Anyway, the point of that story is, you
know, you have to be very careful because
outward appearances can fool people.
And Sidi Ahman Zarrukh says an amazing thing.
Well, we'll get to that when we get
to having a bad opinion of people.
So anyway, those, and the last one is,
So those five things are a sign of
hardness of the heart.
And what this science is about is bringing
life to the heart.
And one of the interesting things in Norah
-li-Aqeen, which is the Sirah by an
Egyptian scholar, one of the things that he
mentioned in there was how the Sahaba lost,
many of them lost all of their dunya.
And he says in there, but he said
their concern was not, and he talked about
the first masjid built at Qada and said
this was a simple masjid.
In fact, he said a Muslim now would
not recognize it as a masjid.
And he said because now we've become obsessed
with ornamenting our outward appearance.
And he said in our inwards, our bereft.
He said the Sahaba were the opposite.
They had no concern for the beautification of
the outward.
They were only concerned with the purification of
their hearts.
And there's a big difference on that emphasis.
And so what he's saying is that, will
generate hard heartedness and indolence regarding obligations, which
leads to inroads into the prohibited.
What that means is, is this indolence, it's
a lack of energy to do things.
Now, interestingly enough, there will be people who
have incredible energy when it comes to dunya
things.
When it comes to Aqara, they have no
energy at all.
In fact, people say, you know, I really
can't pray.
I just, I work so hard and I
get home and I'm really tired and I
just fall asleep.
And I'd like to pray, but I don't
have time.
There are people really that literally say that,
quite literally.
That's a sign that their hearts dead, because
they have time for things in dunya and
they don't have time for Aqara, which means
they really don't believe in Aqara.
And one of the things Hassan al-Bassiri
said, I saw 70 men of Badar.
He said, if you saw them, you would
say, mad men.
He's talking to the tagine.
You would say, mejani.
He said, if they saw the best of
you, they would say, these people have no
character.
And if they saw the worst of you,
they'd say, these people don't believe in the
day of judgment.
So, the belief in Aqara is, will manifest
in the behavior and in the concerns of
a human being.
The more, the stronger they believe in Aqara,
the more they're concerned about their Aqara and
how to protect it.
Now, if you look on the footnote there
is, loss of energy for even obedient actions
and one will begin to convince himself that
he is unable to do what he's obliged
to do, due to his state, unless it
creates inroads into the prohibited.
In other words, he'll say, I just can't
do it.
I'm unable.
And that leads to the haram.
So, Ta'ala al-Amal is dangerous.
Now, there's a tradition.
It's not a hadith, but it's often quoted
as a hadith.
And the tradition says that, I'amal li
dunyaka ka'anaka ta'ishu abada.
wa'anma li ukhraka ka'anaka tamut ughada.
Act for your dunya as if you'll live
forever and act for your Aqara as if
you're going to die tomorrow.
Now, Shaykh Basheer, Asman Basheer, Rahimullah, a dear
friend of mine who was, lived in Medina
most of his life.
He was from Uritriya.
He told me once, he said, you know,
people don't understand that saying.
And he said, it's always used as a
justification for working really hard for dunya.
So, the dunya, when people love that hadith,
because they always say, ya'akhi, a'amal
li dunyaka ka'anaka ta'ishu abada.
He said, if you look at it in
the context of work for your dunya as
if you'll live forever, but work for your
Aqara as if you're going to die tomorrow.
He said, if you then look at your
situation, bifocally, one, your dunya matters, you have
forever to take care of them, but your
Aqara, you're going to die tomorrow.
He said, you're going to start preparing for
your Aqara and say, I have plenty of
time to take care of my dunya.
So, it's the opposite kind of understanding that
most people have, and that's really the way.
Now, the other thing is, that's insan al
siva kaminat dunya, in the Quran, karon, don't
forget your portion of the dunya.
There's two ways that's interpreted.
One is, don't forget what Allah's given you
in order that you can expend it for
Aqara.
And the other is, the dunya is there
and Allah gave it to you.
So, don't forget that there is dunya, but
the important thing is Aqara.
And these are both, they're both acceptable positions.
So, we're not anti-worldly, like say, for
instance, traditional Christianity was.
We're not against the world, you know.
The world is a place Allah made it
for us to enjoy as well, but not
to enjoy it to the point where we
forget what we're really here for and that
it's a bridge.
And then he says, and then another, the
verse in the Quran in which Allah Subh
'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la says, and this
is an example of it, he said, A
long time passed and their hearts became hard.
So, the idea is that if you're not
really thinking about Aqara, the longer you are
on the earth, the harder the heart gets.
Now, if you look at children, one of
the really fascinating things about children, they can
cry like that, very easily.
And part of it is that their hearts
are very supple, and they go into several
states in one day.
They can go from extreme joy to extreme
sadness in one day, right?
And it's very interesting why their hearts are
like that.
They're very pure.
And so, everything affects them in very profound
ways.
And as a person gets older, it becomes
more and more difficult for them.
And this is why, one of the things,
why the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam loved women,
one of the things that he loved from
the world or was made to love was
women, and the Ullama say, liraqati qurubihina, because
their hearts are more brittle than men.
Right?
Their hearts are more brittle than men.
In other words, women have more compassion, their
hearts are more open, things like that.
For men, it's very easy for that heart
to become hard.
And so, the danger of poul al-amad
is that it makes the hard heart.
And then he says, laki nuhufihaqri min nirad
an'ab, aukan ifi tarsniki ar-inmanlam yu
'ab.
Regarding the one who's engaged in preparing for
tomorrow or writing works of knowledge, I mean,
obviously he puts that in there.
He's a scholar, and that's one of the
highest things that you can do is, sadaqajaryah,
or ilm yun tafar bihi nas, like ongoing
charity, or knowledge that people will benefit.
So he's saying, if you're engaged in benefiting
people with knowledge like writing books, then it's
not a blameworthy thing to want to live
a long life.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, that's
a taman no almo, don't desire to die.
Because he said, if you did wrong in
the past, you want life to make toba
and rectify what you did wrong.
Or if you did good, you want more
time to do more good.
So either way, even if your life has
been bad in the past, each day is
a new day and a new opportunity to
make toba to Allah and to change your
ways.
So you should always desire long life if
you're engaged in good things.
If you're not, then what he's saying is,
it's a disaster.
So for people who are not wasting their
time and recognize the urgency of the human
condition and their own impending immortality and sets
out doing useful deeds, such as spreading knowledge
or anything else that's useful.
And Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la
says that, that what benefits, right, yam kuthufir
arb, it continues and it goes on in
the earth.
And one of Mu'tal al-Buna got very
sick at one point and somebody said, you
know, are you afraid you're going to die
from this sickness?
He said, la, la, la.
He said, I have an eye and the
Quran tells me I'm not going to die
yet.
And he said, what?
And he said, Allah says, what benefits people?
Stays for a long time.
And he was a great scholar, was very
beneficial to people.
Hard-hearted people that have a hard heart,
people whose eye, their eye doesn't really weep.
They don't have shame, right?
There's no modesty.
And then desirance of dunya, loving dunya, and
extended hope, false hope.
And then there's also a very beautiful hadith,
which says, Al-Ammaloo, Ahma'tum min Allah, Walau
lahoo, lamarara sahadi son, wara wadaat, ummun wadaadah.
The extended hope is a mercy from Allah,
for had it not been for hope, you
wouldn't see a farmer planting seeds nor a
woman giving birth to a child.
So it's a rahma from Allah.
That's the important thing to understand.
And it is part of our nature.
We really do believe that we're going to
go on, right?
And if we didn't believe that, I mean,
we couldn't do anything.
We couldn't function in the world.
You'd just be in a paralyzed state.
So the idea is not to go into
that state of paralysis, but the idea here
is to reflect on death.
You know, tafakkaro akhayfir motu, inhu nazirun, wa
rataupaylul amal, fayaksurak al-qalbo, it's right there.
In Qasidah, he says, reflect on death, because
it is coming, right?
It is coming.
And then he says, and don't extend your
hopes, fayaksurak al-qal, because your heart will
become hard.
And then the other thing about this, and
I mentioned this before, but one of the
things that is a good exercise to do
is to meditate on death and death state.
And that's, he says, fakir fiyakwar al-qayamati,
da'imakkabat, inhu nazirun, wa rataupaylul amal, inhu
nazirun, wa rataupaylul amal, and
to reflect on the stations of death itself,
like the seirat, to reflect on the seirat
that we have to cross the seirat, that
that's something.
And it's interesting, one of the things that
athletes are trained to do in this country
is visualization.
In other words, if they have a race
to do or a fighting, boxers will do
that.
What boxers will do?
Is they'll actually go through the fight in
their, like a visualization, as a psychological preparation.
And so really, this is the same idea,
is that what you're doing is you're preparing
yourself psychologically for a journey that you're going
to go on.
And this is, you know, like, Marat-Raj
has a kasida about death, and in it
he says, fasat usafiro, radhan al-yasaferi, you're
going to travel tomorrow, and what a journey.
Meaning death.
What a journey.
I mean, this is a real thing, that
the moment that you die, there's a severance,
and you're still conscious, only you're in hyper
-conscious state.
In fact, you're so conscious that this state
becomes like a dream.
And that's why people, when they die, they
actually feel like they're waking up.
And nesuniyem, people are asleep, say nahadi, and
when they die, he said, suddenly, they come
to their, you know, attention, right?
So, the idea of reflecting on death, of
one of the exercises many of the set
-up did, was actually lying down and imagining
being lowered into the grave.
And this is not a morbid exercise, it's
really, it's a training, you know?
And it's very effective.
It really is, it's an effective thing to
do.
Some of the ulema, they said, if shahwa,
if somebody has a lot of shahwa, that
that's a good way to control the shahwa,
like young people that have shahwa for appetites,
that if they do that reflection and things
like that, that it'll give some sobriety to
their state.
Now, another thing that's really important that Imam
al-Karate Radilah, who mentions, is the difference
between raja, right?
And ul-al-amal, raja,
raja is similar to hope.
And then amal is different.
So, there are many verses in the Quran,
warakat kannada kunfi rasoori dahi iswatun hasanat, liman
kannat yarful Allah, the one who yarful Allah,
they have raja of Allah.
So, there's a hope for Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, right?
Waliyom al-Ahir, and for the last day,
and there's a famous hadith, in which Aisha
Radilah Anu said, you know, the Prophet SallAllahu
Alaihi Wasallam said, man ahabbali kah Allah, ahabballahu
liya kah ahu, the one who Allah loves
to meet, who loves to meet Allah, Allah
loves to meet him.
And Aisha said, yarasoor Allah, that, you know,
what about disliking death, right?
And he said, kulu kumta karhonan mal, right?
That's a natural thing not to like death
itself.
But to not want to meet your Lord,
that's something the Mutman wants, he's looking forward
to that.
Now, there's something really interesting also.
The Muslim emphasized this relationship between khul and
raja, wadaabudhaminna'alay khulfinma'raja.
You have to have the two sandals of
fear and hope.
So, you walk with fear and hope, right?
If you're overwhelmed by fear, it puts you
into a psychological state of terror and you
get what's called yes.
The psychological result of yes is despair.
So, too much excessive fear leads to despair
of the mercy of Allah.
You actually think, I'll never be saved from
Allah.
And this is a very common religious illness,
right?
Less so now, right?
Because people are not as religious as they
used to.
But this was a very common religious illness,
and it still is for certain people.
There are Christians that go into this state
very easily that are in a type of
evangelical fire and brimstone Christianity that focuses a
lot on hellfire, damnation.
The pilgrims actually believed that there were only
144,000 saved.
They were called the elect.
Now, obviously, there were more than 144,000
pilgrims.
So, that kind of, your odds in that
religion were not very high.
And I think the Jehovah's Witness actually believed
that also.
Yeah, because it's taken from Revelations, right?
This is 144,000 elect.
So, that's big fear, too much fear.
Too much hope, excessive hope, is another disease
that leads to this lack.
It leads to a type of complacency, well,
I don't have any problem.
And so, one stops doing action.
And this is, there's an interesting article about
Bill Clinton and baptism.
And a lot of people don't know this
about baptism, but the Baptist religion has this
concept that you can really do anything that
you want.
And you're saved as a Baptist.
Because you believe in Jesus as your Savior.
And they have very little fear of the
fire.
They don't really emphasize that.
They really emphasize salvation through Christ.
And everybody's wretched, you're all sinners, which is
why somebody like Jimmy Swagger can, you know,
all that can happen to him.
And he can go back and actually preach.
And everybody in the churches, they're all still
sitting there listening to him, right?
I mean, if the same thing happened to
Imam, right, lata dar Allah.
I mean, that's it, you know.
Nobody's going to have any respect for that
person, right?
Because the Muslims have a much higher expectation
of the people that they expect to be,
you know, examples for their community, which is
one of the reasons why a bastard child,
it's makru for them to lead the prayer.
Not because they did anything wrong, but simply
because it's not a good kotwa or example
for the community to have as an Imam
somebody whose parents were not upright as well.
Mm-hmm.
Say a bastard child to become holy.
Absolutely, yeah.
No, there's no Itham on a bastard child.
There's none.
There's no Itham on them.
And it's between them and their Lord.
What their mother and father did, that's their
business.
That's Azir al-Wazir al-Wazir al-Ukhra.
No soul bears the wrong actions of another
soul, right?
So, and there were people in the Arabian
Peninsula that many people at that time who
were not, they didn't have legitimate fathers.
I mean, there were, the Arabs fornicated quite,
I mean, it was quite common.
So there were illegitimate children at that time
that did become Muslim, right?
And those people were considered the best people.
So, I mean, their worst people are better
than our best people.
Really?
I mean, the least of the Sahaba, in
terms of their actions, the least of them
are better than the best of us.
Simple as that.
And the Urahmas say simply by the rutya,
they were given the rutya, and that's enough
of a bounty from Allah.
They were given the vision of the Prophet
in waking state and believed in him.
So, now, right?
The amal is, what amal is, is a
desire to live a long life, right?
Long life, to have wealth, right?
To have those things in life that we
generally attribute to this state of happiness.
That is what amal is.
It's a hope for that.
It's a rajah.
And then there's something else which is called
unia.
And this is what's blameworthy in Islam.
And unia, unia is a hope.
The difference between rajah and unia is that
rajah, always the sabab is taken.
In other words, the means to obtain the
thing that you're doing is taken.
Whereas with an unia, it's bilah sabab.
The means is not taken.
So, for instance, if you, you know, you
want to get healthy.
So, what you do is you start watching
your diet.
You start exercising.
You start, that's called rajah.
But somebody who, he says, I really want
to get healthy.
He doesn't change that.
He's, as he's eating his, all his junk
food and watching television or something like that.
And he said, I really want to get
healthy.
And he's doing nothing to change his state.
That's called unia.
And that's what Allah says the Jews and
the Christians have about akhirah.
They have a mani.
They're not doing anything to get the akhirah,
right?
They're corrupting in the earth.
They're not, and that's why the Muslims, I
mean, they have to watch out to be,
because, you know, like my friend Abba Hakim,
Murad told this story about the Pakistani man
who has walked by these two, three racists
in London.
And one of them said, I'm moving to
Wales because there's only 1%, 3% Muslims
there.
And the other one said, no, no, I'm
going to Scotland because they only have 2%.
And the third one said, I'm going to,
you know, to Ireland because they only have
1%.
And this Muslim said, why don't you go
to hell?
They don't have any Muslims there.
And so what Abba Hakim said about that
city of the akhirah, what he said about
that was that the assumption, of course, is
that Muslims don't go to hell.
Unfortunately, there's going to be a big shock
on the Yom HaQiyana, right?
Because if you have a mani, and all
you have for your Islam is that the
shahada taim, right?
They call the shahada taim.
Shahada tawidada or shahada tawafat.
Your testimony, when you were born that you
were a Muslim, they wrote it on your
birth certificate, and when you died, right, on
your death certificate.
If that's all you have.
I was in Santa Clara, Farif was with
me once.
These people came, and their grandfather had died,
and they came to the masjid to bury
him.
None of them were practicing Muslims.
And their grandfather wasn't a practicing Muslim, but
he died, and they realized, hey, we're Muslims,
and how do we bury our grandfather?
Well, let's take him to the mosque.
And so they brought him there, and, you
know, we washed the body and did these
things.
But it's very sad that that's the extent
of people's experience of Islam when they get
married and when they die, right?
They have to have the imam to marry
them, or they have to have somebody who
knows how to wash the body and pray
over them.
So that's umniya.
So rajah, hoping for Allah, is when you're
doing those things that you need to do
in order to be pleasing to Allah subhana
wa ta'ala.
And then the other thing that the unama
say is that you should have hope, should
be overriding until when you get to your
deathbed.
At that point, you should forget all about
fear and just have absolute hope in Allah.
You should have no fear on your deathbed.
You should be completely immersed in a sense
of Allah's rahma and that he will forgive
me and he will accept me and have
a good opinion of Allah subhana wa ta
'ala.
Now, another thing that Imam Al-Haythami says
that Shaykhwal Al-Khadim mentions in his commentary
and this is really important, is that, ba
'ul al-amal, this extended hope, what it
is, is it's really a heedlessness about the
reality of death, which he says is not
a wrong action in and of itself.
In other words, there's no commandment of wudhu
that you have to remember death, right?
When the Prophet ﷺ said, that that remember
death, right?
And he also said, I used to tell
you, don't visit graves.
Now I tell you, go visit graves because
it will remind you of the akhara.
So the idea is that it's manduub to
do remembrance of death.
In the same way, it's manduub to do
dikr outside of what's prescribed, like the prayer.
Aqdul min dikri.
Ya ani tududu dikr.
Ud kur allah.
Ud kurul there is fair al-ammar but
it's for, it's an imperative, it's a command
but it's for nidud, it's not for wudhu.
You don't have to remember allah as a
fa'r.
It's manduub, it's mustahab, it's encouraged to do
it because it prepares you.
So that is not a wrong action in
and of itself.
And also, trying to make money, being out
in the dunya, being active in your dunya.
Ya, it's mubah.
Allah didn't tell you.
He said, You
can
actually go and sell things on had.
There's nothing wrong.
You can join dunya and aqr on had.
You don't have to go purely.
I'm only going, that's it.
No, you can take things.
You can take cents or books or whatever.
I mean, now I think it's limited what
they allow through the thing.
But it is permissible for the hudjaj on
had to bring merchandise and sell it.
And there's people that shave people and make
money.
They bring razors and things like that.
And they're hudjaj and they're making money.
Nothing wrong with that.
Our dean doesn't even frown upon it.
You shouldn't say stuff it a lot.
They're not spiritual people.
That's not from our dean.
There's nothing wrong with doing that.
So he says, That's permissible.
Unless it was for tafahor or takathor, or
litaswifa tova, then it becomes a kabirah.
Unless you were acquiring money in order to
compete with others in a proud way, or
to hoard wealth and things like that as
a way of accumulating massive wealth, or taswifa
tova, putting off tova.
In the Yomar Kiyama, it says about...
...
yafjura amamma, yas-eru ayani yomukhiyama.
So there's your pud al-amal.
Man wants to keep doing wrong in what's
left of his life, and he says, when
is the yomukhiyama?
It seems a long way off.
He doesn't really think about it.
And so, in the commentaries on that ayah,
the ulama say that one of the meanings
of that, yuridu liyafjura amamma, yusawifataw to put
off his tawba.
And this is what they call, in this
culture, sowing your wild oats.
Right?
There's an idea in this culture that when
you're young and you've got energy to do
ma'asi, get out and do as much
as you can.
Because you won't have energy to do those
ma'asi when you get older.
Right?
This is a concept in American culture and
European.
Sowing your wild oats.
And this is why Allah loves the young
man who is in obedience.
Because you get old, you don't have the
energy to be disobedient to Allah.
And you get some older people who had
really bad lives when they were young, and
then about 45, 50, they start thinking about
death, they make tawba, and then they become
these self-righteous people that are pointing fingers
at people.
You know, this is a problem.
Religiosity.
There's 50 years old.
They've been doing all the worst things.
They drank, right?
They cheated.
All these terrible things they did.
And at 50, they realized, oh my God,
I'm going to die.
And then they start going to the masjid
and become real righteous.
And then they start pointing fingers at other
people because they completely forgot about how they
were.
Right?
So, now, the next one is called papayor.
And this is a, it's a little bit
difficult because papayor had a jihadi concept, right?
Which is called piyyara.
And papayor, I mentioned this before, the Arabs,
when they wanted to do something, they would
go to a flock of birds.
It was a type of divination.
And that's why the word piyyara comes from
payor, which is a bird.
And so, they would go to a flock
of birds, and they would run at it.
And if the flock went to the left,
they took a bad omen.
If it went to the right, they took
a positive omen.
If it went to the right, they called
it a human.
If they went to the left, they called
it a shem, which is why, you know,
the Muslim cosmology, if you're in the Arabian
Peninsula, and you face the sun, which is
the natural in the morning for a man
to wake up, look at the sun, Yemen
is to the Yameen, and sham is to
the left, right?
So, you get that idea of human and
shem, right?
The sham is the place of the left.
And it's also called north, which is shamal,
which is what we get, shemal, which is
left.
And janub is from jamb, which is right
side because you recline on your right side.
So, the south is on the right side,
the north is on the left side, which
is also indicative in traditional cosmology that the
Muslims always on their maps put the north,
the south on the top, and the north
on the bottom.
And I can show you maps from the
traditional books of Tokit, which was the Imel
Salakh of the Muslims.
All their maps of the earth show the
south on the top and the north on
the bottom, which is why I really think,
and I've said this for a long time,
Muslims need to make their own maps.
And the reason that I realized this, I
was in New Mexico years ago with Hakim
Archuleta, and we were at a flea market
and I found a compass, an old antique
compass, and the guy, it was really cheap.
And he said, there's only one problem.
I said, what is it?
He said, instead of pointing to the north,
the arrow points to the south.
And I said, that's fantastic.
I thought that was great.
And then we were walking away and I
said to my friend Hakim, who knows a
lot about science, why does it make any
difference?
He said, well, it's just a polarization.
I mean, the paint's obviously just facing the
south because it's the Qatab, right?
Polarization, isn't that right?
And so I started thinking about this idea
of the south and the north and why
do we always make the north, the dominant
thing.
And then I saw a map that at
Idrisi, the first map maker of the world
was at Idrisi, was a Moroccan who did
a world map and he put the south
on the top and he put the north
on the bottom.
The European map makers actually took from his
book, but they realized the significance of putting
the south on the top.
It put Africa over Europe.
And so they actually flipped it over and
made their maps with the north on the
top.
And interestingly enough, if you read in the
book called The Venture of Islam, Hodgson's points
this out how he said, it's so unfortunate
that the Muslims don't recognize that they made
the first map and they put the south
on the bottom and they should go back
to putting the south on the bottom because
it's a completely eurocentric worldview that actually does
not have historical foundation.
And so we should make maps that have
Africa on the top and then Europe on
the bottom.
And we say, I'm going down to Europe
and up to Africa.
So we have to say, I'm going up
to Los Angeles and down to San Francisco
because in Arabic, you actually do say the
south is up.
In fact, they call southern Egypt Said, which
is upper Egypt.
And northern Egypt is lower Egypt.
Go down to Egypt.
And also in Libya, they say it as
well.
They say, we're going up south.
We're going down to the ocean, which is
in the north.
So this is traditional cosmology.
And don't think this is insignificant, the impact
that seeing maps all your life with Africa
on the bottom.
And then the other thing about a southern
map, nothing's over Arabia.
That's another thing about it.
Look at a southern map because I have
one that was printed in Australia because the
Australians caught on to this and they started,
they said, why should we be down under?
And so they just turned it right side
up.
Right.
And they, they made their maps.
I have a map from New Zealand that
was the other base I sent me because
I told her about this and she sent
me this map.
And it's really interesting to look at it.
It's actually puts things in a very interesting
perspective.
Start seeing things like how close Ireland is
to Morocco, for instance, and how close Germany
is to England.
You realize how strong the Germanic ties because
you don't get that sense when you see
a north, northerly dominant map.
So it's very interesting thing.
That's just a digression from diseases of the
heart.
That's, but there, I think that has some
merit, you know, about that.
Anyway, that was about of making the birds
go to the right or the left.
So is to take a, it's just a
superstition, but it's also more than that because
in the Arabic language is a pessimist is
somebody who always sees the worst situation.
No matter what, he's the one that's going
to say, it'll never work.
Right.
They're, they're pessimists.
They always look at the worst.
So he says, I'm not, I'm not, I'm
not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not.
It's based on the ignorance that everything is,
is, is a lot.
The affair belongs to a lot alone.
Now for the Muslim, what does that mean?
It means that you're going to have a
good opinion of Allah.
The non-Muslim has a bad opinion of
Allah.
The Muslim has a good opinion of Allah.
And that's the difference.
So you should always have this good opinion
of Allah.
Now he says here,
he's now he's going into bad opinion, but
I wanted to say one thing about papayor,
which is that there are really two types
of papayor.
One is where it's based on normative for
people that are in the Akita class.
If you have a hookah madi, a empirical
proof that things consistently happen.
In other words, you get near a cobra,
it bites you, you die.
Then in that stage, you have to use
your intellect.
That's not papayor.
That is a valid papayor, right?
So if you see something harmful and it,
and by the hookah madi, it's harmful, you
have to avoid it.
That's, and, and, and what the Khudem says,
if you don't, you're not considered from the
people of intellect.
If you don't, you're a fool.
Unless a person, you know, I mean, there
are people of Allah, like one of the
tajin was walking with one of his students
and they came on a path.
There was a lion a little ways down
the road and the student got frightened and
he said, go up on the high road
and he continued walking and the lion didn't
touch him.
Right?
So that's an example.
I mean, people, certain ahwad or something like
that states that they have, but that's not
for everybody to practice.
Uh, now another thing, imam karafi arad iman
who says a papayor is a bad opinion
and pira is the action that results from
having that bad opinion.
As long as the normative experience in which
harm results from that doesn't occur, like walking
under a ladder.
Right?
So in this culture, uh, step on a
crack, you break your mother's back.
Right?
And so when you were little kids, you
avoid these cracks, right?
Because it's a bad or black cat, 13
years of bad luck, breaking a mirror, right?
Uh, knock wood.
You know, I've been healthy for, then you
knock wood.
That is piyyara and that's actually haram to
do any of those things.
On the other hand, if the Sharia gives
us things to do, like to say, those
are things that you should do because there
it's not superstition, it's from revelation, but these
things are, this is actually pagan goes back
to worshiping trees, um, and knocking on the
wood comes from that.
You know, they had sacred wood and things
like that.
So that's what a piyyara is or like
for the Arab things like walking between sheep
to sheep.
That was bad luck in, in Jahili Arab
culture.
Uh, Bhuma to see a, uh, an owl,
right?
To see an owl was a bad omen.
Some cultures to see a shooting star was
a bad omen, things like that.
You know, those are all types of piyyara.
Uh, now the proposal lies and I'm setting
up also that you'll never be free from
the fire.
In other words, it's a human nature.
And there's a book by a skeptic, Michael
Shermer called why people believe weird things.
And a lot of it is about that.
He's explaining, you know, how we really do
have all these superstitions that are part of
our nature.
And that hadith indicates that, right?
So there's people, they have to read the
astrology before they go out on that day.
There's people that won't buy stocks or sell
stocks until they talk to their astrologer.
Completely absurd premise, but they believe in it
and it gives them this thing.
There's people that consult the, the I Ching,
the Chinese I Ching before they'll do anything.
Uh, there's people that do ramal in the
desert, Sahara desert, things like that.
People that flip coins, uh, or throw into
wishing wells.
These are all really part of, uh, human
nature.
So when the proposal, I said that there's
three things that you're going to get in
your life.
One of them is papayor.
And then he said, the way that you
cheer it is that if you, if you
feel that, that bad omen, just keep going.
So if you see, uh, uh, uh, for,
for, for us in this culture, if you
see a ladder and you're about to walk
under it and then that comes to your
heart, you just keep walking, but that's the
way you break it.
Right.
And if the plant falls on your head,
no, I'm just kidding.
But that is the way you break it.
You know, you just ignore it and keep
going.
Right.
And a friend of mine who, uh, has
a strong Iman, he, you know, he, he,
somebody who like claimed to be like this
wally or something like that, um, that he
didn't really think should be making those claims
and said something about it.
And they, this, these people said to him,
don't you know, you know, if he makes
dua against you, he can destroy you.
And so he said, you, let's make dua
right now against me.
I want you to make dua against me.
Because what he was trying to show them
was that's not the way Muslims behave.
Muslims don't make dua against each other if
they're real Muslim and a certainly a wally
is not going to do that.
And if he is a real wally, he
doesn't, a law will give you trouble.
Right.
Without him wanting it.
And there's a Sheikh, I know in Morita
and Muhammad Zayn, who you met, Muhammad Zayn,
Muhammad Zayn, it's known that people that speak
bad of him or, or, or have bad
news.
He's a, he's from the family of the
Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam.
And, uh, and he's very righteous man and
he's very, he would never do anything to
harm anybody.
But, you know, people have been known that,
that, you know, have bad attitude towards him
or something like that, that they have trouble.
So you don't want to mess with the
awliya.
But then on the other hand, like the
Moroccan say, don't belittle any Muslim because he
might be a wally of Allah.
You know, in other words, you should just
be aware of Muslims in general, of harming
other Muslims.
It's not a good thing to want to
do.
So that's the idea of, uh, of piyara.
And then the next one is the bad
opinion of others.
So he says, well, one is suspicion.
It's also opinion conjecture.
It's where you, uh, think something without having
any facts to support it.
It's a one, right?
Now the worst bad opinion is having bad
opinion about people who outwardly they have righteous,
uh, appearance and behavior.
And appearance was something that the early Muslims
actually considered important as well.
In other words, although they say, beware of,
uh, people who you might think have a
bad appearance because sometimes they're just Allah's veiled
them, but they have what's called, uh, an
wasma.
You know, the Arabs have something they call
wasma, which is wasim.
Wasim is somebody who has a good face.
Like when the Arabic came to SallAllahu Alaihi
Wasallam and left, they asked them, what did
you think of him?
He said, his face isn't the face of
a liar.
And this was, this is called firasa, you
know, having the ability to see in people's
faces a goodness or a badness that's actually
manifest in the face.
And so having a bad opinion of somebody
who has this wasma, you know, outwardly they
appear to be a righteous person.
That's a bad type of a bun.
What in the Baba Vani Itham Allah says
some of the fun is wrong action.
And this is important because generally we don't,
the heart you're not taken to account for,
but there is a Hiba of the heart.
And that is to have a bad opinion
of somebody that's unfounded that actually is written
against you.
So that's really important.
It's called Hiba Talqal.
And that's something it's not like a, you
see a lot of things you count for
what occurs to your heart.
He takes you to account for what there's
asm, what continues.
Asm is written against you in the heart,
right?
We'll go into that when we get to
the qawata, because there's degrees, right?
Hadyas, azimah, there's degrees of thought levels, hadith
and nafs, and azimah is the highest degree.
And that, and that is what's written against
you.
Run in the heart.
If you actually do believe it and it
causes you to have an effect on your
behavior towards that person, it's considered Hiba Talqal.
And it's actually a Hiba in which a
second person is not involved.
It's between you and your own heart.
And that is, that's not permissible.
That's why he's saying it's not permissible.
It's actually written against you.
And then he said, so it's azimah, it's
your, it means your heart is convinced and
you've judged him based on your heart suspicions
without a proof that warrants such assumption.
You don't have a Dalil for it.
So somebody says, why didn't you like that
person?
He says, I just don't, my heart tells
me something's wrong.
Now, obviously, and we'll go into that in
a second about, then, you know, following the
heart about certain things, right?
And the hadith, which is, says, yakkah, mawan
nathein, nawan ektabul hadith.
Beware of bad opinion because it's the most,
it's the most treacherous or the most false
of speech is where there's no Dalil.
You say to somebody, do you know so
and so?
He's a really bad person.
And he say, what's your proof?
I just know he is, right?
That's ektabul hadith.
That is a, that's a lie because you
have no Dalil and our sharia is based
omirtan akundal vawahib.
I was commanded to judge people in outward
matters, right?
So it's really important to look to the
outward and see the behavior and things like
that.
And then he says, le'ithma fishekki wadam
anastanada, lisababim fadam yukun mujarada.
There's nothing wrong with having doubts about someone
or having a bad opinion of him if
it is based upon sound reason and it
is not without evidence.
Ah, so this is a really important distinction.
The difference between shuk and vun is, vun
is you have made, when you have your
scales, right?
Shuk is where both the scales are balanced.
Is he good?
Question mark.
Is he bad?
That's shuk.
I've got doubt about that person.
What that means is, I don't know.
And I just, I have to be wary
because I just don't know.
That is not haram.
Vun is where you make the decision without
proof that he's bad.
Does everybody understand?
There's a really important difference that'll help you
in life.
So, now how do we deal with people
that we do get these feelings of doubt
about?
The first thing, if he is a fasik,
Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la says,
if a fasik comes to you, find out
whether he, what he said is true or
not true before you take it.
So, if somebody who's known to do kabayr,
a fasik is somebody who does kabayr openly,
or is mutahawan with sahayr openly and consistently.
He's always doing lesser wrong actions without any
care about them, all right?
So, that person is a fasik.
If they come to you telling you something,
you can't take that at face, you cannot
take it at face value.
You have to find out whether it's true
or not.
Now, if you have doubt about a person,
about his badness, shek, what Sidi Ahmad Zaroq
says is, and this is really good advice,
even though it's coming from the ninth century,
it's actually more pertinent in the fifteenth century,
and that is,
don't
trust anybody with your deen, your family, or
your wealth, until you've tried him at least
a million times.
No, a thousand thousand times.
And that's called hyperbole, it's mobalah.
What he's saying is, you better test them
and see if they're true and sincere or
not.
If you don't know, don't trust them.
One of the poets said, he said, A
good opinion in these days is foolishness.
So, think the worst of people and then
be on guard.
And seriously, that is what the ulama all
say.
When the perioding in is full of corrupt
people, then the best position is to be
distrustful of people.
It's not one, right?
It's just that you are distrustful of people.
You don't trust people until you've really tested
them.
Just because there's so many people that it's
just one, it's a time like that.
People don't have takwa.
They'll cheat you.
They'll come out to you smiling and tell
you, you know, what wonderful Muslims they are,
and this and that, and they cheat you,
right?
And it happens all the time.
And that's why the ulama all about Zakat,
time is bad.
It's, it becomes an obligation on distributive Zakat
to check out the people's situation.
They can't just give them Zakat.
If, if, if it's a good people, if
most of the people are good, then in
those situations you believe people, but when you
get corrupted times and people and somebody comes
and says, brother, I've got five children.
I don't have any money.
I need, then it's a responsibility for you
to go find out if, if their claim
is truthful and they cannot regret, they can't
get upset or angry about that.
They have to accept that it's not for
you.
It's like in this culture, they say, you
know, well, the bad ones ruin it for
the good ones, right?
Sorry, we have to do this, but we've
been cheated so many times.
That's the type situation they have to be
told.
Unfortunately, because, you know, we've been tricked and
this is an Amana from a lot.
We really need to find out whether your
situation is, as you stated, it's not that
we're, we don't trust you.
It's just, this is a blanket policy for
everybody for that reason.
And that's unfortunate that that is the reality
of it.
So that is a bad opinion of others.
So having doubts about people, there's nothing wrong
with that.
And then a bad opinion of a person
who there's ample evidence that he's a bad
person.
That's just common sense.
On the other hand, do not, do not,
if people make Toba, then don't hold their
past.
And one of the worst things you can
do is remind people of the past evil
that they've done.
That's a really bad thing to do to
people.
You should always not remind people of the
past.
You should really let people, you know, let
go of their past.
Don't you hold on to it, because it's
unfair to other people.
And then there's another one.
A good opinion of Allah and a good
opinion of the servants of Allah are two
things that no mutman was given better than
it.
So generally it's good to have a good
opinion.
Certainly of Allah and generally of the slaves
of Allah.
Now, one of the things that Ibn Ammar
said is no servant was ever harmed by
a good opinion, whereas a bad opinion can
harm you.
So generally it's better to have a good
opinion of people until proven, you know, by
Sharia, it's called Baratat Asliya.
People are innocent until proven guilty.
So you should not assume that people are
guilty until really there's ample evidence of it.
The other thing that's really important is the
opinion of Allah.
There's a hadith and tabarani, anandubhani abdi bhi,
saliyahuunna abdi biyama sha'a.
I am in the opinion of my servant,
so let my servant think whatever he wants
of me.
And then there's another hadith that clarifies that
which says anandubhani abdi bhi, right, famanvanabi ya
khayra, wajada khayra, wamanvanabi ya sharra, wajada sharra.
Whoever I'm in the opinion of my servant,
if he thinks good of me, he finds
good, and if he thinks evil of me,
he finds evil.
And that hadith is essential to understanding something
really important, which is the other hadith, which
is in the 40 hadith of Imam Noi,
in which he says that every servant has
what he deserves.
And then he said, faman wajada khayran fal
yahmadi lah.
If he finds good, let him thank Allah.
waman wajada khayra za'alika fal a'yala
manna illa nafsa.
And whoever finds other than that, let him
only blame his own soul.
The idea here is that if you're a
true Muntman, everything is going to be good
for you.
The affair of the moment is all good.
And a true Muntman, you will believe that
even the bad that happens to you is
for a reason.
There's good in it.
And that's a different worldview from people who
are the mutta pa'yar, the pessimist, he's
going to look.
And then we have sahatul qadar, you know,
why is this happening to me?
I don't deserve this.
What did I do to deserve them?
When fall them, right?
They, like the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said,
that if you're not angry at me, right?
I don't care.
If you're not angry at me, then I'm
not.
Well, what I think, what I cannot have
yet to oh, Sandy, but the Athia is
more comfortable for me.
I mean, I'd rather be in a situation
where it's not so difficult, but the difficulty
of the situation for the moment is still
a good thing.
And so that's having a good opinion of
Allah and a good opinion of others.
Next one is called the Ejib.
Now, Ejibul Imam al-Ghazadi says that the
difference between Ejib and Qibr is that Qibr
needs two people.
Qibr is arrogance, right?
And it needs two people.
You need the mutakabir, the arrogant one, and
the one who is having arrogance shown to
him.
So with Qibr, you know, if Zaid comes
and tells Amr, you know, you little insignificant
fool.
Why didn't you do what I told you?
He's mutakabir and Amr is mutakabir.
He's being shown arrogance.
Whereas the mutakabir is similar to Qibr, only
he doesn't need a second person, right?
He's just impressed with himself.
He thinks that he's better than other people.
If he has a mirror, then he's happy
because he's just looking and he's really impressed
at how wonderful he is, how magnificent he
is, now or she.
Well, Ejibul, it is the He says the
definition of Ejib is a Roman name that
you exalt or magnify the niyama, the blessing,
but you forget who gave you the blessing.
So what, you know, and this is the
thing where people in this culture, if somebody
says, you know, oh, you're so beautiful, and
they say thank you, like, as if, you
know, they did something about it, right?
And it's a very odd thing, you know,
if you think about that.
It's a very odd thing.
Now they might have done, paid a lot
of money or something for reconstructive facial surgery,
but they should still thank the plastic surgeon,
not the person himself.
So the point is, is that if Allah
made somebody beautiful, then they should be grateful
to Allah.
They should see the mun'im is Allah.
It's not themselves.
They didn't do anything.
And even if they have talents, those talents,
even raw God-given talents still need to
be developed, right?
So, you know, nobody is born with a
talent to do anything right.
No, they have to work at it.
A person that has beautiful calligraphy, you know,
it looks easy to you.
It's like I took a lesson with Sidi
Muhammad Zakaria, who's famous calligrapher, American calligrapher.
And when I watched him doing the calligraphy,
he made it look so easy.
I thought, I can do that.
And they say the sign of a master
is he does it so easy that you
think you can do it yourself.
Imam al-Jorjani, he said that the man,
the master of rhetoric is the one who
when he speaks, he speaks so with such
a facility that the people listening think, I
could do that, but they couldn't.
And so the same is true with all
the things.
But when you see Muhammad Zakaria, Sidi Muhammad
doing his calligraphy, what you have to realize
is there were years of patient perseverance of
doing over and over again wows and yahs
and buzz and then writing out things.
And so he did that.
And then you see the finished part, you
say subhanAllah.
And that's, and that is a gift from
Allah.
If he starts thinking, look at all my
accomplishments, which he wouldn't be, he's a very
humble man.
But if somebody who was given a gift
like that, he says, Oh, I work so
hard and I've done this all by myself.
And there's many people all over the world
that do this, right?
That think that it's there comes, I got
myself by pulling myself up by the bootstraps.
I'm the one that did all this.
And I, and that's more Egypt, the enough.
Because the, the moment sees if Allah gave
you Tofiyuk to be disciplined, that was from
Allah.
And you can see it within a family.
One person has discipline and another person doesn't
grow up in the same family, same environmental
factors, right?
One person has the ability to, to be
disciplined.
You know, they go on and they master
in their studies and, and they graduate the
honors and anything that happens, it's Allah who
did it.
In Imam R.
Baha he says, in the Allah, he says,
Allah makes every creator and his creation.
So Allah is the maker of the airplane.
Allah is the maker of the automobile.
Allah is the maker of the computer, all
these things.
Allah created the one who produced it and
what he produced.
Allah.
And once you realize that, then you lose
your urge of, you can't be impressed with
yourself.
And then the other thing to remember is,
over everyone who knows something, there's somebody that
knows more.
And this is what Musa Alayhi Salaam was
asked, is there anybody more knowledgeable than you?
And he said, I don't think so.
And Allah sent him al-Qadar, who wasn't
a prophet and he made him a student.
Then he even ended up not being the
student that he should have been, right?
And this was before his Nubuwa, but, but
when he was with al-Qadar, he kept
asking questions.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, had
he not asked those questions, he would have
learned so much more from al-Qadar.
So he didn't learn everything he could have
learned, but he learned, he was taught.
And the biggest lesson that he learned was
to recognize there's always somebody that knows more
than you and never to do that.
So it's very, very, Alayhi Salaam.
You have to be careful when you talk
about prophets and you have to be really
careful with the words you choose and things.
I don't want to say he wasn't a
good student or anything like that.
You just have to really be careful about
those things.
So I'm sure he was a brilliant student,
but he had a lesson to learn and
Allah taught him that lesson through al-Qadar
Alayhi Salaam.
Now, vanity, the reason I translated that vanity,
Urjib, if you look at the word vanity
in the dictionary, it's called accessified in one's
appearance or accomplishments.
It's very close to Urjib in Arabic.
Ajiba means to wonder or marvel at.
Urjib is to marvel at one's own self
or one's accomplishments.
And then vanity comes from a word, vanis,
which means empty, right?
And so it's the idea that the source
of our vanity is empty and will vanish.
Now, one of the things that the Roman
used to do, they had these victory parades,
like when Caesar would have victory, then they'd
have this huge victory parade in Rome and
they'd hold a laurel leaf over the victor.
A slave would be, he'd ride through the
city on a chariot and everybody would be
cheering him.
And he would hold this laurel leaf and
then the slave would say to him, all
is vanity.
He'd like remind this general, it's all vanity.
And this is an ancient wisdom.
It's a hikma to remind people that all
these accomplishments, one day, who's ever going to
remember it?
It's like Charles Lindbergh, when he flew over,
they had a huge parade for him in
New York City.
Within 10 years, he was a criminal by
the American government.
He was a Nazi sympathizer, right?
So the hero, I mean, there was a
great story of, I can't remember his name.
He wrote Secret Life of Walter Mitty, James
Thurber.
It's called The Hero That Shouldn't Have Been
or something like that.
And it's about this guy who like finds,
who saves this child and all the newspaper
reporters come to, and then they want to
make him a hero.
And it turns out he's this really bad
guy and he just wants to make money
out of the thing.
He did a good thing.
So he realized he's not a good hero
for the people.
So as he's looking out the window, seeing
all the crowds applauding and things, one of
the reporters pushes him out the window.
So the point is, right, is that there's
always, there's always going to be this other
side to things.
No matter how much good a person does,
there's always going to be people that are
tractors or it's just a vain thing.
Like now the Yankees went through New York
and they had these huge ticker tape parades
and celebrating the greatest team that ever lived
as the Titanic's going down, right?
New York City's like just complete disaster, morally,
socially, ethically, everything.
But we've got the baseball team in the
world.
That's our Egypt, right?
That is complete Mu'ajab.
New York is Mu'ajaba vinafsihah, right?
And it's really a bad situation when people
get into that state.
So he says, you know, and then he
says also knowing that as a result of
your impotence, you can neither create any benefit
nor produce any harm.
Your edges.
Indeed, vanity originates from nothing other than one's
ignorance of these two matters that he, Allah,
is the fashioner and giver of blessings alone
and you're incapable of doing anything.
That, in not knowing that, that's how you
get to Egypt.
So it's a disease that you have to
be on guard of if you do anything
well or even if you don't do anything
well, right?
You have to be on guard of being
more Egypt or, you know, more so for
women than men, but people that Allah has
given outward beauty, physical beauty, getting vain about
that, having vanity about how one looks.
I mean, men are susceptible to that as
well, right?
Certainly.
But for women, it's also a very dangerous
thing to fall into.
And then the next one is which is
fraud.
So he says fraud is to conceal some
fault or harm either religious or worldly, even
from a protected minority or someone who has
a treaty with the Muslims.
Others have interpreted it to be the adornment
of something that lacks benefit or making an
evil appear to be good.
So there's a hadith in which the Prophet
said, whoever tricks us is not from us.
So a Muslim is not somebody who has
this fraud.
And it's a very common thing.
And what are you saying is you can
be fraudulent in a worldly or an other
worldly matter.
So one of the in the Sharia, it's
it is haram to sell something without pointing
out the you if there's something wrong with
the thing you're selling, you can't hide that.
If you don't know it, you really don't
like you sell a car and you don't
know that the engine is actually in really
bad shape.
You don't know.
But if you know it, you have to
tell them.
And that is the issue if you don't.
And it's a disease in the heart that
enables you to do that.
That's a disease in the heart.
That's where it emanates from.
And also, I mean, I put in there
just in the note that this is certainly
prominent in modern advertising, which to me is
indicative of the fact that only a disease
heart could do that type of work.
And it's also something that the sophist in
Greece was something what the sophist did.
They worshiped rhetoric and they didn't believe they
were the they were really the first historical
relativist.
Right.
Relativism is that you don't believe in right
and wrong.
You believe might makes right.
Whoever has the most persuasive argument.
There's no truth.
And this is a very this is a
modern disease as well.
But the sophist were people who mastered rhetoric
and they believed actually the most important thing
was to be convincing.
And it didn't matter if you were telling
the truth or lying.
The important thing is you got what you
wanted.
And the way to get that was through
rhetoric to master the arts of rhetoric, which
they called the art of persuasion.
Right.
The art of persuasion.
And according to the Muslims, rhetoric is the
art of embellishing truth.
Right.
Presenting the truth in the best way, not
falsehood, very different worldview.
So the sophist were people who made the
worst appear to be the better cause.
Right.
And they actually said men are either wolves
or sheep.
You're either a smart wolf or a dumb
sheep.
If you're a smart wolf, you eat the
dumb sheep.
And this is very common in modern corporate
American culture.
Right.
Is that the competition you just do whatever
you can.
Well, yeah, it actually comes from wisdom.
A word Sophia.
I don't know if the actual Greek root
is.
I think I'm pretty sure it is.
Sophists were people that thought they were wise,
you know, clever, sophisticated.
Same thing.
Yeah.
And then he's going to go into really
a key disease.
And I think he spends almost as much
time on this one as he does on,
uh, on, uh, yeah.
And that's a rub up.
So I'm going to do that next week.
Is there any question?
Anybody has, uh-huh.
He met him before he was sent to,
uh, the Bani Israel.
Yeah.
No, he was a prophet.
That's, it's different.
I mean, a bad opinion of others is
just thinking that they're, they're bad people or
without having proof.
Hating them is something else.
Well, it's not having a one.
I mean, hating is an actual feeling.
Uh, it's an emotion.
Right.
And we'll get into it.
It becomes deadly when you actually act according
to it.
Oh, human and Shem, to Shem and Shem.
Human and Shem.
You want him in Arabic.
Anything else?
Where?
Uh, what
he's saying is, uh, the
fraud is to hide some, uh, religious or
worldly, harm, even if it's against a dhimmi.
In other words, you can't cheat a non
-Muslim either.
Yeah.
Just because they're non-Muslim, you have to
be upright in your, uh, transactions with everybody.
So Hish can be towards non-Muslims as
well.
Yeah.
It's generally, that's not a good thing to
do.
I mean, it's better.
It's easier for people to get beyond that.
If, if they're not reminded all the time,
obviously if they're repeating something over and over
again, and that's a problem, but, but if
it's something to happen in the past and
you remind them of it, it's, it's just
not a fair thing to do to people
because it doesn't leave that door of changing
open to them.
Any other?
What?
Yes, sir.
Well, it's also, it's probably, uh, related to,
uh, because, uh, Ashri is another one for
us, sir.
And you, sir, it might be like, sometimes
it's from the Abbad.
The Arabs will name a thing by its
opposite in order as a tafaul, like they
call Mahalaka Mafaza, like the desert, they call
it Mafaza.
And what they mean by it is Mahalaka,
but it's like kind of a tafaul that
it, it'll be a place where they don't
get destroyed.
So you, sir, by calling the left, you,
sir, it mean like for most people, it's
hard to do things with your left.
So if you call it, you, sir, it's
like a tafaul that it won't be hard
for you.
Aloha.
I mean, that's very common in the Arabic
language to do that, but I'm not sure
if that's the reason.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
Say now, there's a tradition of saying that
he said that, uh, uh,
one difficulty will not overcome two eases.
And the reason for that is that in
the, in that ayah, Allah says, inna ma
'ala usri yusra.
And he, he gives the, the usr is
ma'arifa, it has a definite article and
the usr is nakira, it's indefinite.
And then in the second ayah, it says
inna ma'ala usri yusra.
In the second ayah, that adi phlam is
called, uh, ahad.
It's, it's a, it's an adi phlam that
is a repeat of the first one.
So it's the same usr.
Whereas the usr, because it's a nakira, it's
a indefinite, it actually is a second usr.
So the idea is that even, that with
one usr comes two eases.
Aloha.
Uh-huh.
About like bad vibes, see how some of
the say it.
Bad vibes.
Yeah, that's like a sixties term.
There was a song, bad vibrations.
People used to say that, like groovy.
People have, they heard that word.
I mean, that's scary, but that, when I
grew up, that was a word.
Was that a word?
You groovy.
And that came from, uh, in the groove,
right?
On a, on a record, right?
Groovy.
You know, it's in the groove.
And so, and actually Dr., uh, Suneem and
Yang told me that hepster, now people know
like he's hip.
I think they even still use that word,
don't they?
Hip still around, right?
Hip.
A hip cat in Wolof language means somebody
who really knows what's up.
It's actually a West African, uh, term.
Hept cat.
He told me that.
Dr. Suneem and Yang.
So a hepster, and this is what happened
with the, you know, a lot of these
jazz musicians in, uh, New York and things,
they were hanging out with, uh, uh, Africans
from Africa.
And, and there was a lot of, uh,
cultural, uh, exchange going on.
And many of the original hep cats actually
became Muslim, right?
And, uh, some of the real big, uh,
jazz musicians like Pharaoh Sanders and John Coltrane,
they became Muslim.
And John Coltrane was a Muslim, because I
heard that from his wife.
I met John Coltrane's wife, Alice, and I
asked her, you know, is it true that
John Coltrane was a Muslim?
She said, yes, he was.
His name was Jamaluddin, and he was very
proud of his Islam, you know?
And he is considered the greatest jazz saxophonist
that ever lived.
I think there's some validity, you know, to
that idea that people do have, uh, bad,
uh, energy and people have good energy.
If you want to use those terms, I
don't know how well they work.
I mean, we would say, you know, he
has a, a good soul or a bad
soul.
A bad person, a good person.
And in Sijam, like Munsejem means somebody who's
in the groove, literally in Arabic, in Sijem
means to be in the flow, right?
Munsejem, somebody whose heart is Munsejem, you know,
it's in harmony, right?
And you can see it in music also,
uh, cacophonic sounds are, are not harmonious.
And there's a vibration, a sound vibration that
hurts the ear.
And then something that's, uh, melodious, uh, has
a good impact on the ear.
So I think it comes from that, just
people do get a feeling from certain people.
And certainly if, if I'm, all of us
had this experience, if you're around people that
are depressed, it's very easy to start feeling
depressed.
In other words, it's like entering into some
kind of, you know how the moon, like
last night, the moon had this real, uh,
aura around it, right?
And, and it's like that, you know, people
have aura.
I don't want to get started starting time
too new agey, but you know, people, people
do have, uh, you know, these fields that
you get into that are either uplifting or,
or they, they actually bring you down or
some are just kind of neutral, you know,
again, yeah, I would think that if you
don't feel comfortable with a person, uh, you
should not consider you, you know, to say,
I don't feel comfortable about, around that person,
uh, is not the same as saying it's
a bad person because I had, uh, one
of my teachers, Sheikh Hamid told me once
when he was a student, he said there
was a man who really liked him, a
student there.
And he was always with him and he
didn't like him.
He just didn't like him.
And he went to him and he told
him, he said, I feel bad because I
don't really like being around this person.
This person likes being around me.
And he said, you know, the souls are
regimented ranks.
And the souls, you know, some souls don't
feel harmonious around each other.
And it doesn't mean that they're bad or
something like that.
It's just some people, you might not feel
a connection and other people you feel an
immediate connection to.
And some of the Ulamis say it had
to do with the pre-worldly existence of
the Arwa.
The closer Arwa were to you on that
day of the mesh head, uh, the more
affinity you'll feel towards them.
And the further away they were from you,
the more distant you'll feel, uh, towards them.
So there are people you meet and it's
like instantaneously, you feel like you've known them
all your life.
Like I had that feeling with Sheikh Abdullah
al-Qadi when I first met him, it
was just like there was no, it's like
I knew that person all my life.
And, and, and I think he felt the
same way.
So you just, there's certain people you'll have
an instantaneous connection with and other people you
won't.
And then some people it develops over time
and there's wisdom in all of those things.
One is where you have a bad opinion
of somebody without having any proof.
Have distrusting people is not one.
In other words, as a general principle, you
are distrustful of people.
The Ulamis say it's, it's wisdom in bad
times.
It's wisdom to be on your guard.
Don't become paranoid, right?
I mean, it's just not to become paranoid,
right?
Do you hear what he said?
You see how he looked at me?
You don't want to do that.
That's, that's a psychological condition to be avoided.
Seriously.
The next section in this section is, which
means anger.
And he begins it by saying as
for the swelling ocean of all of these
diseases.
So what he means here is that the
ocean of all of the diseases of the
heart is anger.
And if you come to its shore, you'll
see what astonishes.
If you come to the shore of the
ocean, just the shore, you haven't even gone
in it and looked at what's it, you'll
see it.
Its waves and everything else about it are
overflowing.
So say of it what you will without
constraint.
In other words, say whatever you want about
and don't feel any constraint because it's an
amazing thing.
And there's a hadith that has some weakness,
but it's an important hadith in its meaning.
A man came to the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi
Wasallam.
He came to his front and he said
Yara SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam.
He said, tell me, you know, what's the
best thing to draw near to Allah.
And he said, Hassan Al Khulukh, good character.
And then he went to his right side
and he said the same and the Prophet
said Hassan Al Khulukh.
And then he went to his left side
and he said the same.
He said Hassan Al Khulukh.
And then he went behind him and he
asked the same and the Prophet said, Awalam
Tafqah, haven't you understood?
Let's Arabab.
Don't get angry.
And there's another hadith where a man was
asked the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam, what is
the worst thing that one, you know, occurs
concerning Allah.
And he said, his anger.
And he said, how do we avoid it?
Don't get angry yourself.
If you don't want a lot to get
angry at you, don't get angry yourself.
Keitha Matudinu Tudan, how you behave is how
what will be shown to you.
And then the famous hadith in which the
Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, Ya Rasulullah Al
-Sini, give me some advice.
He said, La Taqaba, but Karra Alayhi Al
-Sini.
And then he said again, that Al-Sini,
tell me, give me advice.
In other words, that wasn't enough for him.
So he said, give me some advice.
He said, La Taqaba, don't get angry.
He said, Ya Rasulullah Al-Sini, I want
some more.
He said three times, La Taqaba, don't get
angry.
So hadith and the controlling hadith is the
key to good character.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam, in that
hadith when he said, La Taqaba, the Unammar
of Allah, our scholars, that it does not
mean don't get angry.
In other words, don't feel anger.
Because even the Messenger of Allah said, Inna
ma'ana basharon aghab mithriokom.
I am a man, a human being, and
I get angry like you do.
And his anger could be seen in his
face.
If he got angry, he had a vein
in his forehead.
If he got angry, it manifested.
So the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam was not
saying don't get angry, don't have the feeling
of anger.
Because anger is not a negative thing in
and of itself.
It's actually essential to the human character.
And many things would never get done if
people didn't get angry.
But anger, if it's not transmutated into something
that's useful for the human being, it will
destroy him.
And that's the point.
So when the Messenger of Allah SallAllahu Alaihi
Wasallam said, La Taqaba, what he meant SallAllahu
Alaihi Wasallam according to our scholars, Imam Noe
and others, don't allow your anger to take
control of you.
Be in control of your anger.
And some of the Ulamah have said that
anger is like the hunting dog.
If you don't train it, it won't get
what you need.
So it literally needs to be trained.
Because if you don't get angry, many of
the injustice of the world would never be
opposed.
If people did not get angry, people could
go around with impunity and do things and
nobody would get upset.
That's not what Allah wants from us.
He wants you to get angry, but he
doesn't want you to get angry for your
sake.
He wants to get angry for Allah's sake.
This is the transformation of God.
Just like these other diseases, you transform them
so that they're no longer working against you
but working for you.
And the reason that he calls this the
ocean is because this will destroy many people.
They'll drown in it.
They'll drown in the ocean of wrath and
anger and it will take them to destruction
and despair.
Now, he's going to go into some dawah.
But at this point, I wanted to make
a diversion that's not really a diversion because
it's very much related to this.
Imam al-Hazari al-Adilana identified four essential
qualities and this is in earlier traditions as
well.
You'll find this in other traditions.
This is not unique to Islam, but the
Muslims recognize the truth of it and this
is why our Imams adopted that model.
Fakhradin al-Razi adopts it and others.
Imam Rahab Bispahani adopts it in his book
on Akhlaq and Imam al-Hazari adopts it
also.
And it is a model that looks at
the human soul and recognizes certain qualities.
And Imam al-Hazari says there are four
qualities in the human soul.
The four qualities that he identifies, the first
one is called Qawat al-A'il and
in the Western tradition they call it the
rational soul, Qawat al-A'il.
And that is that within the human being
there's a power that by its nature is
related to what man knows.
And then the next one is called Qawat
al-Qabab, which is the irascible soul which
is in the human being, it's the element
that relates to his emotions, the basis of
which is anger.
And it's interesting that Imam Jalal al-Dinur
Rumi, he once said that the wisdom for
the prohibition of Qamar is that most people
are angry and if they drink, the root
of their soul is exposed.
Because a lot of people get angry when
they drink, they become belligerent.
And so he said it's like a veiling
from Allah, not to expose people's inherent anger.
So most people at the core root of
their soul is this Qawat al-Qabab, anger.
And then Qawat al-Shahwa and I'm not,
I think I spelled it wrong, but it's
a concubescent soul, the soul that's related to
appetite, the appetitive, I'll use that word because
I can spell that.
That's a college word.
The appetitive soul is the soul related to
Shahwa, right?
It's your Shahwani nature, you have appetite.
And then the fourth power is Qawat al
-Adul which according to Imam al-Razali is
the Qawat that harmonizes these three so that
the human being is functioning, healthy.
None of these are out of balance.
Now, these relate to what are known in,
you find this in Western tradition and you
find it in the Muslim tradition.
The Muslims call them Ummahat al-Faba'il.
In the Western tradition they call them the
four cardinal virtues.
And the Ummahat al-Faba'il are wisdom,
courage, temperance, and
justice.
In the Islamic tradition they call this hikmah,
shajjah, tahr, tahr, fafah, and adel.
Now, when the rational soul is balanced, the
result is hikmah, and Allah subhanahu wa ta
'ala says, waminyut sahikmah fakad utiya khairan kahirah,
whoever is given And hikma is given much
good.
And hikma, according to Imam al-Ghazali, is
the mean between balada and chada.
If the wisdom of the human being, in
other words, their intellectual, the rational soul, if
it's in want, the result is stupidity.
People do stupid things.
And if it becomes excessive, the result is
trickery.
They become clever and use their intellect for
manipulation, for tricking, exploiting people, right?
And which is an essential quality in order
to get a job as the CEO, usually,
right?
CEOs tend to be people that have this
excess of this qawat al-ilm, but they
use it for manipulation, right?
Now, shajya is when your irascible soul, your
ghada, is under control.
And it is a mean between two things.
It's a mean between tahawr or impetuousness, irrational
behavior, where people completely lose control, they become
angry, they don't have any control over themselves,
and then they do things that they regret
afterwards.
That's one level.
Or jibanna, cowardice.
They don't have enough ghada.
They're too afraid to act.
And these are both extremes.
One is deficient, nakhs, and the other is
ziyada.
And tidal is from the hadith khayrul, umar
al-sahtohah, kadarika ja'anaka ummat an-wasahpa.
We made you a middle people, a people
of wisdom, hikma, a people of shajyaa, right?
These virtues, if they're balanced, they become the
qualities of the human being.
And then iffah is the middle way of
qawat al-shahwa.
And it's a mean between jumud, which is
where there's no energy, indifferent.
They don't have shahwa, right?
They really don't have an appetite.
They're not interested in the opposite sex.
They're indifferent to their shahwa.
That's called jumud, which is unhealthy in sharia.
The Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam didn't like it.
And the excess of it is fisk, where
somebody goes into completely indulging in their appetites.
And they become somebody who's a slave to
their appetitive soul.
And they lose that balance between those.
So again, qawat al-shahwa, the balance is
the iffah.
You become afif.
And iffah is part of the sharia.
Allah Subh'anaHu Wa Ta-A'la says
that, you know, the ignorant people, when they
see the poor Muslims, yaksibum aghni yah, minata
'afuq.
They think that they're rich because they have
this iffah.
They're not out trying to get money.
So they have this iffah, this dignity in
their soul, that prevents them from going out
and doing things to get money through trickery
and hudah and things like this, because it's
in balance.
And then the adel is, it doesn't have,
it's not a mean.
It has an opposite.
And the opposite is what?
Ulm.
So adel justice is not in between anything.
It's the opposite of ulm.
Now what you can see then is when
these are in balance, you're just.
And when they're out of balance, you're vahlim.
You're oppressing yourself and others.
In other words, if you completely indulge your
appetitive soul, you've become vahrimun minafsihi.
You're oppressing your soul because you're doing things
that the soul was not created to do.
Khunu wa shrabu wa latsusrifu.
Eat and drink, but not to excess.
The middle.
Eat to what you need.
There's actually, I mean, it's a science now.
You can determine, based on your body size,
you can determine exactly almost to the, you
know, to the gram how many calories you
need every day.
And if you eat more than that or
less than that, you're vahlim.
Now Allah, out of His mercy to the
human being, has created a natural state.
You're in a fipra state when you're healthy,
so you'll eat to where you feel satiated
at a certain point.
And it becomes vahlim to your soul when
you go beyond that.
And this is why the Prophet said, khairu
sharu wia'an, malahu ibunu adam bakmuhu.
The worst vessel that the human being, son
of Adam, feels is his stomach.
It's a vahlim to your stomach because the
stomach has a haq.
And the haq is that you leave one
-third for food, one-third for water, and
one-third for air.
That's the haq and that's the adalah.
If you go beyond that, then you've gone
beyond the adalah of eating.
The same with your sexual appetite.
The human being has a sexual appetite that,
if it's expressed naturally, then he'll be in
a healthy state.
If he transgresses it and goes beyond it,
and this is part of this whole now
Viagra society, right?
Because for many people, as you get older,
that aspect of the self should be diminishing
as you look more towards akhirah and these
things, right?
And so it's very natural for that area,
but for people who don't have akhirah as
a concern, they still want to be engaging
in a shahawat that really they should be
moving away from and directing themselves towards the
akhirah.
And so they go out and they do
all these things in order to fulfill their
shahwa, which is now excessive shahwa.
It's a mental shahwa because the physical shahwa
is no longer there.
The physical shahwa is not there.
It's become a psychological shahwa.
So these are the balance of a human
being.
Now, by the blessing of Allah, according to
Imam al-Ahzadi, the only human being that
ever perfected the balance of these four was
the Messenger of Allah.
He's the only human being that was ever
completely balanced in all three which resulted in
him being the most just of men.
So his character is completely just.
His nature is ada'la.
And this is why the more you emulate
him in his behavior, the more you become
closer to being this just human being.
For this reason, the Messenger of Allah did
not fast all the time because that would
have been, it would have been deficient in
the iffah.
You're not giving yourself enough.
Nor did he go to the other extreme,
but he was in the middle.
He said, some days I fast and some
days I eat.
Ashbat wa ajua.
This is a balance between the human being.
The Prophet ﷺ did not become angry when
it was inappropriate.
He became angry when it was appropriate and
this was his shajaa.
He became angry when the state needed a
mokef.
Imam al-Ahzadi says that, the oboe is
to be angry in the right time, in
the right place, to the right person, with
the right amount.
And how do you do that?
By looking at the Messenger of Allah and
what he did when he became angry because
he never allowed his anger to get the
best of him to where he prayed against
people.
He never allowed his anger to get the
best of him where he struck people.
He didn't.
He controlled it.
And that is shajaa.
The Prophet ﷺ also, an adamo kumbila, he
had more knowledge than any human being.
And it's perfectly balanced knowledge.
There's nothing foolish in his behavior.
He never displayed anything that would indicate that
there was any thing that was imprudent, that
was incorrect for somebody to do who had
wisdom.
Nor did he use his intellectual gifts for
anything that was clever or trickery.
He didn't use it to gain dunya.
He didn't use it to do these things.
He used it for the sake of Allah,
where it was appropriate.
Now, one of the things, and this is
Imam Sayyuti, sometimes in his book he said,
I didn't see anybody get this before me.
I have never seen this in a book,
but I actually, I was reading called the
Abu Bakr, and he mentioned about Abu Bakr.
He said no one was more courageous than
Abu Bakr of the Ummah after the Messenger
of Allah.
And I started thinking about that quality of
Abu Bakr, more courageous, which resulted in a
talk that I gave called, Abu Bakr and
Courage.
And it was talking about this virtue.
But then I realized something about the Khunafah
Rashidin.
Each one of them embodies one of these
virtues as his dominant character.
So you can see, obviously, Hikma is Sayyidina
Ali, because he's Bab al-Il.
And Shajjah is Abu Bakr.
And everybody knows Omar the Jeff.
Now, the only one I was worried about
was, Uthman, does it really work?
And I looked up the word Iffat to
get the exact definition, and immediately after it
in the Qamos of Pharaoh Zabadi, he says,
well, Afan is the Afif Mughalah.
And his name is Uthman ibn Afan.
And that's what he was known for.
And if you think about it, what was
he doing on the day he was killed?
He was fasting.
So his state is complete Iffat, control of
his nafs.
And even the angels were shy before Uthman
because he had so much Iffat.
So each one of them embodies one of
these four virtues as a dominant quality.
But all of them, Ali was Shajjah.
Ali was Adel.
Ali was Hakim.
Ali was Afif.
But the dominant characteristic is Hikma.
That's what he was given.
Say, no, Abu Bakr was Adam.
He was Shud...
He was Afif.
He was Adel.
But you can see in his Mu'aqif,
Shujjah.
Because the Shujjah, the courageous one, is the
one that does not waver when other hearts
waver.
That's the definition of courage is, tabats, andar
masa'id.
And if you look at all of these
events that took place in the history of
the Seerah, it was Abu Bakr who was
tabat.
He was the one that never wavered when
everybody wavered.
And that's why the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
said, I presented Islam to everyone, and the
only one that didn't waver was Abu Bakr.
His heart was Shujjah.
He was...
I mean, that's his nature, Shujjah.
So, now, there's another really interesting thing about
this.
If you look at the Seerah al-Mustaqim,
Mustaqim means upright.
And Istiqama is ertidal.
In the prayer, in order to be...
your prayer to be valid, you have to
be mu'atadil.
And mu'atadil in Arabic means upright, but
it also means perfectly balanced.
So, the Seerah al-Mustaqim is the perfectly
balanced path.
And there's two ways you can deviate.
You either deviate through what?
You either go through Nax or Ziyada.
That's the only way you can deviate from
the path.
You either are deficient in what's wajib, or
you're excessive.
And these two deviations of the Jews and
the Christians.
The Christians are excessive.
They went beyond what they were told to
do.
Rahabaniyaf, tada'u'ah, makatibna'alayhimu.
They invented monkari.
We didn't write it for them.
They went to an excess.
Isti'ah, marbatidah.
They wanted to gain Allah's riva.
So, that's why they did it.
Famara'a'auha, haqqari, ayatihah.
But then they weren't able to fulfill it.
They went to excess, and that's the nature
of excess.
The excess, you can't fulfill it.
You can't, by its nature.
That's why it's so dangerous.
Iyakum wa l'ulufidin.
InAllahu Alaihi Wasallam.
Don't go to excess because Allah does not
taper off until you taper off, in His
reward.
When you go to excess, you get worn
out.
It's not balanced.
And so, the Jew goes to excess.
He becomes a Puritan.
He swears off sexual relations.
He fasts every day.
I'm talking about archetypally, the Christian ideal.
This is the Christian ideal.
He becomes this Puritan.
And he goes to an extreme of iffah,
which becomes its opposite.
And not the opposite, but it becomes an
excess.
It's no longer in the balance.
He's gone to this extreme.
And what happens is, that will always result
in going to the opposite.
Because when you go to an extreme, you
end up reverting back to its opposite.
So, they go to this extreme of asceticism,
way, way out here.
And then they flip all the way over
to modern American society, where it's all shehiwet.
Indulge your shehiwet.
They came here as Puritans.
That's why they came to this country originally.
The pilgrims.
They came here to be the perfect religious
people, and they rejected the European society that
they felt was this extreme society of shehiwets.
So, they came here to reject all their
shehiwet, and they ended the opposite, which is
extreme shehiwet.
And this is what happens with these opposites.
And then you can see in the shuja,
they go to the extreme.
They become filled with rage.
They tell them, turn the other cheek.
That's their ideal.
Turn the other cheek.
But it ends up with them being the
people that massacre more human beings in the
history of man.
The Christians have killed more human beings than
any other religious or secular community in their
history.
And now they have bombs of mass destruction
to do it.
This is all from the Christian mind.
Really, it's the Germans, the Protestants who developed
rockets, tanks, missiles.
It's all from this Christian madness.
And this is because they went to these
extremes.
And the same thing with justice.
They go to this extreme of justice.
They demand justice in everything, and what do
they end up doing?
It's all trickery.
Their law is all trickery.
They use lawyers to trick everything so that
they can get their way.
So it all becomes trickery.
So that this desire for justice in the
end, right, becomes, it becomes, no, the justice
becomes bone.
With the knowledge, it becomes trickery.
The knowledge becomes trickery.
So they use their knowledge no longer for
human development, for increasing people.
That was their original claim.
If you read the original Enlightenment people, it
was all about benefiting human beings.
Bacon, all he writes about is that Christianity
will maintain its morality and will be able
to keep technology in check and it will
free us and will be good people with
it.
They go to the trickery, and it becomes
a means of getting what they want.
With the justice, it goes to the opposite,
oppression.
And so their justice becomes oppression, right, because
their justice is based on oppressing everybody else.
And this is the Roman sickness.
Justice for the Roman oppression for everybody else.
So you can see, that is one way.
Now the other way of imbalance is the
way of the Jews.
The Jews did not do enough.
And this is Musa al-Isaram's complaint to
the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam on the Mihraj.
On the Isra, he told them, they couldn't
even do two prayers a day.
They couldn't even do two.
That's all they were asked to do.
They couldn't even do that.
They wouldn't defend him.
They said, You know, go, you and go
with your Lord and pray.
We're not going to do that.
So the nux is everywhere, right?
The nux is everywhere.
Now again, these are archetypes.
I don't want you to look at it
like, these are absolute.
These are archetypes.
In other words, within the Jewish fold, you
have the Christian phenomenon.
And within the Christian fold, you have the
Jewish phenomenon.
They're just archetypes.
They're ways of looking at human beings.
And this is why you can have this
Jewish archetype in a Hindu, in a Buddhist.
It's an archetype.
And that's the way of, if you look
at Rehran Magdobi, Alayhim Warat Balin, what happens
with the one who has vieda, he goes
astray, right?
He becomes Balun, right?
Now, it's interesting also that going astray, if
you look at the word, the root word
bal means to also be in love.
Bal, in Arabic, bala means he fell in
love.
And this is part of what the idea
of, you know, this excessive love that takes
people, it leads them astray, the love of
Kais, right?
Majnu.
And then within the Christian doctrine, or the
Jewish doctrine, you have naks.
Now, the Muslim is supposed to be in
the middle between the two.
And we could look at this as rabab,
which is the nature of justice, which is
the root of the Jewish tradition is justice.
Musa Alayhisan is the law giver.
He's the law giver.
It's justice.
At the root of the Christian phenomenon is
the idea of rahma, right?
It's the idea of rahma.
That's the root of the Christian thing, is
that out of this mercy, right, everybody should
be forgiven.
It's all emphasis on mercy.
And the Christian believes that they're forgiven out
of God's mercy, despite what they do.
Because all they see is mercy.
They don't see the habab.
Archetypally, you're going to get Christians that become
obsessed with the wrath.
But archetypally, if you look at what they
talk about, it's this idea of rahma.
Now, habab and rahma have to be in
a balance.
You have to have both in order to
be on the Sirat al-Mustaqim.
You have to have the sharia, right?
And you have to have the hakikah, right?
You have to have the law, and you
have to have the spirit of the law.
And the law is rules.
But the spirit of the law is rahma.
Allah sent down the sharia as a rahma.
Ma'ar sannaka illa rahmat illa alami.
We sent you as a rahma.
So what he brought was rahma.
So when these are in balance, this inward
and outward state, inwardly is iman, outwardly is
islam.
And when they come together inwardly and outwardly,
you get the musin, right?
You get this person who's a musin.
He's somebody who has islam.
And so this model here is a model,
really, for understanding what the straight path is.
Now, Muslims, according to Ibn Taymiyyah, Ahemu Allah,
he said they deviate, well, it's actually from
a hadith.
But he said that they deviate one of
two ways.
They deviate like Jews or like Christians.
They go the way of habab or they
go the way of rahma.
They go the way of the hair-splitting,
rabbinical, tyrannical, alim, which is what the Prophet
said, yakum wajababra tar'unama.
Beware of tyrannical scholars, right?
And the other way is the way of,
so this way is this kind of rabbinical
scholar over here.
And this way is the way of the
ignorant worshipper, which is embodied in the Christian
model or the Sufi, right?
The extreme of tasawwub is to go into
this state where it's all one and everybody's
going to heaven and there's nothing to worry
about and peace and harmony.
And you get people that talk, when you
hear them, that claim to be like people
of tasawwub and it sounds more like a
new age type of religion than having anything
to do with Islam because it goes to
this other extreme.
And the balance is to be Sufi fakhayi,
right?
To be inwardly the spirit of tasawwub but
outwardly the spirit of fiqh, of sharia.
And this is why Imam Shavri said, don't
be a fiqh and a Sufi and a
fiqh, don't be one of them without the
other because one of them becomes hard-hearted,
the fiqh, and the other goes astray, right?
So don't be one without the other.
And this is the balance, the joining of
rahma, which is the spirit of tasawwub and
the joining of adal, which is the spirit
of sharia.
Now, if you look, our tradition is closer
to the Christian tradition.
The Christians are closer to us because they
focus more on the rahma and our focus
as Muslims when we deal with other Muslims
should be more on the side of rahma
than on the side of wrath.
You should be more inclined to forgive your
brother than to condemn your brother.
That's a higher thing, right?
That you should forgive is closer to taqwa.
That's higher in Allah's deen than to demand
justice.
And that's why rahma Bismillahani said, that when
love exists, there's no need for justice.
And that's why the sahaba really weren't, because
the love was so intense there, they didn't
want retribution from each other.
They didn't want to take each other to
account, right?
And in fact, the first fitzana is when
they deviate from that minhaj and the adal
overrides the rahma.
Yeah, this is the first deviation, yeah.
Because Sayyidina Mu'ali al-Rabi al-Anu,
he demanded justice.
And Sayyidina Ali, who had hikma, he demanded
forgiveness because he said that if we demand
justice, we're going to rip this ummah apart.
Now Sayyidina Mu'ali, contrary to the Shia
position, we recognize that it was, you know,
there was a positive, we believe, we have
a good opinion of him.
We believe that his intentions like Aisha and
Zuber and others was really that they did
want justice.
But Sayyidina Ali was going to the higher,
higher spirit of Islam, which is rahma.
And that's why we consider him to be
Mu'afak.
He was given tawfiq in that ishtihad, contrary
to Sayyidina Mu'ali, who was not given
tawfiq in his ishtihad.
And that's why they're called al-fia, al
-bariya.
They're the oppressive.
And that's the danger of adal, is that
it goes to bari.
If you take it to its, you see,
it goes to that bari.
And they were unjust to Sayyidina Ali, rahma
al-Anu.
I mean with all our deference and love
for them and when you talk about it,
it's called Sayyidina Turqobra and you have to
be very careful because we're supposed to love
all of the sahaba, rahma al-Anu, including
Sayyidina Mu'awiya.
He was kathabirwahi and he benefited Islam greatly.
But he did, that is a mistake.
He made a mistake.
He's a human being.
He's not mafsul.
He's al-malawkharan.
So any questions about that?
Between stupidity and cleverness.
For example, Ish is a cleverness.
When we hear about people, and then when
it comes to, for example, there are many
and many that are kind of stupid.
For example, there is something like that.
They are afraid of it.
They are in order to be wise.
So they are, they have to be simple.
Right, when somebody has a cleverness, but that
cleverness doesn't take them to recognizing the truth.
In that case, by sharia, they're considered jahil.
They're considered, they're not wise.
They only appear to be wise.
To give you an example, we were talking
earlier about the utta, Ibn Rabi'ah, who
was known for his opinion before Islam, or
Abu al-Hakam.
He was called Abu al-Hakam, the one
of opinion, the proper opinion.
These people were known, and even Abu Hadifa,
when his father was killed at Badr and
he was thrown into the pit, the Prophet
looked at Abu Hadifa and he was weeping
and he said, perhaps you're upset with, you
know, where we've put your father.
And he said, It's not that.
He said, I just remember him when I
was a young man and how intelligent he
was and what good opinions and counsel he
used to give me.
And I always hoped that he would become
a Muslim and now I'm looking at what
he's taken himself to.
And that's an example, and I think non
-Muslims, who like myself, who became Muslim, they,
you know, are parents are not Muslim, right?
Like my parents aren't Muslim.
And I can see that my parents, you
know, they have given me good advice in
the past and I can see that type
of wisdom and I can see that thing.
And that's what Abu Hadifa was seeing.
For a Muslim whose parents were born Muslim
and they were born Muslim, they might not
recognize that.
But there are non-Muslims that do have
types of wisdom and types, but what this
type of wisdom here, when it's balanced, it
sees everything that is true as true and
everything that's false is false.
And obviously the only person that's ever achieved
that absolutely is the Messenger of Allah.
But the closer you come to the Messenger
of Allah, the closer you come to having
that wisdom that enables you to see things
as they truly are.
Does that make sense?
Any other?
The other Christians use them.
The Hellenistic tradition used it.
And even modern UAs?
Right.
Well, it's a wisdom at a Hekmatu balat
al-Mulman.
The wisdom is the lost property of the
Mulman.
So wherever he finds it, he finds it.
And you can see it in the Deen.
I mean, these qualities, they are cardinal virtues
because all of the virtues stem from them.
In other words, if you may give me
a virtue, give me a virtue, any virtue.
Generosity.
What is generosity in reality?
Well, what is it, though?
And what's a generous person?
It's not iffah.
Hmm?
Yeah, but what is karam?
In other words, somebody who can give money,
what are they able to do that other
people can't do?
Why can't other people give money?
Because they're afraid.
They're going to lose something.
So the generous man is really a courageous
man.
Because where other people have fear, they don't.
You see, they're able to give from their
shajah and their magnanimity.
And that's why Abu Bakr is the most
generous of all of the Sahaba.
He gave everything when Ummah only gave half.
Only gave half.
So another virtue.
This one, they call them the ummahats, the
matrices of virtue.
These are the matrices.
All the virtues emerge from these four.
Mercy, right?
So if we look at mercy, what is
mercy?
Mercy is not Adam.
Yeah, it would be, mercy would be hikma.
Because if you look at compassion and mercy,
for instance, Abu Bakr, when he told the
Prophet to be merciful to the people, what
was really behind it?
The hikma, that Allah gives with mercy what
he doesn't give with wrath.
So there's a wisdom in showing mercy, right?
When you show mercy, and it comes from
a knowledge that, and you can do that
with any of the virtues.
You can find where they lie in one
of these four.
And it's been done.
You can exhaust yourself thinking about it, but
some of the greatest minds that ever existed
in human history, they really exhausted themselves.
Imam al-Ghazadi goes into great detail in
the ikhya of showing how all the virtues
come from these four.
And he really exhausted it.
So now, how does this all relate to
rabab?
Rabab, because it's one of these kawas, it's
coming from something that's essential to the human
nature, right?
If you look at the brain, the way
the brain has been made, right?
They call the human brain a triune brain
because it has three dominant centers.
And this is also not so modern.
I mean, this is actually, Imam al-Ghazadi
does mention this.
The lowest brain, they call it the R
brain, which is really out of evolutionary theory,
the reptilian brain.
And this is the appetitive center of the
brain.
It functions, these basic functions, the drive, the
urges of the human being, the food urge,
the sex urge, all these urges.
And then there's the midbrain.
So this would relate to the appetitive.
And then the midbrain is where the emotions
are centered.
And from this model, the root emotion is
rabab.
And this is why children, the real first
emotions that they display are rabab.
They get angry, right?
And they express the anger through crying and
as they get older through tantrum or they
always learn that before they learn naan, right?
They learn no before they learn yes.
And you can see it rooted in that.
So this brain is related to the emotions.
And this is why there's a beautiful hadith
in Imam At-Kirmidhi in which the Prophet
said, He
said, He said, love the one you love
up to a point because one day he
might hate you.
And the wisdom here is if you tell
somebody all your secrets and then one day
they turn on you, which is a human
experience, it occurs quite often.
And people are often devastated by that.
And also don't hate people extremely because one
day you might end up being people that
love each other.
So be balanced in your love and in
your hate.
And so this is again an indication of
having a balance of emotions.
And when they get out of balance, people
become, you know, if you have too much
love, one of the Arabs, he said, Don't
be sukkar and get eaten up.
And don't be callousynth and get thrown away.
You know, don't be too sweet because they'll
eat you alive.
And don't be too bitter because you won't
have any friends.
So be balanced.
And that's the idea.
And then finally, what they call the new
brain is the neocortex, which is where this
would be the rational.
When these three are functioning properly, the human
being is Adam.
Right?
In other words, and see, this is part
of the human condition.
You have people that are excessively cerebral.
They're completely in their heads.
And it's everything's theoretical to them.
There's nothing practical.
They go to this extreme.
Then you have other people that are like
reptiles out there.
They're literally living like a reptile.
And I explained this once in a prison.
And some of these people, the Muslim inmates
really responded to this.
And one came up to me afterwards.
He said, you know that thing about the
reptilian brain?
He said, there's a lot of reptiles here.
He said, these guys are like snakes just
waiting to attack you.
It's an interesting phenomenon, this idea of people
in that really completely reactionary mode.
There's no humanity there.
And then you have people that are, obviously
you see them overly emotional.
They're either angry, right?
And that's the more common one, to get
people that are very angry.
So now, I just brought all of that
in there to put this into perspective.
Anger is one of the excesses of the
human condition, which is why he calls it
the ocean.
Because it really is the big one.
And there's basically three reasons why people get
angry.
One of them relates to primal needs.
Food, shelter, life,
those type of things.
That's the first type of...
Now this is Mejbul.
Yeah, and he's a human being.
If he doesn't get angry for this, he's
considered Ahmuk.
He goes under the category of stupidity.
Because this is a survival.
If somebody's threatening your life, you have to
respond to it, right?
I mean, you need to respond to it.
If somebody is threatening your family, you need
to respond to that.
That is a Khabib that Allah loves.
And Allah loves Shuja'a, wadauf yukhatiri haya.
Even in killing a snake.
And also the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said,
manmata duna madihi, manmata shahida.
Anyone that dies defending his wealth dies a
shahid.
So that Khabib, and because part of it
is, you don't want people to think it's
easy in a society to rob people.
You don't, I mean, you're acting, doing that
as a type, it's an ultimate amar-bir
ma'arauf and nahi'an in munkar.
And if you die doing it, you died
in jihad.
Because amar-bir ma'arauf and nahi'an
in munkar, it's in babble jihad.
It's a type of jihad.
So, the second type is also, and this
is common to human beings, the second type
is also common to human beings.
But this relates to position, right?
Or it relates to things that have to
do with ru'ryat and nafs, seeing yourself,
right?
In other words, I have dignity.
He can't do this to me, right?
I'm a human being.
And this kind of anger that people get
angry about that relates to a sense of
belittlement.
Somebody is belittling them.
Somebody is treating them with disdain.
Somebody is treating them less than what they
want.
And they could be right, they could be
wrong.
It just depends.
Because some people have a completely, they have
a complete delusion about who they are, right?
A delusion of the grandeur of their own
soul.
And so they actually...
And then finally, the third one relates to
specific people.
This is a specific one.
And this relates to, for instance, an anim,
if he sees a book being mistreated, will
get angry.
But the farmer who's illiterate, he won't get
angry.
Because he doesn't really understand, you know, what's
the big deal.
He sat on a book, so what?
Whereas the anim sees it, that's wrong because
it's related to his.
Now, the farmer will get angry if you
throw the pitchfork, you know, because it's his
tool.
What are you doing?
You know, you're going to break that, and
he'll get upset at that.
So this is a type of anger that
relates to specific people, right?
And these three are why people get angry.
Now, Imam al-Ghazadi says the first one
is healthy, unless it's taken to an extreme
where you go and oppress people, take their
food, take their shelter, do things like that.
That's oppression.
But the next one, he says, it can
be healthy up to a point.
But the higher way is to stop seeing
yourself and not get angry about these things.
And the danger of it is you go
to an extreme which is called ba'a,
and he'll deal with that.
It's a disease, which is where you become
so humble that you become humiliated.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam says, al
-Mukminu layudilunafsa, the Mukman does not humiliate himself.
And Allah says that there is an al
-Kufar, ruhama'u bainohum.
They have izzah when it comes to the
non-Muslims.
You're not all humble and meek and Uriah
Heath obsequiousness.
You have izzah with the kafir.
He shouldn't see you as being humble and
weak like that, in the face of him.
Whereas with the Mu'lman, you should.
You should give up those things.
And even according to Sidi Ahmad Zarrokh, if
the kafir says something to you that does
not relate to your deen, like not making
fun of your deen or something, then you
should just ignore it.
izzah katabohum al-jahidoona karu salaam.
When ignorant people speak to them, they just
say salaam.
You shouldn't get angry for things that really,
there's no benefit in getting angry, because all
they're doing is pushing buttons.
And that's why Allah says, Just be patient
about what they're saying and then leave them
in a good way.
So just turn away from it.
Don't obsess yourself with it and let it
go, because there's no benefit in it.
No benefit.
And then finally, the fourth one, again, if
there's ghayra, ghayra is something that Sa'ad
Rabbilah Anu when the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
was mentioning about the wife, and Sa'ad
said, And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said,
I have more ghayra than Sa'ad.
And Allah has more ghayra than I do.
In other words, that is a good sign.
Ghayra is a good thing.
And they say, ghayra, sometimes it's translated as
jealousy.
It's an idea of something that you are
in protection of or something that's yours, that
not letting somebody else do harm to it.
A ghayra takes you.
So this is why when a Muslim sees
the non-Muslim threatening his deen, he gets
a ghayra.
He becomes ghayr for the deen.
He wants to defend the deen.
And that's a good thing.
That's an anger that's positive.
And this is why Allah has made ghayra
part of the human nature to protect Nisib.
Because if men didn't have ghayra for their
women, they would lose Nisib.
People would go and commit adultery with their
women and then you would have a mixture
of the Nisib.
So ghayra is a healthy thing for a
man to have.
To be jealous of his wife is a
good thing as long as it doesn't go
to, obviously, an excess where he oppresses her
and becomes suspicious.
And it's also a natural thing for the
woman to have that ghayra, right?
I mean, Allah has made Mubarak.
He permitted the marriage of more than one
wife.
But the actual experience of a woman towards
the man of ghayra is natural.
It's part of human nature.
And very few women are free from that.
So it's not considered a fault, right?
Right?
Now he says here, He
says that this disease has two cures.
One of them will remove the anger when
it comes, right?
So that you prevent it from coming.
And the second will suppress the anger.
Now Allah says in the Quran, He praises,
Those who suppress their anger, and those who
forgive people.
And that's the famous story of Jafar al
-Payar when one of his servants was pouring
and spilled water on him, he became angry,
and the servant immediately said, And he said,
You know, I suppressed it.
And he said, And he said, You know,
I forgive you.
And he said, And he said, He said,
You're free for the sake of Allah.
And that's the way the moment should be.
He should be somebody when he hears the
Quran.
In other words, if somebody is backlighting and
somebody says, He should immediately say, He shouldn't
get angry at the person that he reminded
him.
And I was once told the story of
Sheikh, Ibn al-Habib, that a man was
with him in a gathering, and he said
one of his qualities, he was a Moroccan
Sheikh, he said one of his qualities was
he never spoke a Hiba about anybody.
And this is also something that I was
told by several people who have been with
him for over 70 years, and they've said
they never heard him once speak badly of
a person, ever.
And these are people that live with him
every day of his life, see him every
day.
In 70 years, they said they never heard
him once say anything bad about anybody, ever.
And, you know, somebody wrote me a letter
not that long ago and said, and he's
somebody that I think has a lot of
taqwa, but he wrote me a letter and
he said that he mentioned me in another
letter to somebody and he thinks maybe there
was some Hiba in it, so he sent
the letter with the thing, he said if
you find any Hiba in it, please tell
me so that I can make taqwa.
And he was questioning what he'd said.
And it was just some disagreements between his
understanding and I understanding, which wasn't a problem
with me at all.
But that type of, even though you don't
have to do that, it's called istahla'alor.
In Sharia, you don't have to go to
a person and say, it's better not to.
Unless you know that there are people that
aren't going to, you know, because most, a
lot of people just make them hate you.
If you go and you say this and
I did Hiba about you, they'll get angry.
Whereas other people, you know, it's not a
big deal.
So, like the Prophet said, aiyaju a'adikum
an yukun, al-laya kunam mithru abiyabam dam,
al-abiyabam dam.
Just one of you is, are you unable
to be like this man, abubam dam?
He used to get up every morning and
tahsabakabiyerbihi al-anas.
He used to give his own good name
as sadaqa for people.
In other words, he would just say, Ya
'Allah, if anybody says anything bad about me,
I give the hasanat that they gave me
back to them.
And so he said, just do that.
You know, who cares?
In the end of the day, if you
start thinking about the grave and questioning in
the grave, the yomukhiyama, if you really think
about these things, you're not going to care.
I mean, once, the moment you die, you
could care less if so-and-so, you
know, said one day that he gets angry
too much.
Or he said to you one day, something
that made you angry.
Ya'Allah, it's all going to be completely
irrelevant.
So, the two diseases he said, the first
one, and then he said here, fadkur litazdana
bihaalia rahiri, kathratamit al-khilmi wa ta'wabiri.
He said, remember, in order to be ornamented
with this quality of the thing that removes
anger, remember the praise of him and ta
'wabiri.
Because no one gets angry who's a mutakabbir.
The mutakabbir, the mutawabir, he doesn't get angry.
Somebody who's humble, they will not get angry
for themselves.
They might get angry for Allah, but they
won't get angry for themselves.
Because, The only reason people get angry is
because they're seeing themselves.
And if the self's not there to see,
then, you know, why get angry?
If somebody says, it's like the Prophet, when
they called him, Muḍamman, they called him the
opposite of his name.
He said, it's amazing how Allah took the
tongues of Quraysh that wanted to condemn me
and they condemned some guy named Muḍamman.
And I'm Muhammad.
So he didn't get angry, he just said,
they're not talking about me, they're talking about
Muḍamman.
So that's that idea of just letting it
go.
If you don't see yourself, there's no, there's
no self to get angry.
And that's Tawada.
And what he's saying is, in order to
get this quality, remember how much humility and
forbearance is praised.
In other words, every culture praises traditional.
This culture no longer does.
They used to.
I mean, humility.
There are still people that will do that.
But there's definitely one of the things that
certain Eastern European elements that immigrated here introduced
into the culture was a concept of chutzpah.
This idea of over weaning pride where you
literally, if you've got it, flaunt it type
thing.
And this has become something which is actually
alien to traditional American culture.
Traditionally, Americans actually did appreciate the quality of
humility.
generally, I mean, it's obviously you're going to
get a lot of different people.
But what you'll find is humility is praised
by all the sages even outside of the
religion of Islam.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, The
one that is humble for Allah's sake, Allah
raises him up.
And whoever raises himself up, Allah lowers him
down.
And Qaswa, the camel of the Prophet SallAllahu
Alaihi Wasallam, it used to race outwind all
of the camels of the Arabs and the
Sahaba really liked that because it was the
Prophet's camel.
But one day it lost a race to
a Bedouin and they all got really upset.
And the Prophet laughed.
And he said, Don't you know that nothing
ever gets elevated except Allah has to bring
it down?
Right?
So it's the sunnah of Allah in his
creation.
And if you understand the sunnah, you can
laugh at things like that.
You don't get upset.
So he's saying, if you really reflect on
the praiseworthy quality of hilman tawada and qana
ahaman nas the Prophet was the most forebearing
of people.
He forgave people.
He did not get angry.
He was very forebearing.
And then and then he also said fishari,
washiri also in poetry humility and forbearance is
always praised in poetry.
Right?
So he's saying that you'll find this in
the shari'ah and in shi'ar.
Wannatha ral hukama and all the sages also
in their writing.
Wawaswil ambiya yatoran bihima and that all of
the Prophets all of them have been characterized
with humility and forbearance.
None of them were known as being arrogant
or easily angered.
They were all known to have hilman tawada.
And then he said, wadabahu yahsurubistishari alayh sata
irum siwal kahari You can prevent it or
suppress it by recognizing that there's no action
except that it's from Allah.
So part of when things happen that make
you angry you have to take some breath
and just say la ilaha illa Allah.
This is a bala from Allah.
It's a tribulation from Allah to see, ayukum
ahasen wa amalah.
Who of you are the best in action?
And so the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said
laysa shadid shadid al surah wainama shadid manghalaba
nafsahu andirahabab The strong man is not the
one who can wrestle people down but the
strong man is the one who overcomes his
self when he becomes angry.
That's the shadid.
That's the real strong man.
It's not the other thing.
And one of the things that Imam al
-Ghazari says is the hamaka of some people
he said is that they see virility and
this macho type of posturing as a good
character or quality.
They become completely short.
And so he said you'll even see a
man who brags about his criminal exploits and
how he robbed somebody and fought him and
did these things and he'll actually brag about
what he thinks is courage.
Right?
And it's not.
It's all, there's nothing virtuous in it whatsoever.
So that's recognizing that only Allah is the
one that, you know, well actually the hadith
says first if you're standing to sit and
if you're sitting to recline and then if
neither of those help to go do wudu
and then to start praying.
So he does it this way but doing
wudu will actually put off the heat because
anger is fire and anger is from sha
'apan.
It's the quality of sha'apan.
And one day the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
was there and somebody became angry and his
face became red and his veins started bulging
and the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said SubhanAllah,
have you noticed how one of you when
he gets angry his face starts looking like
a sha'apan.
And he said I would that if he
said it that would be removed from him.
And I was once in a like a
conflict type resolution situation and it was really
interesting because it started getting heated and both
parties stood up.
They were on couches and they both stood
up at the same time.
And I made them sit down but that's
the nature of anger.
You start rising and the way that you
overcome that is to sit down.
Just to sit down.
If you're in a room and you begin
to feel anger leave the room.
If somebody is making you angry just leave
the room.
Go to another place relax, sit down and
let your anger subside and you can go
back.
And this is a practice if you do
it it works.
And if you don't you'll either end up
duking it out and if he's bigger than
you he beats you up.
And if he's smaller than you everybody sees
you as a heel because you're picking on
somebody smaller than you.
So just the best thing to do is
just avoid it.
There's no benefit in it.
There's none.
It's just empty, meaningless tripe and it's just
best to get out of it.
So do, that's the sunnah.
To do that.
Cold water.
To be quiet.
To sit down.
And then to outwood.
Those all came in the sunnah.
Now Imam al-Razadi said that one man
who had a fierce temper actually hired a
man to insult him and pay him money
to say like, and he would listen until
he could control himself.
That's probably extreme but the point is people
took these things very seriously.
Because you don't want to have anger.
It's a horrible quality.
Now, there is a hadith in which the
Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said Al-Hiddatul tariqiyara
ummeti Anger will even afflict the best of
my ummah.
And nobody displays that better than Sayyidina Omar.
Sayyidina Omar became very angry.
But if you look at Sayyidina Omar his
development as a human being in his Islam
by the end of it Omar was not
a person that his anger ever got the
best of him.
In fact, it was the opposite.
He would tend to be actually very forgiving.
And you can see this in his later
period.
And even when he was stabbed to death
you know, he asked the first thing he
asked was it a Muslim.
And the man said no and he just
he praised Allah that a Muslim didn't kill
him.
He just didn't want that a Muslim would
have done that to him.
You know, he said al-Handiyun.
And that was his nature, you know.
I mean even though he was very ferocious
and a lion of Allah he didn't.
And once the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam was
sitting with women from the Quraysh in Medina
and Omar came in and they immediately all
fled into the other room.
This was before the hijab came down.
And they were sitting and they all fled
into the room and hid behind this curtain.
And Omar comes in and he sees this
and the Prophet's laughing and he said Ma
'ad Haqqakiya Rasulallah Why are you laughing?
He said I'm laughing at these Qurayshi women
when they see you they flee.
And then he went over and he called
these women back, you know.
And they said Omar said how is it
that you you flee from me and you're
not shy before the Messenger of Allah.
He's more worthy to be shy before.
And they said But you're like more you're
meaner and harsher than the Messenger of Allah.
He doesn't get angry.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam he laughed
and he said Ya Sayyidina Omar Lao Sarekha
Fijian La Sarekha Shaitan Al Fijian Ahar If
you went down a path, Shaitan would go
down another path.
That idea of learning to control the anger
is really an example of somebody who mastered
that quality.
He really mastered it.
But again he's adal and ad is rooted
in abab but it's a health abab.
He wants justice because there's indignation.
He becomes angry when he's wrong.
He wants to write that wrong.
And he went to the Messenger of Allah
SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam where he was a Muslim.
That did in a desire to write a
wrong.
He felt it was wrong.
So it always rooted in his belief.
He had a very strong sense of justice.
And the Khabab family were traditionally bought in
the Jahili's abab culture.
So that is and let me see about
go on I'm going to Is there a
question they have?
I think was there a question over here?
They do have what?
I mean personally
for children that are under seven you have
to really be careful about becoming angry with
them.
If they're over seven then you need to
display discipline.
I mean they have to be disciplined.
In fact interestingly enough I didn't mention this
but in in these three souls the question
was about getting angry if you're a teacher
and you need to establish discipline.
In the souls the three souls the stages
are the first seven years are the appetitive
soul.
So that's why you see children are constantly
eating, wanting you know it's all shahawat and
fulfilling their appetitive soul.
And then the second seven years is the
Khabab and then the third is the rational
or the ilm.
So the this is the first.
So if they're in the second this is
why the hadith says la'ibohum li sabirin
and luh'ud is fulfilling shahawah.
Right?
Because the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said that
there's no luh'ud in Islam except one
of them is with the spouse.
Right?
That's a good luh'ud to play with
your wife.
And the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam played with
his wife.
It was muda'adah and this type thing.
So the the hadith of SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
was la'ibohum li sabirin play with them
for seven years during this period of the
appetitive soul just allow them to indulge themselves.
It's part of what they're meant to do.
They're discovering the world and it's all sensual
because they've been in a spiritual realm and
now they've moved into the realm of sensory
and so they have to come into their
bodies and they have to experience it and
that's why oftentimes children things will happen to
them that are quite traumatic like they get
burnt in those first seven years they fall
from high places these are all learning to
come into their body and discovering that they
have a body it's a hikmah of Allah
that those things happen to children because they're
literally to teach them the limitations of the
body that the body has limits and unlike
the ruah which is a more limitless type
of entity the body is limited and the
sharia is a protection for the body it's
touch fire you stay away from high places
you don't endanger yourself and so you know
you allow them to discover the world that
those first seven years it really is discovering
the world and that's why a hudam the
root of hudam is to lust raluma means
to lust so it's a lusty experience they're
very sensuous they like touch a lot children
like to be touched a lot and it's
part of their development of discovering their bodies
and then this period he said ad-dibuhum
lisadrin now you have to discipline them because
now their habab needs to be disciplined they're
moving into another stage they need now to
have discipline and the discipline is when you
see them getting angry you don't allow them
to do that you don't let children get
angry at the parent that's a bad sign
you have to teach them to control their
anger and if you're not controlling your anger
it's a disaster if you don't have something
you can't give it to somebody else so
if they see you getting angry all the
time they're just going to imitate the behavior
and then you'll wonder where'd they get that
temper and it's from you because you're their
model so the ad-dib comes in those
next seven years and then he said ad
-dibuhum lisadrin befriend them for seven years because
this last stage is the stage of elm
now they're moving into the stage where they
need they need your guidance they need you
more shawara they need your counsel because you're
going to help direct them to learning to
what they're going to do with their education
those type of things that's a traditional model
any other?
it's interesting you know the word for elm
what's it mean in arabic?
I know but what's the root word though
what are akhlam when they said sappahu akhlamana
the intellect so really forbearance is a sign
of intellect why?
because you have your kuwala rabba biya under
control it's guided by your rational soul so
your akhal is working because the akhal is
it's an ikal, yaqiluhu the akhal is what
puts the irascible and the concupicent soul in
check it's an ikal for it akhal means
to prevent and that's what the rational mind
is supposed to do it's supposed to keep
the rabbab and the shahwa in check and
if it doesn't you're not akhal you're not
halim you're ahimar or whatever I mean that's
what they say if somebody gets really angry
you're ahimar you're like a donkey or something
like that why?
because he's acting like a beast he's not
acting like a human being and usually he's
a himar too because he's angry too but
the difference is we have a tahallam a
tahallam oh very good point I'm really glad
you brought that up because I didn't I
forgot to mention that ah that's a really
I'm really glad you brought that up there
is a hadith and this is really important
because some of us are going to say
my god I can't do any of this
it's all too hard and I'm a mess
and I get angry and I do this
and that and I eat too much chocolate
or whatever now the hadith says and I'm
glad that Abu Dhabi brought this up the
hadith says inna mal ilmo bita allam wa
inna mal ilmo bita allam knowledge is through
acquisition you acquire knowledge you're not born aalim
you become an aalim how did you do
it?
through effort mujahada right the aalim is the
one who's he struggles to learn he gets
up in the night he studies he reads
he goes to the darts he listens he
takes notes he studies he reviews all that
that's mujahada so you weren't born with that
knowledge it's something that you acquire him is
the same thing the hadith says wa inna
mal ilmo bita allam now what happens when
you become an aalim somebody who's an aalim
if you see an aalim what does it
appear to you?
you don't see that he was a student
it seems like they always had that right?
that's what it seemed you don't see when
they were doing all their studying and all
their work and all that the same with
the halim you don't see when he was
struggling with it you think it's like he
was born that way it's something you acquire
and that's what that's what that he acquired
it's aalim he didn't and then ta'alim
is from tafarud which is takalud you have
to work for it it's hard now really
important point imamah razali uses the metaphor of
a calligrapher he says what do you do
when you have a bad handwriting?
and this is a metaphor what do you
do when you're angry?
he said you go to somebody who has
an excellent hand and you watch him and
then you ask him to draw you the
letters and then you go home and you
keep doing the letters over and over again
and initially they're going to be lousy but
suddenly about a month or two months later
you start noticing there's an improvement but it's
still not mastery it's far from it but
it looks much better and somebody who's not
even started he'll say you have great handwriting
but if the master looks at it he
said this is terrible right?
because sayyatir abraar right?
hasanatir abraar sayyatir mukarabin you're moving up in
ranks now what happens when you become a
master?
you see them drawing like I watched Muhammed
Zakari I took a lesson in calligraphy from
him the first lesson I had and he
I watched him do it and I was
thinking I can do that well why I
thought that I said that looks so easy
right?
because he's a master he is a master
like he's an American master of calligraphy he
wins awards in Turkey and things but he's
I didn't see all those nights and years
that he was doing it now he just
makes it look like he was born writing
perfect calligraphy and then when I got the
pen and started doing it and it's like
jumping up and down really it was hard
he just flowed across the paper that's because
of mastery and so the same thing happened
now the really interesting thing about this so
what do you do when you want good
character?
you do three things one you learn what
it is you have to learn what bad
character is and what good character and that's
what we're doing here that's what we're doing
we're doing the first stage you have to
learn what good character is and you have
to learn what bad character is the second
stage is those who struggle for our sake
we will guide them to our path but
then you have to you have to have
you have to find people with good character
and you have to spend time with them
and there's another benefit in being with people
who get angry easily is to recognize how
unpleasant it is and this is why Imam
Shah once somebody asked him how did you
get such excellent character?
he said I listened to what my detractor
said about me and then I looked into
my soul to see if it was true
and when it was I struggled with myself
until I removed it Sadhna Isa was asked
by a man once how did you get
such excellent character?
and the prophets are born with it but
this is what the tradition says he said
I looked at the bad character of people
and I avoided it so part of it
is just is doing Mujahada but the third
stage is to be with the person who
has good character and you see good luck
it's difficult to find but we shouldn't ever
despair and at least we should be trying
I'll tell you this stuff it really works
I'm serious I'm nowhere where I'd like to
be but really it helped me a lot
to learn a lot of these things and
to just try and struggle with myself as
much as I can and hopefully you get
better and you improve and you do change
seriously I mean Khattab was a real serious
trouble for me for a long long time
and it's much less so now and part
of that is aging thank goodness Imam Sayyidina
Adi said that youth is a it's a
type of madness and the cure is to
get old so yeah anger
with the parents that's a root yeah then
you should be angry at the act not
at the actor in other words it should
upset you what's being done the action of
the person but if it's your father or
your mother you have to be really careful
if you're able to do then you should
Vannal-i-fada is the wudjoo is based
on Vannal-i-fada and not leading to
a worse fit man but the parents you
have to be really careful about it the
Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam a man came to
the Prophet and he said he said that
my father takes my money and it really
angers me and the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
he said you and your wealth belong to
your father in other words he was the
means by which you were given existence so
the parents really have a high maqam in
Islam it's just that's a given and the
best thing to do with the parents is
recognize that they're human beings they have their
limitations I had a teacher once who told
me he wasn't a Muslim he was a
very wise person who was a good teacher
and he said to me once that he
thanked his father because he taught him how
not to be a father and he said
he really did his father was so harsh
on him that he did the opposite with
his children and he said in the end
he realized that it was a gift that
his father gave him and he was genuine
in that he wasn't saying he was saying
I realize obviously and that's looking at the
good side of something obviously it would be
better if your father was a good example
and showed you how to be a father
not how to not be a father but
the idea is doing the worst situation and
making the best of it and that's a
gift and that's hikma woman yuta hikma fakatuthi
akhara kathira and that is hikma and that's
the beauty of Islam is that in any
situation it
can be beneficial for the moment so
inshaAllah we're actually believe it or not coming
to there's really not that many left and
in fact there's only four
more left after today inshaAllah so I think
we'll be able to finish next week all
the diseases and then go on to he's
got a few good sections one he has
a section called the cure for all of
the diseases of the heart like how to
cure them all one fell swoop the Gordian
knot right everybody know about the Gordian knot
the Gordian knot was a knot in Turkey
that it was huge and no nobody knew
they said whoever could would untie it would
rule the land and so people used to
try nobody could get it untied and when
Alexander the Great conquered them they showed him
the knot so he pulled out his sword
and he cut through it so that's the
best way the diseases are like that not
the best ways to get the sword just
cut right through it so that he has
that section and then we'll do what's called
the Hawaii which is about thoughts because obviously
one of the most obvious manifestations of the
diseases of the heart are diseased thoughts in
other words thought impure thoughts that afflict the
mind and also thoughts that one might think
are actually good thoughts but in fact are
from chef on because chef on that is
also one of the things that he does
they call him that would incent the hadith
says that he's like the wolf of the
man who comes to the sheep if he
finds the shepherd one place he comes from
another place so chef on he'll come one
way if it's not effective he'll try another
way which is one of the key differences
between chef on thoughts his how water and
the whole water of the nets because the
nature of the next how water are there
compulsive which is one of the things about
Ramadan we know that the shell pain Sufi
that the shell pain they get locked up
but yet still people have trouble and that's
where you begin to differentiate from chef on
and from Nafs Hawa and Dunya because those
are the four enemies of man chef on
Nafs Hawa and Dunya those four so the
next section is a ruffler what a ruffler
to the roof who don't know I'm not
a mora the hill Ilahua Naha and hood
warah a ruffler and this is a really
important concept because Imam and Junaid said that
this is the root disease and even though
we've heard different routes even a bad Ravi
Lana said it was and it see the
under why didn't answer said it's hubriasa and
procrastination and really procrastination is ruffler so I
think he would probably agree there because taswif
is a type of ruffler the reason you
procrastinate is because you're not really thinking about
the thing because if you really saw the
urgency of it you'd do it so ruffler
is a serious illness of the heart and
he calls it ruffle which is inattentiveness heedlessness
unaware the word in Arabic for a simpleton
everybody know what that is simpleton simpleton somebody
you can fool easily is muhafal somebody who's
taken unaware it's a passive form muhafal he's
taken unaware he's a simpleton he's easy to
trick and so ruffler the definition is it's
it's sehu and as you know sehu is
a very important part of the prayer suju
the sehu and that fact that that suju
the sehu is there and the prayer is
such a short time right and yet suju
the sehu is an essential element to knowing
how to pray because the nature of the
human being is forgetfulness so ruffler is a
type of forgetfulness and the word in Arabic
for human being an insan some say it
comes from unce which is intimacy because the
human being is a creature that needs unce
he needs to have intimacy he's not washi
he's not something that can live on his
own and some say it comes from nesiah
which means to forget and if you look
at the word insan insan is male and
female I mean some linguists say that insanatun
is a is a proper form insanatun fitanatun
there's a line of jihadi poetry that uses
insanatun but it's rare insan is dakar wa
untha al-atar al-insani hinum min ad
-dahri lem yakunshayana qura har-atar al-insani
al-ad-dakar wa untha al-human being
so it's a human being insan is human
being and in the Quran when an insan
is sometimes used for Adam alayhis salaam it
sometimes means Adam and the first the slip
of our father Adam alayhis salaam is nisyan
he was taken unaware by shaytan he was
taken unaware and so and that's why the
human being has to be vigilant he has
to have asim and so the the disease
rafla is seho it's a forgetfulness and it's
yahtariyat insan min kalat tahafod wa tayakod it
occurs to the human being as a result
of the absence of tahafod which is to
be vigilant what tayakod and to be awake
so when when Saydna Ali radi longu said
a nasu ni yam fa'idama to intebaho
people are asleep when they die they intebaho
intebah is the opposite of rafla in other
words the rafil when he suddenly becomes aware
you say intebah kud atani ala khaflatin they
came to me ala khafla when I was
unaware fantebah to and then I became aware
so when Saydna Ali said people are asleep
and when they die they wake up what
he meant is people are khafilun they're khafilun
they're in heedlessness about their destiny where they're
going and what they're going to have to
do when they get there you see because
they're going to have to be taken to
account and because of that if they really
really knew that with a wakefulness a yahkawa
they couldn't do the things they're doing that's
why imam aljunayat radi longu said this is
the core disease because if the human being
knew what was going to happen to him
there's no way he could do what he
was doing if he really was awake to
it now this is not that dissimilar to
the Socratic understanding because that's that that is
in this tradition as well in the in
the Western tradition of this idea of people
doing things because they they're really unaware if
they knew what it was right and the
metaphor that is given is the metaphor of
the cave right that human beings are like
people in a cave and there's a lamp
behind the cave and the and the lamp
is causing shadows and these people can't turn
around and they're looking at the shadows and
they think the shadow is like a real
image and they think that's reality and then
one of them gets away and he goes
out of the cave and sees the real
world the Sun and the stars and the
and the trees and he goes back into
the cave and tells them this is all
in the illusion you we thought this was
real this isn't real the real thing is
somewhere else and they they kill him and
that's like the prophets because the prophets come
and they tell people you're all asleep wake
up don't you realize what and so this
idea of raffa is really important and that's
why in the Quran Allah subhana wa ta
'ala uses the word in many verses and
another word that's used in the Quran is
Samid right Samid and Samid and
Samid is more like a raffa but there's
there's more of an awareness there in other
words the raffa he's unaware he really he's
in the raffa and Allah subhana wa ta
'ala in Surat al-Qamar says Kuntafi rafflatin
minhada you were in raffla about this yama
kiyama fa kashef na'anka a raffa fa
basura kal yama hadid we removed the veil
so there's a raffa over the human being
that's veiling them from understanding reality and Allah
says in the Quran that arab wa arab
sah to him rishawah there's a rishawah which
is similar to rippah rishawah and this rishawah
prevents them from seeing things as they truly
are and so a person who's raffa is
not seeing things as they truly are and
the person who's yuck then who's awake sees
things as they truly are and the prophets
Allah said allow me arini al ashya kama
hiya show me things as they really are
and then in the other hadid allahma arini
al hakka hakka show me hak as hak
wa zukni tibaa and give me the ability
to follow it wa arini al baatira baatira
and show me falsehood as falsehood wa zukni
istinaba and give me the ability to avoid
it so the one who's not raffa is
the one who's that's their state they see
truth as truth and falsehood as falsehood and
they follow truth and they avoid falsehood and
that's muttaki that's him that's a person of
takwa he does what Allah told him he
avoids what Allah told him not to do
and so he's saying that raffa is ruful
amara biil ilahul it's being heedless about what
Allah commanded you to do and what he
prohibited you from doing and that is why
people do wrong actions because they're heedless about
what they've been commanded to do and they're
heedless about what they've been prohibited from and
and so when you see somebody and this
is why if you see somebody and you
say who's doing something wrong you say a
takila if he's a muttman he's he's reminded
and he says astakhfir Allah because you've brought
him out of his raffla and that's a
good person the muttakabir because takabur is something
that Allah will remove and he goes to
that that's why kibir follows after you have
written but kibir is really is something that
I would have been that the person who
has kibir even if they're reminded of their
raffla they still won't they still won't accept
it they go into the state achadat humir
izzah they take izzah and they won't so
you say takila and they get angry at
you for reminding them who do you think
you are because they you know they can't
and that's why the raffla for a muttman
is something the cure for it is good
company sahbah be with people of sifq of
sincerity have takla but be with sincere people
truthful people that are going to tell you
if you're doing something wrong you're doing something
wrong and if you're doing something right they'll
encourage you and those are the people that
will get you out of your raffla so
one of the real cures for it is
being with good people and then he said
wahiyya ladehim asuru kulidambi those of this science
consider it to be the source of all
wrong actions like imam aljuna'id al-Baghdadi
wada'uhaal bi'arba'in dura'bi and
the cure is in four things and those
four things possess rectifying qualities faztakfirillah wazor wa
salbi aran nabi waktabu wathri so he gives
you the four things the first is istighfar
because once you realize that your raffil you
begin to realize what you've been doing wrong
as a result of your raffla and so
you want to ask forgiveness and so doing
istighfar and and the ulamas many of the
later scholars said that really istighfar and salah
al-nabi are the two they're the two
vicars of the last n days the last
period of time istighfar and salah al-nabi
so istighfar is to ask forgiveness of Allah
right asking forgiveness and that is a cure
for hafla because it's a toba asking forgiveness
istighfar and say that istighfar we already did
that and you should have that in the
section say that istighfar is is is one
of the best ways of doing that but
you should do the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
said that you should ask istighfar at least
70 times to a hundred times a day
as takfirillah so it's always a good thing
to do and it's a good thing to
do also a practice which most of the
early people did was called muhasaba and muhasaba
is using the idea of the merchant what
merchants do at the end of the day
is they do muhasaba in their in their
stores they count the money and they see
how much money they've made and or how
much they lost so they do a they
want to see what the scales say was
there loss or gain today and this idea
of muhasaba is that you look at your
day and you look was there loss with
Allah or gain if there was loss you
ask istighfar and if there was gain you
say alhamdulillah you're grateful to Allah because if
you land shakartum la zidinakum when you show
gratitude Allah increases you so that's one way
and he goes into shukar because that's one
of the mukhamat that we'll get to inshallah
now the other thing is to visit ziyara
ziyara ziyarat of salihin visiting
righteous people now the Salih the Salih you
have marathim with Allah the highest is the
Nivi Rasul and then the second is Siddiq
the third is shahid and the fourth is
Salih now really they're all Salih right they're
all Salih a shahidah has to be a
Salih the Siddiq has to be a Salih
and the Ambiya are all Salihin in their
nature Saluha in Arabic means to be sound
and this is related to Salama right soundness
wholeness the one who has a Qalb Salim
so Salih is somebody who's sound healthy they're
not diseased so their heart isn't diseased like
other peoples a Salih is the one the
definition of a Salih you add the haqala
will you add the haqala Ibad that's the
Salih he gives what's due to Allah and
he gives what's due to the slaves of
Allah that's a Salih so when you see
somebody who's a he has taqwa that's what's
due to Allah taqwa do what he command
you to do avoid what he prohibited from
doing that's that's haqala haqala Ibad are any
of those responsibilities that you have in the
world towards other people so the Salih cannot
cheat that's fasq because the opposite of Salih
is a fasq or a pala so the
Salih doesn't lie he doesn't cheat because haqala
Ibad to be truthful to them that's a
haq of people but they have a right
to be told the truth you can't lie
to them so the Salih is somebody should
be visited now most of the ulema not
only encourage visiting the Salihin who are alive
but also the Salihin who are dead and
that means that if you're for instance in
Medina you go to Bakhia and you visit
the Salihin of Bakhia and you and you
give them Salaam and Tarahama Alayhim and the
Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam used to visit Sayyidina
Hamza and he visited the the makbarah and
he said kuntu anhaakum aniziara fazuruhah I used
to tell you don't visit graves because of
the what the jahili Arabs used to do
with the graves but once they were purified
of all that jahiliya they were given permission
by the Prophet to visit the graves visiting
the graves there's a benefit in it and
the graves of the people of Salah there's
a greater benefit in it so there's a
benefit in visiting the the Salihin but the
the graves as a zikra of the akhara
but there's also a benefit in visiting the
people of Salah like the ulema and the
awliya these people I mean the awliya of
the ulema al-amidun so that that is
why traditionally now about women and graves there's
a hadith that the curse zawarat al-qobur
and in a riwaya za'irah and and
generally zawara is an isom wabaraga somebody who
visits graves often there's a hadith that's mutawakalay
in which the Prophet salah isalam passed by
the graveyard in Medina and there was a
woman there and she was weeping and the
Prophet salah isalam said that it's better to
be patient and she said ma osubtabi ma
osubtubi you didn't have the calamity that I
was given and she didn't recognize the Prophet
salah isalam and so he left her and
then somebody told her that was the messenger
of Allah and and she immediately went and
knocked on his door and then she said
I didn't know it was you and the
Prophet salah isalam said a subro and al
-mussiba and a submat al-ula that patience
is with the first subma right it's when
it first happened that's what patience is in
other words you're not patient later on because
that's just time the patience is when the
mussiba occurs that's when Allah expects you to
be patient you know if if after a
year you've gotten over it and then you
say oh mashaAllah he's salah that's not salah
that's just time to get on with your
life but for the sabr is when the
affliction occurs and that's where Allah wants to
see us with tabat with you know steadfast
and not being shaken in a way that
will do anything make us do something displeasing
to Allah subhana wa ta'ala but the
point of that hadith is that the Prophet
did not tell her to get out of
the graveyard and so that ulama take from
that that and there's a difference of opinion
there's a there is a khidaf about it
like in Arabia yeah see that's that's where
you realize the wisdom of not having women
visit the graves like in Egypt I haven't
been to Egypt but I've heard about it
in Egypt and this is the danger also
I want to really mention this there is
an adab to visiting graves in other words
what happens now in graves has nothing to
do with what he's talking about put to
some of the graves like a wahani farad
ilana or you go like in Pakistan they
have Baba Farid and and Imam al-Hajwiri
and a lot of the huh yeah a
lot of the these people who were great
people of Allah and they were ulama and
they would be the first to condemn what
people do tying knots women who can't get
pregnant going and asking the the wadi to
give them a son things like that all
of that stuff has nothing to do with
what he's talking about he's talking about visiting
with adab for the blessing of visiting the
it's a ziara that's what it is it's
a ziara and it's very different so you
have to really be able to the same
and that's what is given to solve a
bad name because a lot of people claim
that that is you know from the soul
and it's not has nothing to do with
the soul it's all bidda in fact that
really is bidda what happens so all these
women that sit around in muri adris many
of them they go there without hijab on
and and they chit chat all day long
and gossip and appear on kala and so
though that those are all problems and in
those cases oftentimes the strategy for the ulama
is actually to stop altogether just for sudden
but very something like that all right but
anyway the best is to see the people
who are alive no unfortunately in our time
this is quite rare now to really see
a salih and you have to often go
to reverse you know and go to really
difficult places just to get to one because
a lot of them have just fled to
places that are hard to get to so
somebody like marab dahmet fal who we visited
in I know hushba who's the father of
shahab dallah I mean I consider him nah
sibohum in a salihin that's my a tikhad
when we when we say visit the salihin
Allah says be with the truthful ones obviously
he wouldn't command us to do something if
there weren't those people and you couldn't recognize
them it would be foolish to think that
you can't recognize people of sit and salah
and there are obviously degrees and levels of
it so when when when we're being commanded
to be with people of sit you you
you just look and you should trust if
they're outwardly upright in their Sharia Sharia is
our criterion and we judge men by the
truth right we judge men by the truth
and one of the dangers in fact of
that I've noticed with people in in tasawwulf
a modern tasawwulf is that in many of
the Muslim countries there's people who go by
the name of pyrzab or shaykh or whatever
and a lot of these people they inherited
it from their father who inherited from his
father and many of them they're they don't
have they have very little knowledge sometimes almost
none and and oftentimes they use these positions
for wealthful gain like in order to extract
money from followers or marry their daughters and
I mean a lot of so what you'll
find is there's a lot of charlatans and
nothing worse than a religious charlatan nothing I
mean that's the bottom you don't I had
it there's a man in thess who some
people here know Sidious Ma'ib who said
to me once he said Allah has made
the world huge and he made the ways
of gaining halal provision without number there are
untold ways of gaining halal provision and he
said so anytime you see somebody who's using
the religion to gain dunya he said it's
that's a bad thing that's a bad thing
if they're using it to a mass wealth
to do these things then and unfortunately there's
a lot of people that do that who
claim to be like share or Sufi share
something like that no
I mean
that's a different thing I mean people have
to have livelihood and and hey room out
without a jerk eat up a lot had
these football hurry the best thing a man
can earn wealth from his teaching the book
of Allah which is why that's where the
ulama took a that it's permissible to teach
and and even though the early sell-off
were generally opposed to it the later ulama
recognized that people have to have livelihood and
the world has become more complicated things like
that so you people have to have livelihood
that's not the point the point is a
massing wealth yeah in other words using it
as a way of a massing accumulating wealth
and now imamatica radilano he was given massive
amounts of wealth because of who he was
he what he did was spend out and
more up the Hajj is a really good
example of that he gets money from all
over it just goes out he's just like
he doesn't nothing he doesn't have I mean
you can see he's got a few cows
and a tent and an adobe house and
a few robes and and books and that's
it and he just giving out all the
time so he gets money but it goes
right out and people give him money because
people if they see people that are righteous
they trust them with their money and Muslims
are generous who are practicing Islam so they
want to give their money things like that
that's another thing right so it's not saying
the point is if it's when that is
hoarding it accumulating it that there's not a
kind of right when your needs are taken
care of and right and and so you
begin to hoard things like that that that's
what that's the trouble so you have to
be really careful because it's an age and
it's been that way for a long time
see the elements are all complained about it
he said in his time most of the
people so quote-unquote Sufi shares he said
we're complete charlatans and that was ninth century
and so it's a bad time and this
man himself was a share but he was
genuine share you know he had he was
a morab they call them morab on people
of Tarbia that do but he was also
an outward scholar and that is a condition
of anybody that does Tarbia is they have
to have outward knowledge right they can't they
can't not have outward knowledge and and unfortunately
a lot of people also I mean now
in the Muslim world you have this real
there's there's such a split now between Tassowulf
and you know exoteric Islam esoteric Islam inward
and outward aspects of Islam and they're like
two camps that are pitched against each other
and and nowhere does it play out more
than than on the Arabian Peninsula right where
where you've got the Nejdi's and the Hijazis
and most of the Nejdi's are staunch anti
Sufi and many of the Hijazis are very
pro-Moulid Tassowulf type thing and they're just
at loggerheads they hate each other and you
know I think unfortunately we're out of balance
as an ummah and and the truth lies
somewhere in between right so you
you should make du'a for them you
know and and ask to benefit from their
knowledges one of the Ahmad Baba Timbukti who's
great scholar from Timbuktu who was actually taken
as a slave to Morocco and and when
he got to Morocco he was he was
so much more learned than any of the
scholars in Marrakech that they realized that they'd
made a grave mistake but he mentions in
his book he wrote a book Dibaj and
Muvahab he did a hashia on Ibn Farhan's
book of Babakat and he mentions going to
several of the graves of the righteous in
Marrakech and one of the one of the
graves he asked that Allah gave him understanding
of two books that he wrote and he
said that by Allah he went back and
the books he could read them without any
difficulty and he was a great scholar so
that was traditionally you know to ask for
the benefits of their knowledges because most of
those people were scholars and things like that
and Tarahum that Allah give them noor in
their grave and bless them Qadi al-Baqarah
bin al-Arabi who's just outside of fast
and gave fatwa of visiting the graves of
the Salihin and same with Ibn al-Hajj
and if people say that it's a bit
that's just you know it's not consistent with
the vast majority of our scholars the vast
majority of them have not only permitted it
but recommended it and and those are outward
scholars you know fiqh that are well known
in the tradition so Qadi al-Baqarah his
grave is well known outside of fez he
was poisoned by the Mujahideen and died there
a shahid and he also fought jihad several
times he wrote two commentaries on the Quran
he brought the Ahiyat al-Umedeen from Imam
al-Ghazadi he studied with him the Ahiyyah
and actually brought it to Morocco and Ambrusiah
and just a great scholar there and anybody
who's been to that place you know there's
just there's a lot of barakah there in
Shabbat so but the living the people who
are living if you have an opportunity to
to visit them and also if you should
have high himma and in other words you
should desire to be one so that our
ummah has people that you can visit right
we need these people so you know you
should make the intention to be one yourself
inshallah and that Allah give you Tofiqh and
give all of us Tofiqh to do that
one of the poet's he said idama al
-mar'o idama al-mar'o ram al
-ulah if a man does not gain heights
if he has not achieved heights at least
he aspires the heights wal-maniqna al-vidouni
qana douna and whoever's content with less than
heights he's less than heights in other words
that's that's an indication that he's he's he's
a lowly person that he doesn't even aspire
to heights and the greatest aspiration is to
be close to Allah so if you have
if you're in the dunya have a high
himma and Sidi ibn al-Qa'ilah said
if you don't think Allah can take you
in this moment and make you one of
his awliyat then you don't know anything about
his qudra so you should never have despair
have yes you should want to be from
the people of wila'a and the people
who are close to Allah subhanahu wa ta
'ala so zi'ara is important if you're
able to visit these people you visit them
and when you visit them one the people
of this who I visited they don't chit
chat they're not people that you go to
you know how you doing in house you
go for the benefit of learning something and
also the benefit of their du'a and
you should ask them for their du'a
because their du'a might be accepted and
if it is then you get the benefit
of that so you visit them you ask
them for the du'a and you show
humility with them humbleness don't be arrogant and
I'll tell you something about Mullah Ramadan who
was from the Saudi Hain and he was
the father of Shaykh Saeed Ramadan at Boteh
and Shaykh Saeed wrote a book Hada Wa
Adidi this is my father and he's told
about what a great man his father was
but I once asked dr.
Booker who's a Libyan about him and he
told me and you can confirm this he's
in New Jersey I think he told me
I asked him he said he met Munda
Ramadan and I wanted to know because it's
always good to hear stories of these people
because it strengthens your Iman and he told
me SubhanAllah the amazing thing about visiting that
man he said I've always hated kissing hands
and he said and he says just something
I never really bothered me that whole idea
of kissing people's hands he said I went
in there and he said he put out
his hand and he said I felt pressure
on my head and I went down and
I found myself kissing his hand and he
said I looked back and there was nothing
there and he just said that he was
compelled to kiss his hand you know and
he was a man of Allah Shaykh, Shaykh
Munda Ramadan he really was he was a
man of Allah so those people they're they're
worth visiting and fortunately there's they still exist
you know you can find them in and
there's there's some women that like I've met
Marathar Hajj's wife Maryam is definitely I consider
her from the salihat to Zar and even
their servant Gabula people go when they visit
Marathar Hajj they visit his wife and then
they go visit the servant Gabula and ask
her to make du'a for them and
there's a woman there Aisha Bint Minni also
who's very righteous woman and a scholar she's
a Alima Fatima Bint Nofal who's in who's
in Dhar Al Bayadah I mean there's good
people alhamdulillah so if you get an opportunity
you visit them and with that at Tikhad
you know and Allah knows they're stationed we're
only it's a belief and we can't like
when we were looking at the seerah earlier
about Khaulah the wife of of Ithman ibn
Midr'un when she said you know he's
in Jannah the Prophet got angry so we
don't say they're awliya with jazim we believe
that they're people of widayah but we can't
say he's a wali and make a halaf
and walahi in hula wali wain nami kun
wali fa'ana kaitoor kaitoor that that's up
to Allah but we were commanded to observe
the outward and then he says Salih al
-nibi pray on the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam
so prayer on the Prophet the third one
is prayer on the Prophet of Salah al
-nibi what they call in Pakistan darud no
darud they call that yeah they don't call
that in Arabic yeah they just say a
salah al-nibi but I mean it's interesting
that their language has a word for it
right that's a good sign right so Allah
commanded us to do that right he began
with himself and then he said the angels
and then also when the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi
Wasallam he said how much of my vicar
should I make prayer on you and and
he said a fourth and he said that's
good and if you increase it's better he
said half he said that's good and if
you increase it's better he said three fourths
that's good if you increase it's better and
then he said I'm going to make all
my vicar prayer on you and the Prophet
said if you did that it's good Imam
al-Jazuli took permission from that for people
that feel compelled to that that becomes their
devotional practice that they do prayer on the
Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam and there are people
that do that that's all they do and
if you and I've met some of those
people and they they're amazing people they really
are they're always happy they always smile and
they're really nice to be around and I
guarantee you that is a quality of people
that do a lot of prayer on the
Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam they're happy they're not
miserable people so there's a great light in
prayer on the Prophet there's a great blessing
and and it shouldn't be underestimated Sidi Ahmad
Zarrouk said if you don't have a murabhi
then the prayer acts as a murabhi in
other words it prayer on the Prophet will
purify your nafs so just doing prayer on
the Prophet and he recommends at least 500
times a day Shaykh Uthman Tanfodio he used
to do 5,000 a day and he
did that for several years and he saw
the Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam envisions many many
times Imam Marik Radilano was always doing prayer
on the Prophet and Muhadithun are famous for
that because every time they would recite a
hadith, write a hadith
They would pray on the Prophet .
And Imam Madak said that he never slept ever a night except that he saw the Prophet .
So there's a great blessing in it and people show that.
And then another thing is Tilawat al-Qur'an.
The fourth thing is recitation of Qur'an and preferably with Tadabur.
Reciting it with Tadabur awakens up the heart.
It's one of the things that will wake the heart up.
Tadabur is reflection.
Doing it, pondering the meanings, not just reading it.
But even reciting it is good.
So Tirawatir Qur'an, you should have a word of Qur'an every day.
You should do, you know, hopefully at least like a hiz or a juz a day.
You should try to do that every day.
If you can't do that, then at least do the SUARK that Allah's messenger recommended that we do.
YASEEN ...
...
after Aisha.
YASEEN generally after Fajr, ...
after Maghrib and Mulk after Aisha.
Well, if you haven't learned Arabic, reading the meanings in English, I mean, that's something I think it's limited because part of this, and this is the honest truth, part of this is the actual sounds of the language.
In other words, it's like medicine.
If you look at medicine, if you look at medicine from an energetic perspective,
Every substance in the world has a resonance, right?
It's resonating at a specific wavelength.
And so medicines are like that, just like diseases are.
So a disease is resonating, and a medicine, if it cures it,
It's resonating in a way that cures that disease.
And the thing about the recitation of Quran is actually the sounds that are emanating from you.
And when we speak, we know now in material science that it's resonating in every cell in your body.
Sound waves.
So when you're reciting the Quran these are divine words that Allah has revealed and they have a sound.
I mean I was once with a man
in a gas station.
And he was asking about Islam.
And he came, there was a mechanics of Muslim and I was there and I had a robe on and he started asking me about Islam.
And then he said that he'd read the Quran.
And I said, You have never read the Quran unless you read it in Arabic.
And he said, No, I can't believe that.
And I said, Well, it's a fact.
And then he said, Why is that?
And I said, Just listen.
And I recited to him the first section of Surat al-Rahman, and Wallah al-ladila ilaha illallah.
When I finished that, he just said, I understand now.
And he wasn't joking, you know.
There's...
people are often amazed, Ajami people, when they hear the Quran who are not Muslims, they're amazed at the sounds.
Really, they're amazed at the sounds.
So the Qur'an, you have to recognize that it's not just the meanings, it's actually the sounds that transcend, that are part of the meaning in a realm we don't even understand, because everything's meaning in reality.
I mean, Allah takes meaning down to the phonemes in the Qur'an .
In modern linguistics, phonemes are meaningless.
They become meaningful when they become connected and polysyllabic.
Right?
Somebody said about Dr.
Hamid Algar, they wrote a really nasty thing about a speech he gave and said it was filled with polysyllabic sentences.
And Hamid pointed out in his rebuttal that a sentence that's not polysyllabic is meaningless.
So, the phoneme, like
Those are phonemes.
Those have meaning even in Arabic.
But we don't know their meaning.
So everything's meaning, the whole thing all the way down.
So those are the four that he gives.
Now, another thing, Allah mentions that
Allah warns the Prophet of sitting with people right ...
those we have we have put their heart into a state of heedlessness now this Allah clarifies in the Quran when they deviated Allah caused them to deviate more
And so people who turn away from the truth, Allah puts them in a state of Ghafla.
And so Ghafla is actually a punishment.
And so a Muslim who's in Ghafla is actually, it's a result of his disobedience with Allah .
So Ghafla is a bad thing.
You don't want to be from the Ghafideen.
And all of us,
I mean this is just reality.
All of us are going to go into Rafla and out of Rafla.
This is part of being on just in this realm and on the earth.
Rafla ends the moment you die.
But what you want to be is to be more in a state of wakefulness than in a state of heedlessness in your life.
So you want to be
in a state where you're not in ghafla.
And that's why Sayyidina Omar said, Ahdalu dhikrila and ahududila.
The best remembrance of Allah is when you get to a limit that Allah has placed.
In other words when you're about to drink the wine, none of you are, but when you're about to drink it you remember
I'm putting fire into my stomach and then you that's the best dhikr of Allah when when the masiyya when you want the masiyya that you remember Allah and it becomes a zajir or a maneh a rada it it prevents you from doing the Haram that is what he's saying so there's degrees of ghafla and what he's saying is the disease is the one that prevents you from doing what Allah has told you and avoiding what he's prohibited to you
Other than that, it's Mustahab to be remembering Allah.
So, Allah has made remembrance at certain times of the day.
He didn't tell you to always remember Allah throughout the day as a Wajib.
Because not everybody is capable of doing that.
He said, Remember me in Awqat Mu'ayyana, just in certain times.
Right?
But, he encourages us, ...
Make much remembrance of Allah.
And that's for , it's , it's not .
So the more remembrance you do of Allah, the less like you are to fall into , when you don't want to.
But what he's telling us is the disease of the heart is the one that prevents you from fulfilling your obligations or avoiding what's been prohibited.
Alright?
and the opposite of those people are those who Allah that Allah wrote in their hearts Eman because one of the meanings of is not to put the diacritical marks and the vowelings in a book
right that's one of the meanings of it to to so that IMAN that Allah writes in the heart now the next disease is GHIL is a disease of the heart that is related to rancor anger it's it's it's resentful malice and Ghil
comes from a root word which is it's a what they call a Thulathi it can go three ways Ghul, Ghal and Ghil all three ways the Ghal or the Ghul is a Qaed right Ahlal people are there's a Ahlal that binds you and that's that's the what's called a Ghul and Ahlal like Liya the Ankha Anhum Israhum well Ahlal
to the Prophet was sent to remove difficulty for them and those things binding them holding them back so that's that's what the the is and is is when the heart is bound to treachery so the heart it becomes there's like a on it that's binding it to to treachery to somebody or malice towards them and or
to betray them or to trick them.
And then he tells you what the thing that's holding it together.
So the qaid is being held together just like you have like on a handcuff, you have the things that hold it together.
The ghul, the thing that's holding the ghil together is .
And is resentful malice.
It's something that results
from being angry at a person and holding that anger in the heart and then that anger becomes foul until it causes you to actually desire harm towards that person and and this is why one of the things Allah says uh in the Quran don't put in our hearts for people who have so you don't want to have in your in your heart for anybody who's a
Because it'll kill your heart.
It'll kill it.
And another thing, even though, one of the things Allah does in Jannah is He removes Ghil completely.
So, in other words, Momens will die with Ghil, but you don't want to have it.
But Allah says in the Qur'an, Wana Za'na, Ma'fiy Sudhuriyim Min Ghil then.
and he makes them Ikhwan and Al-Araik you know they're brothers sitting together so in the Dunya and Sayyidina Ali one man who had fought him at the battle of I don't it might have been at Jamal Arkat al-Jamal he came and he apologized to him and that and that's the ayah that Sayyidina Ali recited him We removed from their hearts
So he was saying, you know, that alhamdulillah, Allah will take that ghil out of the heart.
So you can have rancor towards a person and Allah can remove it.
So you should ask Allah to remove that ghil.
Now he says here how to do it.
Ahsan ilayhi Show good to that person.
So that's what that man did when he went to Sayyidina Ali.
He was the humble, he went and he apologized to him.
And that's Ihsan to him.
So if you have Ghil towards a Momman you should do good to him.
Ahsan Ilayhi.
And the nature of Ihsan...
Jubbiyatul Qulub Ala Hubbiman Ahsan Ilayha.
It's a hadith.
By nature the hearts are naturally inclined to loving those who do good to them.
Allah has made that a natural inclination of the heart in spite of a person.
If you do good to a person, Allah has made his heart naturally inclined towards you.
Right?
Now some of the Arabs, like the Arab poet, he said, ...
that when you're good to a noble person you'll possess him or own him.
And if you're good to a low person
it makes him even more rebellious.
He gets more angry.
So there are people at ...
But you've done your job.
In other words, if you do good to a person to cure your heart, that's what Allah is asking of us.
That we do our best.
If somebody else is not responsive to that, you've done what you've done to try to do it.
And then you're left to make dua for people and to ask Allah.
And really remember that Allah can forgive them.
Now,
he says you will cause your enemies from Shaytan and his minions who love Ghil between mu'mans Shaytan loves he loves to do this he loves to get the believers fighting each other and that's why I asked the Shaykh once why is it that
so many of the Kufar they live peacefully together and there's no problems and the Muslims you see good Muslims they come he said because Shaitan not occupied with them anymore their Kufar has he's not really he just lets them they're fine they're in Kufar but he said he's very obsessed with the people of Iman so he's always working on them to stray and that's why Shaitan
Shaitaan has despaired from being worshipped on the Arabian Peninsula but Tahrish Beynakum he has not despaired of causing Fitnah dissension amongst you so we have to be vigilant against him and Tuqnitoh when that Ghil begins to emerge in the heart the way you cause Shaitaan to despair is to reject the Ghil and to do good to that person when you want to do harm to them alright
and then remember what came in the Sahih Hadith about the Mondays and Thursdays because in the Sahih Hadith according to the Hadith the Prophet says that Allah forgives people on Mondays and Thursdays and when the angels come they say there's two people here that are fighting they're Mu'mins
And Allah says, Then leave them ...
Leave them until they rectify amongst themselves.
So what he's saying is, if you have ghil towards a mu'man, Allah's not forgiving you.
You see, if you're in a war with another Muslim, Allah's not forgiving you.
Now all you have to do is ...
with sincerity.
That's all you have to do.
Don't turn your back on them.
Don't just say Assalam Alaykum.
If they don't reply to you, you've done your obligation.
Then it's in their court, so to speak.
So, you just do what you can do.
That's all.
...
But that is a frightening Hadith.
You don't want to have animosity towards another believer because it'll prevent you from getting forgiveness from Allah .